No, no, not another loop.
That's just bait.
It's not another loop.
Oh, you guys can sort of see what night I chose today.
I'm actually stuck between three nights, but I'll show you guys.
All right.
Sorry, I'm eating my Oreo cheesecake.
Get pee.
I went into errands today and went to the post office.
Also, I'm really tilted about the new laws about sending things to the United States of America.
So for those who live outside of America, fuck us to send shit to the States.
So now you guys sort of realize why?
Because I heard like, also fuck you guys too.
You guys got fucked as well.
Because you guys can't receive like a lot of stuff now outside of the States.
Because I heard that Japan Post suspended all shipment to America.
And now I know why it's so tedious.
Okay, so what I have to do is that there's a new law about tariffs.
And it's basically like how you can't...
There used to be a law where if it's under $800, you don't have to worry about getting tariffs and stuff.
Or like customs and everything.
So basically, the new law for Canadians to ship to America is we have to download a fucking...
app and we have to fill because like originally we have to fill a customs forum originally and and that's it like I just fill a custom forum I get the I get the QR code and then I hand it over to the post office now you have to also download a specialized app just to ship to America it's just it's dedicated to any American parcels,
any American package.
And, um, and I have to fill out, like, I have to, like, make an account.
And then I have to declare all the stuff I want to declare.
Um, I know, I was like, why does it have to be an app?
Why can't it just be on a website?
Like, it's so, it's so fucking annoying.
I'm like, why can't I just do this on the website?
So, but it has to be download a
it and then we have to fill out like the custom forms and because like we have to prepay if it's over a certain amount of money for customs we have to prepay the customs before we ship it out so but then i fill it all out and they're like oh you don't have to prepay anything anyway here's your id code because you have you can ship anything into the states if you don't do this app it's because like they actually turn you away because i didn't realize this because it was
so i went to the post office because you know i shipped stuff to america because i was shipping some important things to the states um and um and uh i went over the post office like did you do the app and it was about to close because you know i love procrastinating and it was about to close and they're like oh did you do the app we have a new thing on the 29th now and then i was like oh what and they're like yeah you have to download this app oh but i don't know you have time to fill it up because we're closing in 10 minutes.
I was like, oh.
So I had to, and I couldn't do it.
And I'm like, sorry.
Maybe you can ship it like next tomorrow.
And then I waited until Monday.
And then I realized Monday is Labor Day.
And I was like, and I took all my packages on Monday.
And then the post office was closed.
And I had to come, and then I had to turn around.
And go back today.
So basically I went back today to the post office because I forgot yesterday was Labor Day because I don't pay attention to anything around me anymore.
If it's not about me, I don't care.
No, I'm joking.
I'm joking.
Anyway.
So yeah, it was very annoying because we had to fill...
We basically have to fill out three separate forms now to ship anything to America because of like a terror situation.
But it's very inconvenient to me the fact if I didn't have to download an app it would have been fine the fact I didn't download a separate app like make it if you okay I'm just gonna say just streamline it like put it on the website just streamline it like what if I'm doing everything on a website I don't want to do everything on my fucking the worst part of doing anything on the phone is just the cop like don't I don't have my I don't have that ctrl C and ctrl V that's the most annoying part You know how annoying it is to highlight an address on your fucking phone and then like like then hold it and then control V and it could It's just so annoying.
I'd rather just use my mouse and control C and control V.
It's much more like it's much more easier Like it's my first world problem.
It really is.
No, it's just a highlighting part.
It's so annoying something before you control c control v on the phone it's very inconvenient and what if i have numerous tabs it's like it's more annoying swapping between tabs on a phone than it is on them than it is on the pc um anyway so i had to do that and um and uh no wonder there was a store there was a store um the small business i for those who watch my members i was i was talking about this like small business that I really like that sell like handmade clay charms and then literally on the top of their website it's like we don't ship to US anymore I guess it's so inconvenient she was like this is too inconvenient like we don't ship to the US anymore now I know why I was like yeah I live in Canada.
Also, dad update.
Dad update.
Today, he was, I don't know.
Like, I guess every, okay, ever since he got, like, he's been very bratty lately.
He's been incredibly bratty because, I don't know, the more, the, the, like, you know, he's, like, beat death, like, twice.
You know, he...
He survived twice, so now he's like, nothing can stop me.
So, you know, okay, every morning I give him a little treat, and it's like those dental treats, the green bones thing, because I'm, like, really worried about his dental lately.
Because the vets have warned me about it.
Like, oh, there's a little bit of tar on his, like, on his teeth.
And I was, like, asking for advice, and my friends were like, oh, yeah, if you give him these, like, the greenies, um you don't have to worry about uh you don't have to like really worry about dental problems um so you know um it's more so of like you know it's like a little tree for him in the morning and now now he knows it's a routine so he's been like like if after I feed him and I was like okay sleep time and then he like wakes me up like two to three hours later and he stands next to the bag of greenies and he's like bitch where's my treat
where's my treat in the morning bitch like I demand my treat and I'm like what the this is like a this was like an extra bonus like and he's just like get out of the bed and give me that treat woman and it's just like you give What?
I just give it to him in the morning so he doesn't, so he won't have his fucking teeth pulled out.
Like, classy.
And then, like, today, um, yeah, today, when I was walking dad today, um, we were, there was a dog from across the street, and he was, the dog was just staring at him, like, staring at dad, and, like, dad did not like that.
Like the other dog from across the street was literally just sitting there staring at dad and then dad's we were just waiting for the Waiting at the crossroads for the light to turn green to walk or white I guess because like in Canada, it's white and not green for some reason and
So he was just like looking at him looking at my dog and my dog like dad noticed it and he like stared back But then dad got like super antsy and And he was like, he was like, he started barking.
He was like, what are you looking at?
What are you looking at?
Why are you looking at me like that, huh?
The other dog, he didn't fucking care.
He just kept looking at my dog.
Like, zero reaction.
It's zero reaction.
And then dad just kept barking at him from across the street because he just didn't like it.
He just didn't like how he just kept staring at him.
Like, are you staring at me, pun?
Yeah, that's fucking right.
And then the other dog just didn't care.
He was just standing there.
He was just sitting, like, not even standing.
He was just sitting there looking at my dog.
And, like, he had zero reaction when Dad just kept barking back.
Like,
I'm just chilling.
Um, yeah.
Also, honey, honey, dragon, oh, and then you have a super chat.
Then you hit, as American, I'm a little lost.
This will affect the new merch.
Nope, because...
merch is handled by gamer subs um and gamer subs is located in america so do not worry um it doesn't affect us um because um all the merch is already in america so you guys are fine so you guys can still buy merch and it doesn't it doesn't in effect
it doesn't affect like if you're outside america or if you're in america it doesn't affect us so we're fine um gamer subs already handled all of it like because they were like anticipating like what if terrorists get worse so um the terrorist situation gets worse so they all they all like anticipated it so you guys are okay for now um for now okay i i don't want to get like political but for those who looked at twitter it's actually pretty funny right now what's going on on twitter
on right now and the pizza thing the pizza like everyone's just like refreshing the pizza counter right now okay anyway anyway um i just like the memes so anyway i have several i have several skins to choose from um for those who don't know this guy it's So you know the praise the sun guy.
This is him.
He's a praise the sun man
So like you know Holland that is the dark souls of Metrovania So we have and I almost started the game All right, so it was very difficult between Rick and from Rick and Morty, or Soler from Dark Souls, or...
No, okay, it's not bad, please, no.
We're gonna, you guys have to be, you have to leave.
You have to have a certain IQ to understand Rick and Morty.
Do you know Soler from, yeah, I know it from the, I know Soler from the famous crow dance.
What was it?
Oh, I can't remember the term.
Right now, but it's my one of my favorite videos for praise the sun and he dances with a crow That's literally how I that's the only reason why I know so there Uh, wait, let me see I can find them Praise the sun Here you go Wait, where is it?
Crow Oh my god, where's that video?
That's actually one of my favorite videos There you go
That was literally...
That's one of my favorite animations.
I love this animation.
But that's the only reason why I know Saler.
Bum, bum, bum.
Take on me.
Oh, my God.
Did I crash?
Take me on.
Take on me.
I'll be.
That's the only reason why I know it's so there.
Or, or we be a grub.
Okay, this guy's cute, though.
Wee.
Okay, not gonna lie.
This guy's pretty.
Wee!
I gotta save brothers!
I gotta save my brothers!
Oh, shit!
Okay, wait, I don't wanna...
Oh, wait, completion.
Okay, I don't know where I am.
Crew of gaming.
Am I a little delay?
Am I?
I don't know.
Everything seems fine.
Okay, guys, look at that.
All right, guys.
Grub.
Wait, I want...
All right, I'll have a pull.
I'll have a pull.
It was very hard.
I didn't know which one to pick.
All right, we'll make a pull, though.
Pull.
Okay.
Skin.
Uh, grub.
Okay.
I can't even spell grub.
Grub.
And it's not even sun.
Or...
Rick.
Here we go.
Grub, son, or Rick?
Oh, Grub is what- I think it's the spin.
I think everyone just loves spinning.
Got a Grub's life.
You already know we want...
Spin!
What does it look like for the dash, anyway?
Where the fuck am I?
I don't even know where I am.
Oh my god.
Who the fuck is shit?
Oh, it's the guy that stole me here.
I was like, what the fuck was that?
All right.
I think rub one.
I was like, holy shit.
I got a stalker.
Bad touch.
Oh my god.
Get this man away from me.
all right oh i'm at the boss arena okay all right we're we're just a little guy we gotta find yeah he's gonna connect we gotta find him okay so i have i have the the steam guide for what i have to do so i have to go to the queen's there or the queen's garden oh my god sorry
the grub has guys you don't understand the grub has no fingers the grub so he calls his friend john hollow knight to help out look the oh my god forgot that there's no map okay we gotta go back to the bench all right he has no fingers so uh so so john hollow knight shows up to hold out a map for him all right let's go fix this we don't need steady body we don't need a mark of pride we need a compass because i'm lost as fuck right now and what was oh wait maybe it was steady i don't remember did we have steady body swarm and then what else do we have i guess we'll put this on first um oh how to change skin it's a mod that's basically how it was okay we don't need any of this actually wait what's this steady okay we got steady body on um i legitimately don't even remember like our stuff for this what we put on all right we gotta go to queen we speed
all right uh we don't have queen's garden are they going to get there through the fog canyon Oh, wait, wait, no, we need the...
Okay, we need to go to the green path because we gotta unlock the last path, like, the last magic.
Okay, give me a sec.
I gotta figure out how to get there.
Okay.
That's so creepy.
Like, this guy wants to fucking kidnap me.
Okay, we gotta go to the green path.
Yeah, we don't have the last power up because I didn't care.
Alright.
We actually...
the game without the last power up?
Alright.
No, it's the green...
Isn't the...
The last power up in the green path?
Oh.
The last one is close.
I don't even remember, to be fair.
I read the guide, but I wasn't really paying it.
Ah!
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Let me eat my grass real quick.
That was so close.
I forgot these guys exploded.
okay the last one where i power up into the sky that one we're like you know the one where i i look up oh yeah i gotta collect i gotta meet my dad give me a sec father oh wait no my foster care dad father can i got my allowance please yay allowance yay Yay!
Yay!
Look at that!
I'm collecting my allowance!
Oh wait, I got it.
What's this?
I got the website.
Nice.
Yay!
Hello, brothers!
Hello!
Hello, daddy!
Hello, hello!
Oh my god, that's raining money!
Thank you, father!
I got another egg.
What is it?
Whoa, whoa!
Hello, hello, daddy.
Alright, got all my money.
Hello, brothers.
Yay!
Hi, brothers!
Alright.
Okay, there you go.
Average Grammarians visit.
Okay, so the last power-up is in...
Where is it?
Is it...
Is it in Queen Station?
I don't want to pull up my guide right now.
I'm lazy how do you have no help um excuse you I beat a game with no health I don't need HP okay we gotta go this way oh I forgot that existed okay nice I had a feeling that helps me too um yum yum yum yum I eat my greens that he says I got I'm eating my green.
So I want to grow up to be a big grub.
Yeah, HP.
Just don't get hit.
You don't need HP if you just don't get hit.
Okay, down here.
Alright.
Okay, I don't need that yet.
Where is it?
It's to our left, right?
Okay, it's to our far left.
All right, I gotta figure this out.
Wee.
Okay, far left.
So this way?
Wait, what's over here?
Oh, I never been here before.
Oh, shit!
All right, that's a lot.
Okay.
I didn't realize what's over there.
Uh...
Let me think a little.
bit.
Okay, I think, yeah, alright.
I don't know, they've been here before.
So I don't know what's over here.
Whoa.
Oh, I'm a little scared.
Not gonna lie, but... Whoa.
Okay.
Ow!
Oh, oh!
Okay, I was worried that I was gonna get hit by that.
Wee!
Ah!
I'm okay.
Wait, there was...
Wait, this was nothing.
Wait.
Ow.
Okay, wait, what's the point of being here?
Wait, what the fuck was...
What?
What's the point of being here?
Oh, for this.
What's this?
I got a charm.
Oh, yay!
Yippee!
I got a charm notch!
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Okay, that's the point of...
Ah!
I'm okay.
I'm a big, strong grub.
It's okay.
I'm a very strong grub.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
I'm gonna grow up to be a big, strong grub too someday.
Okay.
This way.
Yippee!
Alright.
I'm about to go next.
Okay, we just go forward.
I'll just swim in the acid.
It should be five.
And then I'll grab this.
Uh...
Who's this guy?
Trained.
Oh my god, who trained you?
Can I have their number?
Alright.
Tired.
All right.
Grab this.
Just...
Okay.
I'm gonna...
Okay, I'm full HP.
I can't tell if I'm full HP.
It doesn't tell me when I'm lost HP.
Which is pretty bad.
It's pretty bad that this mod just tell me how much HP I have.
I'm so cute, though.
Look at me swim.
Look at how cute I am.
I'm swimming.
Yes, we are a grub today.
My popular boat.
Oh, whoops.
It's fine.
Yeah, it's not buggy.
It's just that they didn't draw everything for the mine.
So, like, they didn't...
I guess they gave up.
It's not that...
necessarily buggy.
It's just that they just were like grubs don't hold maps.
It's against my grub lore.
It's here, right?
Oh, it's a bug, but...
Kill it.
Oh, wow, it feels like a nerf.
What do you mean?
You can't win the game at a grub and you ain't gaming i'm just gonna swim fuck this why parkour when i can just swim all right is it here is this where i get the power up oh yeah grub cat hit up either apparently grub can only hit left or right wait what is what is uh what's up top though Go up.
That's gonna say, what is on top?
Oh, is this where the power-up is?
Oh!
I'll grab.
I'll kill these guys just for the sake of it.
Alright, this is the power-up.
At least these guys are, like, super weak, which is nice.
Alright.
Oh, is it up?
Oh, it's up, isn't it?
Also, like, everything seems very doable, except for the part about the parkour for the true ending.
That's the only thing that I feel like I'm going to spend the most time on.
And apparently, I have to, I'm going to have to get, like, a regen or some shit.
Everything seems very, very doable, except for the parkour.
part oh wait i gotta cut this part off so i can get the shortcut shortcut oh there it is so i need to get like a regen thing to do the parkour
oh it's up okay okay i can't apparently grub doesn't know how to do that either
look I'm the grub is called is just calling for extra help okay it's called a friend and the friend is John Hollow Knight he's
just great he grub don't know Matt exactly grub don't know magic he has to call a friend grub can only walk exactly grub walk John Hollow Knight do rest
We'll do the rest what's over here though.
I don't know what's over here
Oh, is this queen?
Oh, it is it's the queen's garden.
I don't have map for this area though
Jesus, okay, this guy's annoying I have to kill him all right.
Yeah, it goes against grub lore
Okay, at least he can't do that.
Am I full HP yet?
No Oh, I should get rid of him, too.
God, where the fucking egg?
Me egg.
I don't know what to do with the egg.
Okay, I gotta figure out where he...
Oh, hey.
Ah, tiny warrior.
Then you too came to test yourself against that traitorous tribe.
A deadly bunch, Dayara, that roost within these glades.
I will stay awake while clear them.
But your actions have shown me the truth of it.
face down our fears.
If we both make it through, we can swap stories of our adventure.
I look forward to that.
Yippee!
Oh, shit.
Wait, can I not, like, use that as a... Can I poker this?
No, I can't.
Okay.
No.
I'm yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Gotta eat my grub.
Just silly grub.
Raves went upgraded and It's extremely powerful.
We don't get all hits with Shaman Stone.
It does 120 damage.
So Shade Stone does 40 normally.
Oh, that's a lot.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, we gotta figure out where the map guy is.
I thought that was meta.
Okay, that is Queen's Garden.
Well, maybe we'll fight.
I don't know.
Fuck it.
Let's just go this way then.
Let's just keep going.
I was gonna upgrade my thing first.
but like might as well just grab whatever the fuck um it's fine we're we're grab get the stack station first and then we'll go upgrade it all right here you go i'll spend the money soon guys don't worry oh hey it's these guys again wait why did he paint me i thought we were friends what happened why don't we friends no more Oh shit.
Where the fuck is the stack station though?
I'm yum yum yum yum yum.
I'm so hungry.
I gotta eat my greens.
I don't know where the stack station is.
There's no maps.
Ow!
That's not cool.
But how come they can do the whirlwind this?
Oh, it's a trap.
It's a trap.
Okay.
God damn, I'm trying to eat my veggies!
My mama told me to eat my veggies!
Get out!
I'm yam, yam, yam, yam, yam, yam, yam, yam, yam, yam, yam, yam.
My dad said I have to eat my greens.
Oh, there you go.
Okay, he's here.
They said they were traders, but how are they a trader?
Is there anything here?
Where the fuck is the...
Where's the map guy?
The map trip... Oh, there he is.
Are you serious?
He left?
Sorry, I missed you.
You're feeling lost.
I now pop up to our star and dive mountain.
Purchase the map with this area.
Oh my god, they go back.
Okay.
We gotta find the bench, though.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh.
no no grub no draw map phone up friend john holland night update map grub tired
grub tired grub too stupid okay yeah we gotta fucking find the sag station yeah yeah john holland that is babysitting the grub right now grub done all right guys where is the stack station oh what's this isn't this just the most intriguing place so many discoveries waiting to be made we're about to set off ourselves so we can't agree seem to agree on which way to head it's led to something of an argument between us we should really stop squabbling about such petty things grub need dream goodbye grub need essence don't eat no plus one no yum yum how could you plus one not even then it's not gonna affect i just need true ending it doesn't affect it yum yum grub grub grub grub hungry journey in the grub hunger for souls i know it should have given me two you're so right why the did not give me two i reaped two souls you're so right that should have been two whoa okay i did not see that You're so right,
though.
Why the fuck was that not too?
Oh my god!
Okay.
I do not...
Oh, nice.
Okay, where is this open?
How the fuck did I open?
Wait, what did I open?
Guys?
What did I open?
Plans hungry for grub.
Oh, door.
Oh, this door?
Was this door closed?
Oh, I wish I had a map to know.
Oh, whoops.
It's fine.
Om yum, yum, yum.
Grub have grass.
Grub, okay.
Oh, no.
Grub not okay.
Okay, Grub turned to John.
Oh,
this is actually pretty bad for Grub.
Okay, nice.
Grub, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Grub, okay now.
Oh, nice.
Wait, they respond.
That's actually really good for me.
John, help!
No!
Okay.
Okay, I'll just farm these guys because they respawn anyway.
There we go.
Om yum yum.
What world hates, grub.
Okay.
We'll just farm these guys.
No, grub won't die in this room, guys.
Grub is fine.
Om yum yum yum.
Alright, poor is enough.
Save the grub.
on all the night.
You're her only hope.
Okay.
Nice.
Okay, nice.
Okay, okay, that's pretty strong.
Okay, it's fine.
I took him down with me.
Oh my god, that's so annoying, though.
All right.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Eat your veggies.
And you'll become a big, strong grub.
Jesus, that is so annoying, the whirlwind shit.
Like, ah, because I can't encounter it.
Because he throws it right at my face.
Oh, fuck.
I didn't know where it was.
I was like, where the fuck is that spike?
Are you serious?
Fuck off!
Ah!
Grub don't feel good.
Oh my god.
Why are you chasing me?
Crook don't want to do this again.
I'll go all the way back.
I don't want to do that parkour thing again.
Because I'm going to be lost.
I know I'll be lost so I don't want to go back.
Run, little Crook.
Run.
I'm going to be lost to try and find this place again.
So I'd rather just go back.
Alright.
That should be enough.
Just need to do...
Alright, here we go.
That should be enough now.
I wonder if the Mantis responds.
Are you serious?
No!
Okay, it's fine.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
It's fine.
I have lettuce.
Okay, they don't.
Yay.
Okay, they don't respawn.
That's good.
Yippee!
They don't respawn!
Okay, that's good.
That is just one.
Are you serious?
Oh, I fucked that up again.
Okay, that's fine.
I didn't realize that's...
There's only one.
Okay, bench two does.
left.
Oh, I guess that's where the stack station is.
Well, Karen, I know that breaks when you get hit.
Yeah, we're not doing that.
We're just getting a true ending.
Oh.
Oh!
Fuck.
What?
It came back!
Okay, that's bullshit.
Is it here?
Oh, it's a bench.
Okay.
I rather grab the bench then.
Bench time.
Yay!
Oh, I get to listen to music.
All right, let me turn and fix this real quick.
All right, I'm going to put this over here.
And then put my dream thing over here.
And I'll close this.
Yay!
Grow up, listen to music.
Um, go up, sleep.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh, yeah, they respawned because I...
Oh, my... Okay.
That's good.
I gotta remember to double kill them.
Yay, I glowed now!
What the fuck?
Okay.
These, like, flying ones, like, don't really too much.
Okay, we go this way.
Oh, shit.
I guess not.
Where do we go?
Oh, nice.
There's money here.
Yeah, I could know.
I think, yeah, I was gonna say, I think it's, uh...
It's how much HP is that?
I don't even know how many hp i have technically okay where the fuck am i
wait i'm not in the queen's garden anymore wait where am i hello oh it's the spiders yippee yippee yippee yippee it is a massacre face upon the creature in hollowness a difficult thing It can be the decipher.
What the fuck is he?
Oh, is he a mask maker?
I won't think they have a face.
Nothing with which we are all are blessed.
Does it know of the face that hides beneath?
Such remarkable contrast that I am conceived.
Oh.
Wait, I have to use the...
Where?
Here?
Where do I do it?
Use downstop?
Okay.
Oh my god!
Has it witnessed the truth most tragic?
The worms' great shame steal the way.
Now this kingdom's status becomes the worms.
Wait, you're not...
You're not even a...
Whoa, what's wrong with your face?
What the fuck is wrong with your...
The Hintoki, you cannot just say what's wrong with your face.
Wait, that's not like...
That's not a bug face.
Is it?
and he's just yeah his eyes are like like dizzy why do you think he would no wonder he has a mask on i'm sorry buddy now i know put the mask back on
okay we got figure okay wait actually how close am i to stack station here.
Not close.
Okay.
Wait, actually?
Not close.
Okay.
Alright, we gotta whoops.
We gotta figure out how to get out of here.
Get to the we gotta figure out how to get to the stack station from here.
Because I'm trying to buy my map.
Oh, I didn't finish getting the money.
Oh, and there's more money!
Go up?
Okay.
Keep going up.
I'm trying to find a stack station here so I can go back and buy the map for this area.
Okay.
Oops.
Oh, I didn't realize that was a platform there.
God, I hate these guys so much.
Did I go here yet?
Can't tell.
Oh, yeah, I did.
Crop is a witch grove.
there is there is maybe up top did I go up top oh there it is nice okay alright the sack station is up here oh shit oh please I'm just a baby
I'm just a baby
I'm mercy
okay there you go please oh my god like i said these guys are the most annoying one i got killed these guys first oh fucking course that hits me
okay that's good that's good i got in time
Okay.
I sort of know the pattern.
Just make him throw the boomerang first before I go.
Oh shit!
I don't expect to see these guys.
Okay, nice.
Okay, get rid of him first.
Oh!
I would tell my father about you!
That wasn't nice!
All right, where's the stag station?
This way, this way.
Stag station should be nearby.
Okay, that's money.
I want to be a rich world.
Unless you forgot, and I probably misspoke.
Oh, shit!
Clab, zoop, bretta, and leg eater.
Wait, it's this way.
Oops.
Okay, up.
Stag station up top.
Wait, is it that door?
Where's that station?
I follow map.
Up here?
Maybe?
Oh, it's here.
Oh, this does not look like stack station.
I missed it?
Yeah, I was gonna say, this does not look like it.
Oh, up and around.
Stag station, doco?
Is it here?
What is this?
Here sleeps the traitor's child.
Dream!
Oh.
What?
The traitor's child.
Oh.
I have no idea.
Oh, shit.
I have no idea what that is.
Oh, oh my god.
Pac-Core.
Oh, I jumped!
Oh, yay, speed ride.
I'm yam-yam-yam-yam-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y-y.
Okay.
Oh, it's a side quest.
Okay, because I was like, what the fuck is that?
That wasn't part of the true ending guide.
Okay, so I have to go up and then down.
Right?
would lead me to.
God, these guys are annoying.
Holy fuck.
Okay, I don't care about them enough.
These guys are very annoying.
I think it's more so like, I don't know where they're...
Like, I don't...
Like, I don't know their pattern.
They have no pattern.
They just jump.
That's their pattern.
They just want to jump.
Oh!
That's all they do Oh my god
They're just jumping
Oh my god They're so annoying They're actually so annoying Holy fuck It's just the worst part is that they don't have a pattern to their jumps
okay whoa that's a big boy wait that's a big-ass bug are they like the dinosaurs oh there's more
okay at least i can heal here it's like a dino bug yeah it's like they went extinct
okay that's bullshit that's actually bullshit
Oh my god, I hate these guys so much.
I hate them and their jumps.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
I have one more leaf.
My dad packed a leaf in the backpack for emergencies.
Are you serious?
oh my god and they respawn and they respawn
i didn't realize they respawn oh i can't jesus wherever i woke up i'm so sad i got Gotta do this all over again.
Oh, wait.
It was this way.
That's fine.
Grump!
No!
The fact that they respawn as well is so bullshit.
I'm just gonna pass you.
Goodbye.
That's so messed up.
Wait, how did I get Dream?
Grump Father will be sad.
Alright.
Gotta do this again.
Was it up?
Wait, yeah, it was up.
Yeah, because I was like, where the fuck is the stack station?
And then it was this way.
The randomly jumping bugs.
It's just so bullshit!
Oh!
The fact that they respawned, dude, fuck he sucks.
I'm just gonna run past him.
Fuck this.
Oh my god.
It doesn't matter.
I got...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You do not kill me.
Okay.
My own soul was trying to kill me.
Get back in here.
Okay.
All right.
Here we go.
We gotta figure this out.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, I see the...
Oh, God.
Okay, we got rid of him.
Okay, I can heal the...
Yeah, no, fucking.
I don't...
Yeah, I know.
I can tell why it kills speedruns.
Yeah, no, these guys are absolutely bullshit.
Oh my god, I have no idea where I'm at.
Brother!
Yippee, yippee, yippee!
What's this?
What the fuck is that?
How do I get there?
Oh, I actually found it.
Peace and thank you for the super duper.
chat thank you thank you how do i go there why can't i let me through let me in let me in let me in
you're somehow smaller um i just haven't hit my gross dad he said i just haven't hit my growth spurt yet okay uh rude he said i'll be big and strong just like my brother and that i won't stop
You don't know that!
Daddy said I will keep growing!
I'm just a late bloomer!
Oh my god!
Wait till I hit my second puberty!
Daddy said everyone has second puberty!
What the fuck?
Okay.
Nice.
Like, I bent down so I don't get decapitated.
Alright, wait, where is it?
Where the fuck is it?
I'm still trying to find the goddamn stag station.
Is this where I came from?
Yeah.
That's some loony dude shit.
But I came from here.
This was froggy hell.
Wasn't this frog...
Oh no, this was not froggy hell.
This is new froggy hell.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
There's multiple froggy hells.
Jesus, I hate these.
I hate them so much.
The worst part is that I don't have a map Because that I refuse to leave this area Okay, there we go This has to be Stag Station Right?
Oh my god, they can shoot up Okay No, he went back to Dirt Mouth I didn't miss him He just, he won't sell me my map
okay so that's why i'm like i'm trying to find i'm trying to find uh find the sag station so i can just leave this place what's this oh the queen the queen is coming i've been waiting so long and she's almost here i feel like i'm about to burst i've kept it safe the secret garden i kept it And soon the queen will return And teach me to fly Shall we wait together,
strangers?
Shall we play together?
No, no, no.
Grub needs to Go home.
Alright.
Alright, now.
Oh, it's these little guys.
Alright.
I can't have my ass kicked Just yet.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Okay, now we can do it.
I can take him.
Hmm.
Alright.
Oh, and there's a chair.
Thank God.
That map couldn't, like, do it, go through here?
Okay, yeah.
This is a shortcut.
Okay, now I can go back to Dirt map.
I'll open that later
I'm gonna Buy my map Wait, who the fuck is that guy?
Talonclips Where is that?
Chill,
hot spring, gleaming Wait, tram pin I don't know what the tram is, but I'll get it for now Wait, that's conifer?
Oh my god, he's a snorer.
Do you think he has...
What's it called where he can't...
Where when you're snoring, it means you can't breathe.
Whispering...
Whispering roots.
Oh, are these uh...
Yeah.
Do you think Cornelius has sleep apnea?
Well, you should get that checked out.
Gotta get that checked out, sir.
You might have sleep apnea.
all right go this way all right we gotta buy some let's just buy the charms now because we need what 25 to unlock another charm notch right two four uh how much you have two four six eight wait 10 12 14 16 18 20 21 all right we just need to buy four potomac chill okay whatever he only has
It's all right.
We can find three more.
Actually, yeah, you're right.
He shouldn't get that checked out.
I hope he doesn't get it checked out.
Okay, nice.
Let's just buy everything.
So I can move on in.
Oh, we're broke, broke.
That's all right.
Wee.
I can't I can't I love I love his little spin it's so cute all right the things that grant gain solo and taking damage okay we need that okay what else is two there's a dash master so soul catcher used to draw more souls and he increases the power of spells wait actually shaman stone.
Do I have a stronger one?
Or is that my strongest?
I think that's my strongest.
Reduces the soul cost of or increases the force causing enemy to her quarrel further.
Okay, if I take these two off, I might be able to have a better charm on.
Oh!
Wait, that's good.
Okay.
that when using shallow yeah i should do that sharp yeah i'll get sharp shadow wee
or long nail okay wait long nail actually long nail is better okay i'll do with long nail long nails too right heavy bolo okay yeah long nail wee i'm sorry um i'm very entertained by the smallest things and his little spin is very entertaining
okay queens okay now we can go to queen's garden
why are we gonna fight him now
oops whoops wait what's over here can i get it it?
No, I did.
I just full-hitted.
Wait.
What happens if I just dream him here?
Oh.
Oh, shit!
Oh!
That's what happens.
Oh,
it's like a...
It's like a little beach bug.
Okay, wait.
Yeah, it's like volleyball.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I'm messing it up.
Oh, he doesn't let me hear.
Ah, no.
He doesn't let me hear.
I thought he would...
Okay, also, I realized I forgot to grab the upgrade.
It's good, because I actually needed to grab the upgrade.
It was planned.
Volleyball won.
I wanted to die.
So I could grab the upgrade, guys.
Wait, you don't need a...
Wait, do you need money for this?
For the Abyss?
It's fine.
It's $26.
dollars okay all right that's good i was gonna say all right it should be like here right yeah i was gonna say why the fuck would i need money
all right we got here it's okay we just fall straight down be fine.
The issue is coming back up, but it'll be okay.
I'll worry about that later.
That's okay.
I'll worry about coming back up later.
Okay.
See, I told you everything will be okay.
one upgrade.
Here?
How do I activate it?
Wait, what?
Oh!
Don't worry, my babysitter can do it for me.
John Hollow Knight, my babysitter activated it.
Bro, just scream.
Yeah.
Yeah!
Happy.
Okay.
Okay, now I just gotta scream.
See, I told you guys.
I told you guys everything would be okay.
The donkey wave.
Alright.
Now I can go back up.
Just gotta remember how to do it.
I think that's the hardest part.
It's so far up.
I noticed that there was something to- oh shit.
Whoops.
I noticed there was something to my left earlier.
Is that important?
Remember that it is on my left side?
It's a side quest?
Yeah, there it is.
Oh wait, no.
Not here.
Is it here?
No?
Oh shit.
Yeah, okay.
Yippee!
Grub no need to think!
I gotta figure out where to go.
This way.
Oh shit, what the fuck?
What the fuck?
Okay, my jumping thing was being weird there.
For some reason.
Oh yay, money!
Random money!
Oh!
More random money!
Yeah.
Where do I go?
This way.
This way?
Oh my gosh, I'm so... Oh, there it is!
Yay!
Okay.
Now we go home.
Now we fight the volleyball!
Okay, the volleyball has a lot of HP.
I was not expecting that.
Alright, now we can fight him.
Can't catch me.
No bad touch.
Alright.
Alright, now we go back.
How great is my nail?
I think it's plus two.
Alright, nice.
all right there we go now i'm full all right now i can challenge you oh oh oh oh my god i can't time this correctly oh my god he's fucking me up oh my god
Woo!
Bamboo!
Yay!
Okay, that was a lot easier with the upgraded shriek.
Oh, stranger, you're strong!
Much stronger than me.
I've been waiting a long time, stranger.
I've been finding a long time, stranger.
I'm very, very tired.
The queen will be here soon, and I just need to sleep a little.
me when the queen arrives stranger rise the street queen will teach us both to fly stranger that would be fun wouldn't it i guess you'll never wake up again oh yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum grub hungry
protected at roof and leaf we honor you it's a grubby grub world It just said an alarm.
It's a grubby grub.
Bro was consumed.
All right, we gotta figure out how to... Okay, now that we have the map.
We're gonna figure out... Okay, it should be the top, I guess.
Assume it's the top part.
You will be forgot.
Oops.
I'll go back to the bench.
I was looking at chat.
Like Grubhub.
That's right.
Get Grubhub.
Top right.
Yeah.
I assume it's the one area I have yet to explore.
Yeah, this way.
Like up top here.
There you go.
Oh.
Okay, I might as well grab Close Souls, too.
While we're at it.
Okay.
Alright, I have no idea where I am.
That's the best part.
Oh.
Usually, like, it doesn't hit me on the first level.
I'll just heal this.
Made that look easy.
Because it was easy.
Oh, my God.
How can Korya's...
Are you serious?
I hate these guys so much.
Oh, I hate them.
Oh, my God.
There you go.
I don't know.
I don't know if it's up, but I'm gonna go up anyway.
Just tank that.
For extra.
Oh.
I mean, yeah?
Oh, shit.
What?
Okay.
I had a feeling.
Ah, god damn it.
I had a feeling it's Pogo.
Oh, that's bullshit.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
No.
I was trying to stop it.
Okay.
Grub leave.
Oh,
I'm back at the green path.
I mean, I might as well grab this while I'm here.
Okay.
Oh.
I can't do that.
Grub leave indeed.
Well, I can't do anything here.
Oh, is bad because i think down here are like more mantises i'm pretty sure
okay they don't respawn that's good oh this is a little scary
okay there you go there you go this is parkour training for This is parkour training for the parkour hill that I have to do later.
This is actually training for the hard part of the parkour.
Okay.
Really?
He's gonna go down?
Why is he slowly heading towards me?
Fucking freak.
There you go.
Yeah, this one is a little annoying.
Oh, fuck, I didn't see that.
God damn, I didn't see that.
I did not really.
Oh, my, oh, fuck.
What?
I got comboed in the sky.
Where am I?
Oh, I'm here.
I'm here.
Wait, where do I go?
Is this the one?
I did not see that.
God damn it.
I'm literally, this is actually practice right now for me.
This parkour practice.
Grub life.
I got wobble comboed.
Is Thorne actually fucking with me?
I can't, or the long nail.
I can't tell.
Wait, Lover?
Wait, what does it do?
Why is it bucking with me?
Okay, this way.
Oh, my god.
There you go.
That should do that.
Oh, my word!
Alright.
I hate the whirlwind shit.
That one shit actually is so annoying.
Okay, let's get the full HP first.
Get it over here.
I don't have thorns on.
Oh shit, sorry.
I was looking at my chat.
I don't have thorns on.
I don't think I do.
I think I took- I'm pretty sure I took it off, right?
Yeah, I took it off.
No, I took off the thorns.
yeah that's why i was like what are you guys talking about i was like okay i'm pretty sure i took it up i
make this one yeah i can oh come on how did you let go
please fly fly up mage thank you for the raid thank you thank you oh shit oh nice
Excuse me.
Oh, this is bad.
I don't think I... Yeah, I was gonna say I'm not gonna hit that.
I guess I die.
I guess...
I guess I'll die, I think.
I mean, I think.
I mean, I could...
I could just fall down a little.
I'll fall down a little.
Oh.
Wait, that's bad.
Okay, nice.
all right it's fine all right I got another one it's so awkward because like sometimes my I need to stop looking at chat when I do my parkour I we got this we will get this parkour this is basically practice For the parkour of hell.
This is my parkour of hell practice.
No texting or driving.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
I don't...
Why is it like that?
Okay.
I don't know why it does that sometimes.
It doesn't, like...
Like, you guys can see that?
Like...
Oh, come on.
Come on!
That's so bullshit!
Does that work?
No.
Ah, down!
No!
Okay.
Don't worry.
Maybe we'll grab some extra HP.
I hate this.
Parkour is so hard.
Why is Parkour is so hard.
Why can't parkour be easier?
We don't understand.
Wait.
If only...
Okay, I don't think I should be here.
This is static!
Alright, here you go.
It's okay.
We will...
If we master this parkour part, we can master the harder parkour part.
It's this way.
Oh, you don't understand.
If we master this, that means we can take on any parkour level.
Like, this is a truth parkour test.
Oh my god, what the fuck happened to me?
It's okay, we still, we didn't die.
It literally hit the edge there.
That's how, oh my god, that's how I was saying, we didn't die.
Guess I missed another lover.
It's okay, guys.
We don't need the lever.
We don't need it.
Oh, shit.
Where did I die?
Oh, it was this way.
Okay, I gotta remember where my soul is.
Okay, I gotta find my soul.
Get over here.
I gotta pick up my babysitter.
Dude, like, the jump is not...
No, it's very difficult.
It's not allowed to give me that super chat.
You don't understand.
I was not made to parkour.
Like, right now.
I've never seen this guy before.
Like, outside.
Okay.
I've never seen him all the way up here before.
Usually he's like, usually he's like not there.
Just don't get hit.
Don't worry, we got it.
Don't worry.
He's knocked.
Fly up.
Up.
Not down.
Fly up.
That's right.
Keep flying up.
There we go.
Oh, this is a little too close.
Okay.
Oh.
How do I cancel?
I wish I could just cancel this right now.
God damn it!
I hate that you can't cancel it.
I did.
Fly up!
Go higher!
Oh my god.
It won't.
Of course it's a double.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, fuck it.
Okay, I was like, you know what?
I'll just do the poor girl.
But fuck me, I guess.
I...
I'm pressing LT!
I'm pressing...
I swear to God, I pressed LT.
I swear to God.
Oh.
okay oh my god I don't okay that's brother we did it guys now that we've mastered this parkour area we're unstoppable ow it's fine we need are you how do I get down how do I get down oh my god oh my god I guess you don't wait okay it's fine it's my wolf okay
okay we did it I'm so tired It's just I'm so tired We did it It was even part of the true ending I did it out of spite I had to do this You don't understand If I mastered this parkour Area I can master All of the parkour area Okay This way
Are you serious There he is, okay.
It had to be done, guys.
If I mastered this, I can take on any parkour area.
What's this?
Oh, no, not again.
Alright.
There you go.
I'll heal real fast.
Oh my god.
What the- Oh, hey!
Yay, yippee!
Big B, big B, big B.
Woo!
I'm never gonna...
Oh!
Big Bamba, help!
Grab him!
Please!
Oh, shit!
Finger, Mom!
Oh, my god, he's so big!
Oh, my, guys!
I have literally one HP.
I don't think I can live this.
I...
I have one HP.
I'm surprised it's a boss fight.
Yeah, I literally have one HP.
I do not think I was gonna live that.
No, one HP and a dream.
Random fucking boss fight out of nowhere.
Okay, now that I know...
No, it's still possible I can get the true ending, guys.
I believe.
It's this way.
Because you did it.
believe.
Okay, now that I know there's a boss fight, I'll lock in.
And this way.
Alright.
See?
Easy.
Oh, hey, I missed the lever.
Yay!
Will I ever get that lever?
Maybe one day.
Okay.
Unless they go back from the mini guys, too.
Yeah, it does.
Okay, so.
Okay, now that I know.
Alright, that's fine.
Yeah, I want to make...
Nice.
Okay, one more small guy.
Oh!
Oh, yippee!
Yippee!
Oh, shit!
What the fuck?
Oh, I forgot it doesn't do knock.
back these guys.
Okay, now that I know.
Okay, now I know it doesn't do knockback.
I didn't even have time to learn his moves.
Okay.
All right.
Oh my god, he put me in the corner.
There was nothing I could do there.
Oh!
He's dabbed.
God damn it.
Wait, what?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I don't know if I can heal, though.
I don't know if I can heal.
I actually need her to distract him.
Nice.
Oh, he does double!
That does double the damage!
Oh!
Oh, that does double damage.
Okay, I can actually...
Let me arrange my charms now.
Okay, I don't need this.
Okay, now that I know that does double damage.
Okay, he does too.
Okay, now that I know.
Okay, I need...
Okay, I got rid of...
Why should I get locked?
I feel like long nails good.
Uh...
Mark of Pride?
What was that?
I don't remember.
This one.
Really?
Okay, the range.
Okay, we can do marker prep.
Whoops.
Oh my god.
I would assume it would go back.
Okay, then we can do uh...
Okay, we have steady body.
What can we do?
That's one.
I guess grub saw?
I'll do...
I did grub saw or aura time um they stack but i get over charm i don't want over charm yeah grub song yeah i was like wondering if i would compass
okay now that i know
the switch wait where's the lever okay where is the lever Oh, there it is.
Look at that.
I found it.
Oh my god, it was right there the entire time.
Wait, where was...
Where is it?
Oh, it goes that way.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm not overcharming.
There's no fucking way.
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
I was like...
Okay, I'm sorry.
Okay, I might have been fucking around there.
I rushed that.
Whoops.
Tee-hee.
Just being a little silly.
I'm just being a little silly, you guys.
Tee-hee.
Okay, there we go.
Alright.
Nice.
And then this guy just dies instantly.
Oh, what the fuck?
He just spawns on my head.
I'm just like...
He's just gonna...
I was not expecting that.
I don't know.
I just I thought he wouldn't be on my fucking head.
Okay.
I want to use...
Are you serious?
Oh my god.
A fucking course.
He dashes away.
Okay, there you go.
Oh my god.
I think that's the worst part about that move.
It's just the fact that I can't see him.
Oh my god.
What?!
I can't see him!
It's good damage, but I can't see him when I use it.
Yeah, he hits so hard.
I hate that he does two damage.
Yeah.
Alright.
Oh my.
This boss is difficult.
I think if he didn't...
If he didn't do two damage, it would have been so much easier for me.
I'm not used to bosses doing two damage.
Oh no, I do not have TP.
Yeah, I'm not used to the dive spell.
I keep fucking it up.
Every time.
I don't know why.
I just can't get that move to work properly.
I make a try.
I'll try for this one.
Oh my god, are you serious?
Yeah, I tried.
Okay, there you go.
I felt like that was a waste, though.
I'm just gonna heal.
Okay.
Whoa.
What?
Okay, okay, why are they all?
Why are they all above me?
What the fuck?
You'd say all just showed up above me.
Oh, my.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, my God.
The shadow thing didn't work.
That sucks.
Are you serious?
Whoa!
Okay.
I'm gonna play more careful here.
I dashed too far.
Oh it was on cooldown.
I didn't realize it was on cooldown.
Oh my god.
I dashed too.
I was too far away from my dash.
This one has to be my current hardest.
Or maybe I'm just not locking in.
I don't know.
I don't know bro.
I think this is the hardest for me only because it does two damage.
Yeah.
Only because he does two damage.
Lost King did like one.
So like, it wasn't like...
I wasn't too worried about it.
When he does two, it like...
Fucks with me more.
Because it makes me more...
It makes me more like...
Anxious, I guess.
I didn't, I don't know that's the right word, but like It just makes me more anxious
Because I have less
Because I don't have that much HP
Yeah, yeah, there's no openings to heal, I agree
I agree, there's barely any chance to heal at all
Alright, I'm locking in, I'm locking in this.
I'll try.
I'm gonna I'm I'm
Yeah.
Are you just not so far?
The range for that was so far!
I wasn't ready for that.
Oh my god.
I fucked up.
I fucked up there.
Okay, okay, I'm locking in fully.
Yeah, his range for that was so far.
Okay, I'm fully locking in.
I understand his patterns.
I just need to figure out the range of his dashes.
His dash range, I messed up on calculating.
I miscalculated the dash.
Okay.
Come on little grub.
You can do this You're just a small grub in a big bug world But I believe in you Also that reminds me because oh fuck He loves to go at Pixar You know they're making Coco 2 And I saw a Twitter comment and they're like What the fuck are you gonna do in Coco 2?
The grandma fucking died I'm just like wait he's so true Like what I was like, wait, he's right.
The grandma's dead.
Why the fuck is there going to be a Coco too?
Like, yeah.
The spoiler, it is toky.
Alright.
I was like, wait, he right.
Are you...
Okay, that's bullshit.
That's bullshit.
I should have been able to kill that guy here.
Let's wait for Big Baba.
Yippee!
Big Mama!
Oh my god.
I'm just gonna let her kill him.
I'm just gonna...
Yay!
Yum yum yum yum yum!
Yeah, maybe I'll I'll do the pogo.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I'm not going to do that move.
That move is way too risky.
Are you serious?
I thought he was jumping.
That was my worst run.
I thought he was going to jump.
That was a bad prediction.
Holy shit.
This fucking stupid Lord Mantis.
Fucking You know, that means he's a virgin Because he's still alive Let me think about it The woman hasn't eaten his head yet
Not rock
Toki Oh shit, sorry Is that, isn't that one the male mantis?
I thought it wasn't, this one was the male one.
I refuse to believe that.
How is he alive?
His head should have been eaten.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I thought he was male.
How is he alive?
Then he's a fucking cat.
He's still alive.
He's a fucking coward.
No honor.
He is.
That's why.
That's why he's a traitor.
Because he didn't get himself get himself eaten.
He ran away.
No honor.
No.
No fucking honor.
He didn't get himself.
himself eaten.
Okay, because all the other male mantises did it?
He's a coway.
He's a fucking coway.
It's not worth it, bro.
It's so tight.
The...
The dash.
Oh my god.
I was trying to pogo.
It didn't work.
Are you serious?
Hey!
Okay, I actually got focused up, though.
Are you serious?
Oh my god, that's so bullshit!
Okay.
Oh my god.
That's just so bullshit.
It is- he's so fast.
He does double damage for a reason.
Okay.
He's so fast.
I think this is my strongest filter.
I don't need the dream gate.
I don't even know what that is.
I'm getting rage baited.
I am.
I'm getting rage baited, but I'm not.
a guy that ran away.
No honor.
Get your head eaten like all the other male mantises.
Actual no honor here.
Look, I'm just a little baby.
Look at me!
I'm literally just a child!
Why is he picking a fight with a child?
about it it's sadder that he's picking a fight with me that's
a lot sadder are you serious it's just cuz like she did the attack and mess with me okay okay I can still heal all right I'm full HP now oh
my god I thought he was gonna jump I thought he was gonna jump!
Guys, the run's dead.
The run's already dead.
Oh, the run is already dead.
Oh, my God.
The run...
I'm just...
Just kill the child.
Just kill me.
Wait, unless...
Unless...
Alright, 1 HP and I dream.
We're gonna do the 1 HP run.
It's like an extra challenge.
I just feel You know what, fuck it
Just wanna make it more exciting, you know That
was actually doing so well I fucked up the pogo That was actually Oh my god That was actually, like, my best run with 1 HP.
So no head, probably that Mantis is X-Roy.
Oh, my God.
That was my...
Yeah, I messed up the Pogo.
Okay.
Alright, we'll take this seriously now.
Can't believe Mantis Lord is my biggest filthy.
Out of all of the...
Out of all of them.
Just because of the two damage.
The two damage is, like...
You know how, like...
more nervous just because like it does more like because it's like a change okay i couldn't fucking stand it the pressure yeah just more pressure in general so i'm like making more mistakes than i should oh fuck okay i'm like okay let me i'll play play with my controller up i've been playing it on my lap and like yesterday i was playing it on my desk okay i think it's also because i'm playing on my lap too maybe it'll be different but all right here you go so give me a sec me check something real quick gotta check my volume and i gotta blow my nose real quick uh oh sorry my sponsor was asking me about I'm sorry my my manager was asking me about sponsors and I didn't see the message all right here you go all right I'm focused up stupid fucking mantis I bet they're all like I bet they're all male mantises that refuse it they're all the mantises that ran away from home because they refuse to get eaten cowards
You're cowish!
That's why, yeah, that's why they're all traitors.
You can tell the females here didn't feel like it.
If they ran away, you know damn well.
You know damn well they were supposed to get eaten.
Yeah, I just want to be over here.
Oh
Actually locking me in this side Oh, oh no I mistimed that one so I couldn't No
Oh, come on
No, no, that's wrong right that's what you get that's what you get we're not dying with honor rumble thank you for the super chat thank you thank you pretty man smells get to live in a female felix and some type of spiders it depends on their foreplay game if they are eating or not so performance can play a role and whether it's a female ate a male or not
don't worry she's just sleeping Guys, that's okay.
She's just sleeping.
See, she's closing her eyes.
Guys, she's closing her eyes.
See, she's going.
She's sleeping.
Don't even come back?
Okay.
Hello?
Oh, look, see, she's alive!
Yippee, yippee, yippee!
Well, now that was something.
A true battle of mighty warriors.
So intense.
So climatic.
It's really everything I could have ever hoped for.
Thanks for all your help, my friend.
For a tiny bug, you said a valiant example.
We'll meet again.
I'm sure of it.
It's okay, Mama.
You can be inside me forever.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Yippie, yippie, yippie.
Now, kiafis will be inside my stomach forever.
Yippie.
What is this?
protect no she's not dead she's inside my essence bread welcome to the tomato farm welcome welcome grub hungry grub consume what's over here
oh one arrives far i walk so fine did it see My aid?
Or does a path carry it by chance to so pertinent a place?
It is true.
True that you were awaited.
No, perhaps.
That is inaccurate.
True wing like you was awaited.
I have a gift.
How long for one of your kind.
Half of a whole, when united, great power is granted.
And on the path ahead, great power it will need.
Yippee!
Free stuff!
Yay!
Yippee!
Wait, that's my mama?
Where were you?
My dad had to raise me on his own.
I had 40 plus brothers!
Where were you, mom?
It faced a gendered child.
She was a fierce foe.
Strong in mind and body.
Shaking reflection of her mother.
minute little time together i never begrudged the worm stallion says bargain in fact i feel some affection for the creature some affection you're my mom of your paths forever to lie i imagine you might gain yourself a pal what the fuck do you mean some affection yeah mom moment within my roots the weakening of the vessel i plainly feel i mean too obvious i have there are from such a thing.
The first is inevitable on a current course.
Regression on mine relinquished their play.
The second I find preferable and will seek your aid in its occurrence replacement.
I implore you, you swept the vessel.
I suppose its train was ill-judged.
It was tarnished by a dealer and stilled, but you, you're free of such blemishes.
You could contain that thing inside.
Dream!
So you can access a mine.
The seal shall break before its blade.
Oh, she was talking about the hornet.
Oh.
Can't believe my mama hates me.
I don't have mommy issues, I swear.
Oh, gender child is the hornet.
Oh, because she's the only one with, like, a gender.
No, Toki.
She was gonna go to Bah'u'llah.
Why, Toki?
Why?
she's but what's better being with me forever or going to stupid vahala where i'm not there that's all i'm gonna say if by being in my stomach she's with me by being in vahala i'm not there
so all i'm saying is that i'm the better option go up what is your up here?
I understand.
What do you mean by up?
Alright.
Where am I?
Oh, I don't have my map.
I forgot.
Yel and Pogo this one?
Up here?
How do I do that?
Ow.
There?
How mad just of you.
From that?
That better be something up there.
I swear they're God.
Oh, there's nothing there.
Oh, my God.
I fucking knew it.
I knew that I was bait.
I fucking knew that was bait.
I got one guy.
Me when Doki gets one guy.
Where do I go now?
Guys, where do I go?
Oh, yeah.
Let's do the dream.
stuff the dream essence stuff we're supposed to get dream essence right we gotta get 1800 or some
shit oh my god which is the easiest ah okay
all right there we go we figured it out oh my god This one is still inactive.
There you go.
We're okay.
Everything is fine.
Okay, we're not going to deal with these guys because I feel like I'll die.
There you go.
I'm y'all, y'all, y'all.
I'm going.
Come to say happy September to you and all the other dragoons.
I know nothing about Hall Life.
I want to wish you the best on the battles ahead.
Trevor for the Aka Aka Supa!
Thank you!
I really appreciate it!
Thank you so much!
And now we have a great day too, Trevor.
Alright.
Staggedness.
Which is Staggedness?
What the fuck is Staggedness?
Yeah?
Oh, I forgot to equip the compass.
Wait, what's this?
What the fuck?
Okay, give me a sec.
Let me...
Alright, I'm gonna go to...
Let me sit down first.
I didn't even know...
Yeah, I didn't even notice I unlocked it.
Alright, let me grab my compass before we do this.
Okay, compass, and then...
I'll grab this.
All right.
Okay, Stag's nest.
His home?
His home is pretty sad.
Oh, they're all dead!
Oh, that's so sad.
All his friends died of old age.
Oh, nice.
Sippy, more souls.
All my friends are dead.
They all died at that old age.
You're like lonely George.
The past you hold.
Is it not for that ghastly machine to tram?
I hope you're not thinking right on that gross tech contraption.
The thought of a mere machine could tempt what we stags do.
Foolish.
Very foolish.
Okay.
a secret?
Over here?
Why do I go up top?
What?
Oh?
Oh, there you go.
Huh.
Oh.
What's the secret?
He's gonna get me.
I'm gonna get you.
Oh where am I where did I go oh oh I'm supposed to go left oh I missed it I went too far where did I go I was like where am I hey well Come home!
Yay!
I'm home!
Okay, back to the Stag's Nest.
It was all a dream.
I was like, where did I go?
Being back in my own home.
Feel the way of my long life bearing down on me.
I'll carry it proudly, though.
Whenever I travel, the memories of my family might come with me.
I skipped a dream fight.
Alright.
Going back.
Wee!
Oh, do I go here?
Oh, it's here!
What's over here?
An empty eggshell.
Wait, a stag is born here.
Where'd I go?
Yeah, that means there's one side.
Oh, that's him!
Oh!
Wait, are these all eggs?
Wait, they're all eggs here!
Wait, his family's all here!
His family...
Look, there's more babies!
Oh, it's a new one?
Wait, that means, like, he's not alone now!
You're not alone, Grandpa.
What do you think of my old home, little one?
It was full of life once.
Sags coming and going, swapping stories of places they've been and the passengers they met.
For a long time now, I considered myself the only one remaining, the last snag.
But being the nest again, there's something in the air.
A smell or warmth?
Or perhaps a presence, perhaps?
Other stags have made her way out into the wild world?
Yes, I'll hold on to that hope.
My kin, still alive, still out there, journeying beyond these lands.
But for me, I could never abandon the stagways, not as long as Paggisters still need them.
Um, it's Passenger, it's only me.
I could tell you some important work to do.
I will be your companion as long as my old body still serves.
Let's enjoy the old stagways of this kingdom to you.
together a little longer.
Yay!
I'm his one and only customer.
Yippee, yippee, yippee!
Wait, his name change, right?
It's old stag.
Just give me a... Oh yeah, it did!
He's now old stag.
He's a boomer.
Alright.
Or I believe...
I believe there's a guy here for it, right?
Okay, we updated the map.
How did he kill us?
Or what?
Okay, but I want to attack one, kill one.
Okay, where's the other dream guy?
Where can I kill a dream man?
Is it here?
Oh my god, stop!
Yeah, where is the flawless net?
Where is it?
Is it this way?
From the nest?
Where's the nest?
I don't even remember where he lives.
I know there's a knight here.
Left?
Oh, first boss room.
Okay.
Alright, we'll go there.
Okay, there is like one area I've been went to.
Where is this area?
I haven't been here before.
Apparently.
like how do i do this like here what is this what is this oh it's a charm wait we need that we need more charm slots anyway we need charms anyway so that's good i don't know where to go i'll go this way just because i can i'll go right Oh, it's a trap.
A fucking course.
It's always a trap!
Okay.
Just pooping babies.
Are you serious?
You hit up.
Oh my god, I hate you.
That's right.
Of course you spawn into me.
Oh, your babies!
Your fucking babies!
Nice.
Why is there a heart beating below me?
Whose heart is that?
Oh, it's your heart.
Yoink.
Loing womb.
Can I dream you?
Is that what
God, Soda, man.
What's that?
I'm just a little baby.
Oh, wait.
My...
Oh, gross.
I'm in his juices.
I'm in our fucking juices.
That's gross.
Oh.
juice.
That's nasty.
All right, I got this way.
What even is that?
What is the womb?
Glowing womb.
What?
Drains the soul of his bearer and uses it to birth hatchlings?
The hatchlings have no desire to eat or live and will sacrifice.
of jesus fucking christ that's fucked up it's really fat that's a little messed up not gonna lie i have a charm that that lets me get get little babies that will kill themselves for me Little grubs.
Ooh.
Who's crying?
Is that him?
Wait, is that him?
Is this?
Are you crying?
Whoa!
Oh, is that your brother?
Oh.
Dream!
Oh no no no no no no no no!
Wake up, brother, help me!
They're like, brother, help!
That's just a little sad.
Not gonna lie.
Is this where he lives?
Where does he live?
Oh, here.
Right?
Yeah.
I legitimately forgot his movesets.
It's been so long, guys.
I don't know how to kill him.
It's been so...
I don't think I'm first trying this just because I forgot what he does.
I...
Oh my god.
Oh, yeah, no, I'm fucked.
No, this is fucked up.
Oh.
Hey, I'm back.
Wait, I'm gonna watch if he can kill himself.
Come on.
That's right.
Oh, his head's too big.
That's so sad.
Wake up.
Oh, that's so sad.
His head's too big.
Oh, he also deals double...
God, fucking...
They all do double damage.
A fucking Qursi also...
Oh, whoops.
I shall wake up.
I'm back!
Hello!
I woke up from my coma.
Okay.
You don't sound too sad about it.
Oh, I know that.
Yeah, because I'm like, why does it go that way?
i'm so confused like what's over here oh it's just a long oh it's the longer way to get there yeah because i look like why is that why does that go up i see it's just a longer way to do get there okay okay That's annoying, actually.
Okay, that also does damage, too.
That does damage on him.
Okay.
Oh, this guy's hard.
Wait.
This guy's hard.
Yeah.
I see now.
Okay.
Wait, actually, give me your shit.
I need some of my souls.
Okay.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
All right.
I'm trying to figure his pattern out.
I don't remember if I could, like, walk up to him or not.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
He's serious.
Oh, why?
Oh, I am awake again.
Do I have a bench nearby?
Oh, I do.
Do I need a...
You know what?
Yeah, fuck it.
I'm gonna grab...
I'm gonna grab a bench.
Alright.
I'm gonna grab a bench real quick.
I'll be back.
Ooh.
More bench.
Here?
Wait, did they block my bench?
No, right?
Okay.
Wait, did these blobs block?
Oh, they blocked it.
Oh, goddamn stupid blobs.
Stupid fucking infection.
God stupid.
God damn it.
Man.
I'm so mad.
It's their bench now.
You can jump away when they...
Alright, I'm gonna grab...
Okay.
Okay, there we go.
Alright.
Dream!
Alright, I don't want to...
I don't want to go all the way to the stag.
I'll figure this out.
Okay.
Oh my god.
This is annoying, actually.
That's actually so annoying.
Holy shit.
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
That's so annoying!
I need to figure out his attack pattern.
They're farming guys.
Farm you of essence.
I can dash through his attacks.
Yeah, but it's still pretty annoying though.
All right.
I think it's also because of the fucking curse.
Yeah, the room environment.
It's like the kin thing again.
It's the room environment.
I think if I didn't have...
I think if I didn't have to deal with the room, yeah.
If I didn't have to deal with the fucking rocks as well.
Okay.
Holy shit It's like an actual like Skill jump between Between like the bosses
Alright Okay I'm gonna try and just do a range Are you serious?
Oh my god he
just Oh Oh my god I don't think I need the dream thing.
Oh my god, he's comboing me!
Oh yeah, I was like, I didn't think I could do it from here.
Holy shit.
Okay, I'm gonna try and figure out his combos and what to do.
I think it's just that.
Oh my god.
I'm trying to figure out a playstyle for it.
Like...
I'm trying to figure out a place down for this cat.
Holy shit.
I'm like playing...
I'm like whack-a-mole.
He's just whack-a-moleing me.
Okay.
When he jumps...
Okay, I don't know his...
His jumping attack yet.
I'm trying to figure out his pattern.
Okay, I get it.
I don't get it.
Okay.
I get it.
Okay, I get it now.
Oh, I get it.
I get it.
I figured it out.
I'm figuring it out.
That's it.
Brothers, I'm farming you.
Jimmy!
Your brother's not here to protect you because I killed him!
Yum, yum, yum!
Alright, nice.
I did it.
I figured it out.
I downloaded.
That's right.
Your brother ain't here no more.
He left you alone.
It's just me now.
Oh, shit.
Oh shit.
Sorry, I got too confident.
Okay, shit.
Okay, I understand now.
I do understand.
I just...
I swear to God, I do understand.
Okay, I swear...
Okay.
Sorry, I fucked up.
All right, now I understand.
JK, let me do this again.
I got too overconfident.
Do you really...
there you go i understand now i lock in i lock in for real i like it for real
yeah it's the rhythm guys are you serious
it's okay i like it when i'm one hp I like that risk.
I like the Oh my god Okay, when it's 1 HP, it gets More exciting
What are you doing?
Okay, okay, okay Sorry, I was actually At 99% of the downloaded But Now it's 99.5% Alright, this is it 99.5, but now, now, now I'm at, now, now I'm at 100.
Now I'm at 100 this time, I swear.
I'm locking in.
For real.
What?
Okay, that's fine.
Are you serious?
Okay.
That one was my bad.
Oh, I didn't see him.
I didn't see him.
The rocks covered me.
All right.
I'll just farm it once and then I go back.
I'm totally locked in for real.
The rocks distracted me.
I didn't see where he was jumping in.
I swear I understand.
For real.
Okay.
Ah, the stupid rock.
I don't double jump it because yeah see Someone said just double jump But I can't because it's the timing You have to double jump it super early Oh I didn't listen Why did I listen?
Yeah Dashing is easier I'll just dash
Yeah Alright
Okay Okay
Oh shit.
Oh fuck!
Get out of here!
Okay.
Oh my god, why did I dash?
Why did I dash towards him?
Why did I not dash towards him?
Okay.
Boom!
I forgot what the run was that I did the best at.
Is it?
God.
I should have killed your brothers.
You're so lucky that I need your brothers for...
You're so lucky.
I need to farm your brothers.
Oh my god.
I accidentally walked up.
I walked up to his beef fucking body.
Okay.
Oh my god.
It's actually disorienting me though.
Jesus Christ, the rocks!
The fucking rocks!
Too much shit on my screen!
Oh.
It's okay.
I don't need to change my charm.
It's too far.
The only reason why I don't change my charm.
charms it's too far i'm too lazy oh my god okay i'm restarting this run i'm restarting this run jesus yeah rock slide don't they know flying is weak against rock
flying is weak against rock what am i supposed to do and Bug, too!
Rock smashes bug!
It's not fair!
Oh, I thought he was gonna jump.
Not gonna lie.
I hit that rock because of course I did.
Oh, fucking course I hit the rock!
Oh my god.
I hate them.
I'm killing one of the brothers
I hate them And then I'll kill you after I kill him I let my anger out on the living
That's right I killed y'all Brother, what you gonna do about that?
That's fucking right.
Oh, shit.
That's what he's gonna do.
That's what he's gonna do to me.
Whoa, shit.
That's right.
Wait, is his body still there?
Oh, and it's God.
That means he's hanging out.
That's right.
I killed your brother in the living.
I can't kill you here in the dream.
I'll kill your fucking brothers.
I'll kill your family.
In-game.
Oh my god, it's stupid.
Okay, that was just me being mad.
Oh, I thought I could...
Oh my god, these...
This move is so annoying, actually.
That hits me?
I don't even see him!
Oh, you think you can just run?
Oh, you're so...
You're so lucky.
In fact, he did think he can just run.
okay are you serious that oh
my god it's the rocks
i thought you was gonna jump locked in i'm locked i'm gonna okay i'm gonna full trial right here i'm gonna full focus the rocks are evil the rocks are so evil
Oh Fucking course he tries to slap me now
Hmm It's that it's that thing
Holy shit is he actually the hardest dream boss?
Oh my god, this better be fucking one worth it.
It's very...
Oh my god.
Are you serious?
He's...
Okay, he's not.
Whoops.
Okay, thank god.
Thank god he's not the hardest dream boss.
I think it's just the environment.
The environment fucks me up the most.
I'm pretty sure.
Oh my god!
And I'm like, we're...
What is...
me what did me
as long as you fighting me you won't kill my auction print came into it had a bunch of extras including chocolate chocolate no it was slightly melted no don't let me thank you for the chance of soup i'm glad it came in today did it get on the print it is I hope it didn't get on the print roll.
I hope it didn't get on it.
I included chocolate because it was one of my favorite chocolate.
No, it was, thank God.
Okay, I was really worried it got on it.
Alright, that's good.
That's good.
I'm glad it arrived safely.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
That's good.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my god.
I just realized it doesn't like...
Are you serious?
Okay, that's fine.
Oh, nice!
Okay, I figured it out.
Okay, I figured out the pattern.
Okay, whoops.
He has a second buff!
Never mind.
I was like, what's that move?
What was that move?
Okay, now I know.
Now I know what to do.
I'll just dash through.
Alright.
Yeah.
I was like, yay!
I was like, wait, I've never seen that before.
Alright.
Oh.
That sucks.
I didn't think you would do that first.
Are you serious?
Oh, I'm restarting this.
I'm restarting it.
Yeah.
Okay.
I know.
Heal and stagger.
Yeah, I'll heal and stagger next time.
It's so far.
I can't change it.
No, you don't understand.
I'm too lazy to go back.
Now, I'm just stubborn now.
You don't understand.
I'm stubborn as hell.
Oh my god, the rock got me!
Okay.
All right.
Okay, he does this.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Are you serious?
Oh, it's because I already dashed.
Oh, I don't have time to do the thing now.
Oh, oh, I just was like, wait, why can't I dash through it?
It's because of my cooldown.
Okay, I get it.
I realized my cooldown ran out.
I was like, wait, I can't dash through him anymore.
Can't confirm.
I smiled at him when he all came.
But it made me happy, included it.
Wait, what do you mean?
The child is good.
It was good chocolate.
It was good.
Takeda, thank you for magenta, so far.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm glad it didn't get on the print.
That makes me happy.
Yippee, yippee.
Didn't get on the print.
I would have been worried if it did.
I hope it didn't get anywhere else.
Okay, maybe I shouldn't have included chocolate.
I should have included candy.
I didn't think about that.
Because I like, my place is air conditioned.
so I never thought about things melting.
I'm just a little stupid there.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm, I'm like, I'm stumbling now.
Oh, okay.
I might reset this run.
I'm like, messing up when I shouldn't be.
Oh, god damn it.
I thought he was gonna jump.
I got distracted because I was happy everything is going arriving safely
all right all right there you I'm slowly downloading holy shit the dream bosses are are it's like the thing about it is like it feels like uh what's
It's definitely like a huge skill jump from what it was before.
Yeah, from what it...
From the normal bosses to the dream bosses is like a huge skill jump.
The difficulty spike.
Okay.
all right okay i'm gonna try and lock in now for these runs because it's taking too long and i'm angry three in a row jesus he's fucking greedy
oh my god there's so many rocks oh my god he just uses these attacks that's so oh it's just all these attacks
the fact that it was just these attacks too
oh my god not the rocks oh my god i didn't have dash oh Oh my god.
The damn rocks.
I have double.
What the fuck I'm playing Dream?
Of course I have double jump.
Oh, you can nail him down.
You can nail him when he's staggered.
I just...
I can't do a double jump when he's too close.
Because like...
Um...
Like, see, I can't time that.
For those who are like, oh, just double jump it.
Jesus Christ.
I might have to do a rerun for this.
Forgetting the cooldown.
No, this guy's harder because the environment is harder.
He does double hit and, like, the rocks are harder.
Okay.
Alright.
I had...
Uh...
You can dash away and then double jump faster than you think, but that depends on the reaction.
Yeah, I could do that, but...
I'll do this for now.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Okay, I'll eat.
Wait, I thought you said doesn't stack.
Wait, what?
He got back up.
You guys said he wouldn't get back up.
You guys lied.
Wait.
Oh.
I
read Nell and I instinctively used Nell.
Oopsie.
Someone said Nell and I used Nell.
Oh.
Oh no!
I've written it!
And then I went...
No?
Oh!
Oh no!
I've written it!
No, it's so much harder now.
Ah!
Okay.
I guess I'll go grab and swap my charms.
I guess I'll swap my charms now.
Okay, what?
I fucked up.
I'm sad.
I'm so sad.
What do I swap to anyone?
I gotta remember how to get there.
Not my fault.
I read now.
Wait, so how do I...
Wait, but like, he does...
Okay, I'll get rid of this long nail swarm.
And then we'll do...
God, it makes me feel like I could...
Mark of Pride.
And then this.
There you go.
I don't know what fragile charms are.
What is fragile charms?
What do you guys mean by fragile charm?
What is that?
Then he'll make some dream that'll laugh faster.
Wait.
What the fuck is fragile?
I don't know what fragile charms are.
Oops.
Get away from me!
Wait, where's the other one?
Alright, at least I'm full.
Oh, I don't know how to get them.
And don't go away when... Oh!
It's too late.
It's fine.
It's okay.
We'll figure this out.
Okay, so what do you guys... You guys said he doesn't stagger.
How do I do it?
Because I did the dream now thing.
I do dream now and then what?
Pogo him?
And then what?
I don't know how to make it.
Because you said he can't get up by himself, but I dream nailed him and he got up.
Dream nailed twice and hit him?
Oh, Dream now of the armor!
Oh!
Okay.
One hit, then hit him on the...
I don't know if I can actually do that.
I'll try.
Okay, pull go the armor.
Okay, I'll try and do that.
Okay, I already fucked it up.
Oh my god, I fucked it up twice.
No!
Oh, no!
Oh, I restart...
I'm killing me.
I fucked up.
I got my timing messed up.
I'm like, I'm overthinking.
Okay.
We'll grab our stuff at the bottom.
I was overthinking, guys.
I was overthinking.
Oh my god, I hate these guys so much.
It's okay.
I get money at least.
At least I get money.
No,
I have to beat him now.
I have to beat him.
I don't care if he's one of the hardest.
I have to beat him now.
I'm invested.
No, I'm invested.
I don't give up.
Oh my god.
I hate that, though.
Are you serious?
Oh my god, really?
I missed the pattern.
Oh, he landed on me!
Hey.
I wish his brothers were still alive.
Oh, no.
I keep forgetting that guy explodes.
Wonder what happened to him.
I wonder what happened to them.
Whose fault is that?
Couldn't be me.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I don't remember killing no brother.
Yeah, we're up here.
Obviously.
I don't remember killing no brother.
Who could it be?
Maybe I just need to be six on.
Are you serious?
Okay.
The fucking rock!
Oh, that's it.
I don't want to farm anymore.
We'll just brute force it.
Okay.
A fucking course.
A fucking course!
Oh my god!
I got hit by four rocks!
We are not fighting a different boss!
We're right or die!
Oh, I shouldn't have dashed that.
I don't know.
Really?
That hits me?
Oh my god.
I'll never back down.
I know Quitter like the traitor Mantis.
This one is actually...
This one is my filter now.
Oh my god.
He's too...
He takes up 20% of the screen.
Oh my god He actually takes up like So much of the screen though Like no lie
Oh I should have dashed under him Yeah I ain't no quitter
Yeah I am I am calling him fat He takes up like Not even 20% Oh Oh my god Oh
my god
Three times Three times Three times What is this RNG?
The fact that he has three fucking staggers
okay oh my god it's fine at least i'm fine we're getting hit by the rock
what hit me what the fuck hit me i'm angry
i'm angry
fucking course oh fucking course the rock
give me other here get me out of here oh
get me out of here oh my god the stupid rock the stupid rock
i wish i didn't kill the brothers no the brother no it wasn't my fault the brothers mysteriously died of heart attacks yokey you didn't do it the accident wasn't your fault
are you serious he lands on me oh my god
oh i shouldn't have dashed that way
they died of heart attacks guys and then a nail was on the floor and they fell on the floor the cause of deaths were we did an autopsy and the cause of deaths were i swear the cause of deaths oh my gosh i'm i was looking at chat the cause of death oh my god i need to stop talking
okay pull down
i'm tired he i'm tired Yeah, he tripped over.
No, no.
They got a heart attack and there was a sharp object on the ground.
And then they fell.
Both of them fell on.
Fell on it.
There were two separate nails and they both fell on it.
It truly was very unfortunate.
I don't know.
I just...
I was just done.
I was just so done.
I was...
So done.
Yeah, I have witnesses.
And no, witness is me.
Alright.
Eventually I'll lock in.
it's now!
No, we're not changing.
I will smash my head against this wall until it's over.
I am stubborn.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
You can tell I'm like heavily focused right now.
Every time I talk.
Every time I talk, I'm getting out of my rhythm.
So I should stop that.
Okay.
What?
I hit the rocks.
Are you serious?
Okay.
I figured...
I figured it out.
There's no...
I can't time it in a way where I can jump over it.
Every time I try to jump over it, I get hit.
Oh my gosh.
I think it's just reflexive for that.
Unlucky.
I'm just gonna tank this one.
There's a rock above me.
Oh my god.
Okay, I could jump.
Okay.
I'll show you guys what happens when I try jumping.
He just does it too close to me.
I'll show you guys.
We tried it before, and it's...
I just get...
He was just too close to me.
Fucking course.
Okay.
Oh, of course he does that.
Oh!
Yeah, but then he's lame.
He gets too close to me.
When I do the jump.
He just gets too close to me.
That's why I do the dash.
See?
He's too close.
We're back out a little bit.
See?
Oh.
I don't know.
The jumping is throwing me off more.
The jumping throws me off way more than dashing.
I'm going to do my old playstyle.
Because I did the...
I progressed the most with my old playstyle more.
Okay, I'm gonna be more cautious here.
See?
I'll back away just because.
Oh, I didn't realize he was in front of me.
That's unlucky.
I didn't realize he was gonna, he was in front of me.
All right.
All right, okay.
Oops.
I'm going to reset this.
I'm resetting this.
I was trying to...
I had to hydrate.
I had to reset it.
I had to drink water.
Because I'm thirsty.
This is the biggest wall I've hit.
For sure.
Oh, no.
I wanted to double jump.
Oh.
Oh, I already used my dash.
I didn't know.
Oh.
The rocks.
Not fair.
Not the rocks.
Why can't the RNG of the rocks be closed before they're away?
Oh my god, are you sure we used rocks again?
Burn it!
Your mom fucking hated you.
That's why you're orphans.
At least my mom's still alive.
Surely the other dreams are like easier, right?
Surely.
I'm fucking curious I get hit by the rock.
This is a rock day.
All right.
Whoa.
Three.
Wait, how did that not hit me?
Whoa.
Nice.
I'm yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
I'm yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
What?
Okay, I threw that.
Oh, I threw that.
I'm sorry.
I threw.
I got scared.
Okay, I think I got it.
I think I downloaded it for real now.
Okay.
It's a hard...
You know what?
Fuck this.
Now it's...
Now it'll be easy.
This is all I need.
I just need a big wick.
Oh shit.
You know, I thought he would.
Oh my god, not the goddamn rock.
Yeah.
Oh, what?
Nice.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I'm alcoholic now.
Look, look,
look, look, look, look.
Give me a sec.
I gotta be an alcoholic.
Alcoholic.
Good little luck.
I gotta be an alcoholic still.
I gotta keep being an alcoholic.
There you go.
Okay, that's unlucky.
That is so unlucky.
Oh my god, that is so unlucky for me!
Okay, I think I did my best run as Rick.
That's Rick Sanchez.
I think I lock it hard.
It has Rick Sanchez.
I figured it out.
Wait, what the fuck?
Couldn't like...
Oh my god, that's unlucky.
Oh, I think it does the dash...
Not the rocks.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Okay.
JK.
Maybe not as Rick Sanchez.
Okay.
Maybe it's time.
This feels like the dark souls of...
This feels like the dark souls of Metrovania.
Maybe it's time.
Okay.
It's the dark souls of Metrovania.
It feels a Appropriate.
Praise the sun.
Oh god.
Oh shit.
I didn't think that he was doing that move.
Are you serious?
There we go.
I'm drinking my flask real quick.
Okay.
Drinking the flask.
drinking my estes
are you oh my god
he baited me he baited me so hot
he actually baited me so hot he got out of
I will beat him if it's I swear to you guys I swear I feel like the last boss, it's gonna be easier than this shit.
I will never give up.
I ain't no quitter.
That's because I should never corner him.
I need to give him enough room.
Because he can't do his little, the speed.
He can't do his little thingy when I'm too far from him.
I feel like playing I feel like I'm playing the dark souls right now of Metrovania this feels like how I feel normally in dark souls someone praise the Sun for me if you praise the Sun you'll free me
praise the Sun to free me from this torment yeah
oh Um, stupid rock.
Okay.
He's gonna do the fire strike.
Oh my god, he's gonna keep doing the fire strike.
Oh!
They hit the rock!
One day, I'll see what the second stagger looks like.
One day.
Okay.
This is why I started the stream at 4 12 30.
I knew this was going to be a long haul
Oh, what?
Okay
Really?
Too many rocks.
I can't believe There's there's such a thing as too many rocks Too many rocks rocks too many rocks if only i could level him up my vigor i know okay that's my bad
oh that was accident i didn't mean to dash into him
what what oh no i'm degrading oh Quick boss fight in and out.
Five minutes.
Papa Smert.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We will die here on this stream.
Until I defeat the stupid boss.
Call your loved ones.
Oh my god.
That's right.
We will die here.
Make sure to call your loved ones.
God damn it.
Oh, of course, of course.
Here we go.
This will be your final resting place at this particular boss.
This might as well be the true ending.
This is my true ending, killing him.
I feel like the rocks never fell before
It was only for It's only for this dream land where the rocks fell right Because I swear to God I feel like they know I feel like the environment wasn't involved in this area Oh my god that was on me I got greedy there I don't remember He was the first one I ever fought
I'm trying to just go straight to the parkour.
Oh, wait, I can't.
Because I need my essence, too.
I forgot.
I can't even.
Oh, the rock messed with the timing.
Oh.
He didn't do it.
That was his jump back.
I'll see the first dagger again someday.
I believe it.
I believe I'll see it.
It's there.
It's right there.
Okay, he does his fire strike.
Okay, he does his fire strike when he jumps back, which I've noticed now.
Okay, fire strike.
Fire strike.
Nice!
Okay.
Fine, we're just chilling here.
Until this tempered chantrum is good.
Okay, he did not...
Okay.
Okay, fire strike.
Alright, that was not a jump back, but that's okay.
Alright.
Dream!
Okay.
Okay, we're going back here a little bit.
Okay, fire strike.
Oh, fire strike.
Fire strike.
Oh, shit!
Oh.
Dream?
Assess, assess, assess.
Look,
look, look, look, look, look, look.
look oh oh oh gosh no okay all right what wait is it higher oh my god is it higher what happened why couldn't jump in anymore that was the closest oh that was the closest i couldn't i and jump it!
Oh my god, that was the furthest I've ever got!
I got the pattern down.
Fire strike!
I just gotta call it out.
Oh my god.
I think I just have to call it out.
It's doing again.
What the fuck?
So many.
Oh,
I got a pattern down finally at least.
Okay, nice.
Dream!
Oh wait, I didn't need to do that.
Oh my God, I didn't need to do that.
Oh my God, I was, I got to, oh I panicked.
I panicked there.
Oh!
No, I panicked!
Oh, ah, strike!
Ugh!
Fuck!
Dream!
Oh,
fire strike!
Yeah, do it!
Oh, fuck.
Fire strike!
That's the only way I have to call it out so I know he's gonna do what he didn't back up
I know that's a five strike oh wait another five strike
back He didn't jump back!
No!
I don't know!
He didn't jump back!
Oh!
Oh shit.
Wait, what?
You're- Yeah, but I have to- Wait, wait.
I can't- You can't keep in down if you don't want dream now to yeah i'm using the dream now to heal why am i making it harder because i i want it to heal wait why am i wait did my thing froze whoops
wait is that not what i'm supposed to do i thought people were telling me a dream though yeah i needed to solve to heal because i was one hp do i just keeping one HP?
No, I wanted to, I dreamed that I had him to heal.
Oh, I can only do one thing.
Oh.
Oh, I can only do...
Oh, so when I heal, I pogo.
Yeah, I know it doesn't do damage.
I'm trying to... I don't care that I'm not doing damage to his face.
I just want to heal.
Because I have no HP.
That's what I'm doing.
Okay, I'm resetting.
Because I was talking to chat.
I'm going to reset.
Am I not supposed...
Okay, I'll stop healing then.
Since you guys told me to stop healing.
I won't heal.
I just focus on the face.
I thought I was supposed to heal.
I'll just...
stop healing.
I don't know why I'm...
Why am I paused?
Wait.
Why is my motto?
Why is my skin suit broken?
Hmm.
Okay, now it's back.
And I fix it?
Oh,
stop healing.
Because you guys told me to.
Okay.
Fire strike!
Fast strike!
Oh shit.
Okay, he's backing up.
Fast strike!
He's doing another one.
Okay.
Okay, he's gonna do a fast strike here.
Fast strike!
Oh my god.
That was, I should have went up harder.
Fast strike!
Oh no!
Don't worry.
Fast strike!
Oh!
I dashed too close.
I'm out of my rhythm now.
Okay, he's gonna do the fast strike.
He's gonna do it again.
Oh my god, so soon?
Oh my god, stop!
Okay, I need Tim to be...
Dude, why are you doing so much fast?
Fast strike, Minoyaki.
Again?
You're so greedy.
Holy shit.
Learn something new.
Okay, nice.
Now he's using something new.
Oh, my God.
Fast strike.
Nice.
Okay.
There you go.
I'm gonna back up, because I feel like I won't be able to see when he does his thing.
Okay, fire strike.
Fire strike.
Oh, shit!
Oh, my God.
I dived into the rocks.
That's unlucky for me.
Okay, I need to make him back up a little bit more.
Fire strike!
I had a feeling I was going to do a random fire strike there.
Because he's super...
Fire strike.
What?
Oh!
He landed on me!
Okay.
Calling fire strike actually helps me so.
much because it makes me aware when he's doing it it makes my brain be like oh he's gonna fire strike i was like yes yes he is what oh it's just a fire strike it's because i didn't call it out see i told you i told you oh my god oops
i told you only when i call it out am i aware of the fire strike Fire strike.
Fire strike.
Oh.
What the fuck?
That was such a small jump.
When did you become a goddamn fucking baby?
Alright, here we go.
Fucking baby.
Oh, what?
Fire strike.
Oh, shit.
Doing things that I'm not used to.
Fire strike.
Fire strike!
It's so fucking dumb.
It's the only way you don't understand.
Fire strike!
Aww I thought you would, like, jump further.
Legitimately thought you would jump further.
Alright.
Fire strike!
Please die.
I'm trying to get the fire strike going.
Oh shit, fire strike.
Fire strike.
Fire strike!
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Can I just do that?
Okay, I don't know how...
Okay, fire strike time.
Fire strike!
shit.
Oh.
Okay, fire strike time.
Fire strike!
Okay.
Oh, fire strike!
He jumped forward, so I was expecting it!
Whoa Fire strike fire
strike fire strike Oh fire strike fire strike fire strike He's fire striking when he's close Fire strike fire strike Fire strike now It's the third phase!
Five strikes!
Oh!
Fire strike!
Okay.
Firestrength!
Firestrength!?
Hello?
That's it.
It's time.
I'm yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo, y'all.
Get in my belly.
I'm so hungry.
That's it.
That's right.
Get in my belly.
What I saw that night sleeping safe in this big armored shell.
It wasn't madness that drove me to it.
I just wanted it.
But in the end, if strength cannot save you, then what can?
That's fucking right.
in my belly.
Get in!
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
I fucking finally did it.
Oh my god.
It's...
Sorry.
I was on dialed up.
I finally downloaded.
Oh my god.
I finally locked it.
We fucking did it.
Hey, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Oh my god, I actually fucking did it.
That was, oh my god.
That was actually my wall.
That was my, I'm gonna feed dad.
I, you're back, he's hungry.
He wants his dinner.
Go ahead, thank you for that.
Give the shit, thank you, thank you.
Oh,
that was my biggest wall there.
Oh, that is, yeah, I finally, I figured it out.
I...
Oh my god.
I swear to God.
I feel like the end boss would not be as hard as that.
There's no way.
Oh my god.
Biggest wall.
So far.
It must stream like for my surgery tomorrow.
Well, I'm not nervous.
It does make me sad.
I won't be able to use my hand for a while.
Oh my god.
I hope you get luck with your surgery.
And I hope your recovery is fast.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Holy fuck.
That was actually so hard.
It was the times two damage.
We're financially, we do not go after the other Dream bosses.
You can get Dream 1800 off just the Dream Warriors now.
Oh, shit.
Let's go.
Yay.
Or unless, what if, okay, what if I do one more Dream boss?
That's cute.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You can't stop me.
I'm gonna go after one more dream boss wherever he is unless
You can't tell me what to do That's right.
I don't know where it is though.
I don't know where any of the that was the only dream boss I knew
All right, which is okay now which one is the easy.
Okay, this is bad because I actually don't know where to go.
So Unsanctum.
Wait, isn't he a hard boss?
Are you sure he's easier?
I'm yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum.
Where is the...
I don't remember where it is.
Because I can't read this map.
Where the fuck is the tram?
Oh, wait.
here wait no wait how do i get home i don't have a compass okay it's down down okay it's down
there it is
but it was some love your energy d thank you for the super chat thank you thank you we did it we fucking did we persevered look at that i told you guys were like do another boss And I was like, no!
No!
Call your loved ones.
We're gonna die here.
That's right.
We are not quitters.
We're not fucking quitters.
Okay.
You'll never be free.
All right.
Which is the easy...
Okay.
Which is the...
There is an easy bus.
Okay.
I don't...
I can see.
Not yet.
Because we're going to do another bus.
All right.
Which one?
Go to city.
Is he actually...
Is Soul Tyrant actually easier than the Dung Beetle?
It...
Which one's easier?
The soul or the tongue beat up?
No double damage?
Smile.
Yes, smile.
He doesn't do double damage.
Alright.
Okay, where is it?
Where is Soul Tired?
Dayplay.
you.
I can't fucking trust any of you guys.
Alright.
Soul Sanctum.
Where the fuck?
Where's that?
Where do I go?
Store room or king station?
City store rooms and go up to the left tower.
Oh.
Go to the left tower?
Okay.
I'd I play and got stuck at Matt.
The senior brute force This boss has inspired me to Continue.
I need dragon Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Never give up.
Alright.
Is this the... Okay.
Let's grab the charm Shit, I guess.
Alright, we had this and we had Market Pride.
Okay.
Alright, so we're at The city store room.
Which is here.
Alright.
Where do we go?
where is it okay we're gonna uh we're gonna figure out okay where is it we don't have a compass so I'm just gonna I think we're here right now we're here so down and right where is it guys okay okay now what down okay now where do I go yeah here Yeah?
Where he died here?
This is where he died?
I don't remember.
Is it where I killed him?
Yes.
Okay.
We technically don't have like a compass so we're gonna, we're gonna figure this out.
We spent 80 years in that area.
Poor M.
Okay, we can do this by going down.
I remember.
No, I know a sinner.
Don't worry, I read how to get the true ending, so I know all their names now.
Oh, just go, right?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, well.
Now we're here.
Okay.
Okay, now we're here.
We go down.
And then right.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
I think that's right.
I'm like, yeah.
And then we go right.
And then we should be able to go up from here.
I'm like trying to figure out where we are.
Okay, from here.
We go up.
This way.
And then from... Oh, hey, nice.
Oh, shit.
I forgot about these fuckers.
Okay, let's just...
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Okay.
And then...
Now we're here.
So we gotta go right up, up, up, and then left.
Oh, God, not these guys.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
And then now...
Are we...
The right?
I don't know.
Are we here?
Where are we?
No.
No, no, no.
We gotta go up.
When we're up.
Oh, I hate these guys so much.
They're actually so annoying.
Oh, my God.
They're so lucky.
I can't even reach them.
Get away from it!
Okay, there we go.
With pure anger, I shall live.
Except for that guy.
Okay, now we go left.
Wait, what?
Why did I dash backwards?
Okay.
Yeah?
Is this where... Oh, there he is.
Hello, sir.
Now I'm gonna bash my head against your wall.
Yippee!
Another header, another one to bash.
Here we go.
I'm gonna get yelled at for this boss.
I forgot his movesets, by the way.
Like, yep.
Yep.
That sounds about right.
Oh my god.
Because he's faster, I don't remember what he does.
Oh, he does an extra five strike.
Okay.
Okay, I get it.
I get it.
All right.
He does a five strike too, so I have to be aware of that.
Yeah, he fakes me.
I was really forgot what he does.
I was like, who are you?
Yeah, he does that.
How the fuck?
Okay.
I just need to download his playstyle.
It's fine.
Okay.
I can't jump.
that how the fuck how do I do that okay it's always a fire strike yeah he's some magic man I can jump it okay because if I have to dash and then or I could walk it and then dash because I had the I was dashing his initial strike okay I'm gonna see if I can I'm gonna see if I can like When he...
Okay.
Oh my god, okay.
What?
Okay.
I was trying to figure out...
Yeah, I need to like figure out how to get rid of the deal with that one.
I didn't know.
deal is that okay i got run while jumping i know oh fuck whoops man thank you for the red thank you thank you i'm doing a dream boss right now it's pretty intense i'm holding my chat hostage we fought a boss for like so that okay okay whoops i'm trying to download this boss ah i can't download it
It's all right.
It was all a dream.
I hope you had a great stream, Theta.
All right, here we go.
Now, now we lock in.
Why is Doki?
It's a grub's life out here.
I'm here to find my brothers.
Brothers!
All right, here we go.
I'm trying to download.
I'm on download!
It's really hard to download.
Down!
Oh, shit!
Okay.
I'm gonna die, though.
You're like, I have so little opportunity to kill them.
Yeah.
Oh, fuck.
The...
I hate nerds.
Alright, here you go.
Ah, thank you for the one gift that ships!
Thank you, thank you!
you god damn nerds oh shit oh i'm sorry i didn't mean you i swear to god i didn't mean you
are you serious if i bump into him that shouldn't cause me damage unlucky
someone's on the phone so I can't download it correctly thank you for the other raid I didn't see what was in the Eddie sorry I didn't see your name just then I was trying to lock in but I have my buffering right now thank you for the super chat thank you thank you for the raid thank you thank you
okay all right I gotta figure out this pattern
All right, I think when he does his jukes, that's when I have to worry.
Okay, nice.
Are you serious?
Fuck you, I don't care.
Also, I don't care.
I feel like I can heal too.
Okay, that hits him at least.
I'll tank it.
Woo!
Just a little guy.
Yippee!
Oh shit.
No yippee's for me.
Alright.
Okay, I got it.
I got the pattern.
Get over here!
Oh, shit, not here!
I didn't mean there!
That's not what I mean!
They're like, you told him to get over here.
Okay, but not like that.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Are you serious?
How do you even see where I am?
Oh Oh
Oh Oh Oh Oh Shit Oh At least I got the stagger Oh Oh Oh.
Okay, that hit him.
That's good.
Please!
Okay, I got one hit.
Nice.
Got the other dash.
Oh!
Okay, I know that hits him at least.
And I get free hit here.
Oh my god, I hope he does this more.
At the jump?
Oh, shit!
Wrong direction!
Please get over here.
All right.
Oh, that was close.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
I pressed nail instead of magic.
Eh.
Oh, you know what?
Fuck this.
Ah, shit, I'm sorry.
I didn't mean it!
Okay, maybe...
Maybe I should have eight more.
Yeah, I should have eight more.
I got greedy.
The greed was real.
I got so greedy.
I was like...
Oh!
That was close.
Okay, oh shit second face.
Oh, I forgot he had a second face.
No, no!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh my god.
Oh, my god.
Oh, I don't remember what you're doing against the second face.
I don't remember.
Oh, I don't remember.
Oh!
Oh, he fucked up.
Fucking gorgeous I forgot he had another face I was like
My Please Okay, okay Now I know Now I know Okay I was like I'm dead it.
I was like Yippee, yippee, yippee!
I forgot about the second face.
I figured it out, though.
I got faked out.
This isn't even my final.
Oh, shit!
Okay, that was just me fucking up.
Are you serious?
Okay.
Please.
No, no, no, no, no, my bad.
That was me.
I'm still, like, thinking about that second phase.
Oh, my.
Whoops.
I'm still thinking about it.
Are you serious?
Oh, my gosh.
I'm fumbling.
I'm still thinking about it, guys.
And it's living rent-free in my head.
Whoa!
Oh my god.
I don't know why I'm fumbling now.
I'm sorry.
It just lives rent-free.
Oh no.
I might have to reset.
He's living rent-free in my head.
I can't help it.
That's not looking good.
Oh, so many.
Thank you for giving me the chance.
Thank you.
Okay.
It's okay.
It's okay now.
I'm Zen.
I'm focused.
I'm so focused.
All right.
What?
whoa there you go whoa whoa okay that's good he did that twice I really appreciate that I knew I didn't even move up I didn't even look up I swear to God I swear to God I didn't look up it's fake news
You know I don't look up!
Gamers don't look up!
You know it was fake news!
Alright.
There you go.
Gamers don't look up.
Exactly!
You know I would have done it on purpose!
Oh, that's close.
Oh my god, that juke!
That was a really good juke.
Are you serious?
Here we go.
Oh, shit.
I got a leaf, though.
I gotta leave.
Oh, that was close.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, I was too short.
Tricking.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh!
There you go.
Nice, I got it.
Okay, no juke here.
Are you serious?
That hits me?
Okay, that was bullshit.
It got me on the tip.
The tip got me.
Okay, nice.
That hit.
Oh my god.
We're such a bitch.
You're actually such a bitch.
Too short!
Short.
King!
Nice.
I really appreciate when he does that.
I will never stop doing the magic.
Magic good.
For only this one moment.
One time I say magic good.
Okay.
Nice.
No, no, no!
No heal.
Oh my god.
And then he does that instantly.
That's so fun.
Oh.
That hold me.
I can't believe I accidentally magic.
Oh!
Magic good went on my side.
We will get the true ending.
I will kill him.
Oh my god!
Excuse me?
I was there first.
I...
That's so annoying.
That's Ashley's so annoying.
Holy fuck.
Okay.
What?
There you go.
No!
No one's seeing their family!
We will die here!
I know, right?
He's out of...
What?
That's right.
No one's seeing their family.
until I beat until I get the true ending oh my what wait did you guys see that what the fuck happened yeah what the fuck happened he actually cancelled me.
Wait, he's cheating!
He actually did an animation cancel.
That's cheating!
He plays street fighter.
God damn, nerd.
Are you serious?
There you go.
Okay.
Okay!
I don't know how...
I don't even...
I have to, like, not touch my controller at all to make sure it doesn't, like, accidentally go up.
That's the most annoying part.
Are you serious?
Oh my god.
Yeah, I have to, like, let go of my controller.
Okay.
Oh my god, he literally did it in front of my face.
I...
That's it.
I'm eating.
Oh, the fake out.
The goddamn fake out.
Okay, I got an extra food.
Angry eat.
Oh, whoops.
I didn't see that.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, now he does this move.
I swear to God, sometimes he doesn't do this move at all.
Oh, oh, oh, fuck.
Okay, I can have one extra E.
Two HP.
And a dream.
He just stood there melissingly and did damage to me.
Phase two.
Yeah.
I have made it further.
Alright.
It's fine.
This boss, I'm not, I'm not tilted.
Because, like, I understand it.
I'm just, like, I'm just...
I'm just messing up because of, like, little small mistakes.
So it's not as bad.
He's just tedious because there's not a lot of, like, openings to kill him.
That's the only tedious part.
Whoops.
Yeah, like, I should have jumped.
The only annoying part is just the fact that there's not enough openings to kill him.
Oh my god, what?
My polo didn't work there.
Okay.
He's not as bad though.
Gotta lock in.
The moment I get like a little bit distracted, it like messes with me.
Oh, he uses one?
Okay.
Like, there's just barely any openings.
And that's, like, the worst part.
Oh.
Okay.
All right.
Okay, that's two hits.
That's good.
I feel like there's barely a time to heal.
The only time I can heal with is when he does his little thing.
Whoa!
Where did he come from?
This part?
Oh, yeah, you're right.
Okay, now I know.
Now I know.
I didn't realize this was enough time.
Ah!
Oh, I live.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
I love that.
Feeding animation.
It's so silly.
Yay!
I'm going to eat in front of you.
Eat your veggies.
Oh, that's good.
Alright.
Oh, I didn't realize I was full HP.
I was really hungry.
Oh.
I really like my veggies.
Look, I was just really into my veggies, guys.
You don't understand.
Oh, shit.
Whoops.
The grub is growing thick and strong.
I'm a strong grub.
Well, shit.
Whoops.
I just love I love it so much It's such a silly animation Makes me so happy
Oh, oh I didn't think he was going to do that
Okay.
Oh, I'm fine!
Gotta grow big and hussy!
There you go.
Here you go.
Stupid man That's not me
Stupid fucking frog sorcerer I could just use magic there
Okay That's close That's good.
I'm glad he used that move.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh my god.
He's so tedious!
I feel like it takes 20 years for me to hit him one- Ah!
For me to hit him one time!
Oh my god, he actually spawned next to me, thank god.
Thank god.
Alright, I'm full HP.
Alright, it's time.
It might not be time, I feel like I could fuck it up.
No, I mean, I could still fuck it up.
Okay, he should appear here now.
Whoa!
Oh.
It's fine.
Whoa!
Oh my god, he's just so diminishing.
Oh my god, he keeps doing it.
Okay, there you go.
Did I do it?
Wait, what's that?
He's...
Oh my god, it was that easy?
Holy!
I can't believe it!
I knew it was that easy!
Oh my god, okay.
In my dreams, I could see it.
The kingdom's salvation.
The cure for the plague.
The answer was in the soul that animate our bodies.
But the king, why?
He opposed everything I did.
His jealousy, his madness.
My saddened gets me.
He robbed me of my mortality.
Now the king is king and we're dead.
But I'll live forever.
Yeah, in my stomach.
Grub still hungry.
I'm like, I like how it looked like I'm patting my stomach.
Yummy.
That was me Hitting my leg Grub still hungry That's it Now that's a belly Not the tummy ASMR I don't get out I'm a very hungry hungry caterpillar.
How do I get out?
I don't have a compass.
I don't have my map.
I don't know how to leave.
How do I get out?
Down?
Okay.
No, I ain't no save scum.
Oh my god!
Why did I go Go down!
What the fuck?
Now up.
Wow guys, thank you.
Well, thank you guys.
Now just go up.
For it.
Just that easy.
Okay, two down.
Two down.
There you go.
Now I could just farm graves or whatever.
I don't know how to do that.
Okay, I think that's enough boss that's gonna still have my parkour shit that I have to do.
The biggest wall was definitely I don't know how to get down.
How do I...
How do I get out of here?
I don't know where I am.
I don't know.
Yeah.
That big boy was so tough.
Now I can fight the easy ones.
I don't even know where they are.
Okay.
Let's grab the map.
Map this and...
What was it?
Oh, it's Grub also in here.
here i don't remember uh oh wait it was wait what was my thing again no it was not this and we are not doing that what did i have was it long now i don't even remember what i had i don't remember my my my rollout my loadout
was it long now
find a pin I need to figure out how to get out of here Oh Okay, we'll go this way
Do I have max no Great upgrade?
Of course not Because I love making things harder for myself Not on purpose of course
I mean I could do the tree here Is it a tree here?
Oh, where's the tree?
Okay, let's just grab the tree and stuff.
This tree, yeah?
What the fuck is that tree?
Oh, trees give like nothing?
Oh, okay, I leave.
Grub leave.
Alright.
So where do we go, chat?
Okay, this guy keeps flying away like a bit.
Fungal waste or how wait where what's howling close and what's fungo waste chat
which one
okay fungo waste okay home first okay I'll go to home first all right I already bought it though I
already bought I already bought the graves shit I have it I remember buying it Is that his little maggot?
Weak as members of the kingdom of Haldunus.
Surely look down upon and force him.
Oh, that is sad.
That's why I fucking killed him.
Doesn't deserve to live.
Okay, fungal waste.
Alright, what do we do?
Fungal waste.
Where is fungal waste?
There he is.
Alright, where do we go?
That's right.
I killed his brothers too.
Alright, where do we go?
Alright, he made... I don't even know how many hours I spent on that guy.
He deserved it.
He fucking deserved it.
And I killed them all!
I made sure their species went extinct.
Yeah.
Isn't these graves?
Aren't these the graves?
Yeah?
Or here?
Yeah, or here?
Here?
Or here?
There?
What's there?
This one?
Okay.
Alright.
Where's the stag?
Okay, Queen Station.
Or City of Tears.
Yeah, City of Tears is the... Wait.
Yeah, City of Tears is the easiest.
Am I already in City of Tears?
No.
Okay.
Alrighty.
This idiot... Wait, what... Which one is that?
Oh, it's closed?
Oh!
It's a queen station then.
Alright.
And then we gotta go right side.
We'll never open this area.
They'll look at me.
No, they said the pathway is apparently closed.
That's why we're not going to that there.
uh right right oh shit
now what okay this way oh wait wait what is that
what is this oh it's another wonders journal all right um wow it's really heading towards me what will happen to me.
up.
She gets this, but not the, it's not that important.
You don't understand.
That journal is much more important than the match card.
Okay, here you go.
Wow!
Come on!
It's Waluigi.
I'll kill your child too.
Ow!
That's mean.
How dare you?
Wait, it's locked.
Should I go from below?
That area is locked.
I will need that bench!
Okay, it's this way.
Oh.
Maybe I do need that bench.
Okay, guys, we're just looking at this.
Guys, where's the bench?
Where is it?
Oh, shit.
Up and left.
Okay.
Where?
Oh, it's cute.
They're running away because they know I'm a murderer.
Oh, it's above me?
Oh, yeah.
I see.
Oh, yeah, I gave up on this because I keep falling into the fucking acid.
Ha ha!
Not anymore, though!
Oh, hello.
Oh my god, who are you?
Don't try to sneak past me.
Oh, leg eater.
I can smell you.
Do you collect a lot, Gio?
Give me Gio, and you see something nice.
Oh, sure.
Yippee, yippee, yippee!
Let me show you then.
Take a look.
Do you want them?
If you really, really want them, I'll trade them for more.
Gio.
Sure.
I mean...
It doesn't really matter.
I'll just take it all.
Run, child.
Let's buy everything.
Yay.
Are they like...
Wait.
Are they like in here?
Oh yeah, nice.
And we'll break.
Wait, do I lose these geo forever?
Like, if I...
Yeah, do they...
Are they just like lost?
Repair them.
Oh, I see.
Um.
Oh.
Okay, 2-2.
I feel like I should get the fried strength one.
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
I should...
I should go back.
And, um...
I should go back and do the Geo stuff now.
Alright.
We'll grab...
Okay.
Do we grab strength?
are a long nail.
Uh, we'll do strength.
Strength and then
uh...
And scrub.
Which, don't use...
Yeah, but I can't die in the dream, right?
Yeah.
Oh, it's a ghost!
Oh!
Oh, whatever.
If I die, he'll repair it.
That's fine.
I'll just pay him to repair it.
It's okay.
I believe.
He can repair it.
Yeah, it's a ghost.
Go, go, go, go, go, ghost.
Wow!
Oh my, holy shit, he was one shot.
That's crazy.
This guy is one shot.
It's alright.
I have geo for days.
Wait, how do I get there again?
It's down here?
I actually don't.
Oh, yeah, it is.
I have geo for days.
days my my papa gave me an allowance wait child why have you come here have you come to tame the savage ruined land many have come to purify this place but all who dwell here eventually consumed yes even the wild bugs lurking below us they were once proud like you but now they are only monsters beware dreams of glory child turn back and do not return all right challenge
oh shit okay
okay this strength shit is is really good
okay after fighting a magic guy I'm fine
No, this shit is easy After dealing with the fucking dream boss This shit is nothing My mind is clear Have we been sleeping, child?
I remember those proud lords Were they truly monsters?
I remember their eyes now Bright and clear in and i fear them so there was madness in that village those i who brought it they're right to cast me out when attacked they're right they're right to kill they kill me oh get in my belly wait we remember the elder oh my god my stomach
Happy stomach?
Okay, where do we go now?
Now go into stags.
Let me grab one, two, soul.
Okay, 400, let go.
I'm trying to remember.
We're gonna go now.
Sacrifice your souls for the grub.
Alright.
But I forgot how to get back to the bench.
We don't have a map.
Okay, this way.
Actually the heart.
That fucking rock guy was definitely my filter.
I had no, like all the other bosses, yeah they were hard.
But like the fucking, the rock guy was such a hard filter for me.
Drops it on top of Gourm.
Okay.
Soul is full of the Grub God.
But after I understood the pattern, I like, I got it.
But like, it was still...
It took me a while to figure it out.
It took me a while to figure out that when he jumps back, when he jumps back, he does Fire Strike.
And I have to yell Fire Strike to understand.
Like when...
And I have to yell Fire Strike.
strike so my brain was like he's gonna fire strike me he's basically not gonna lie he's basically ryan heart i had to re i had to realize i was playing against ryan heart and he was gonna use his fire strike and shatter
why is she a worm because i gotta find my brothers it was like rick shantrick sanchez What is
it here?
Oh, I keep going back to it.
Alright.
Okay, stag nest.
Now good?
Okay.
Try to go this way.
Go let the collector get me.
Collector get me guys.
No!
We'll never get that mask.
I jump down now.
Where am I?
Anyway.
Where do I go from here?
Do I have a map for this place?
Oh, I do.
Oh, there's a chair there.
Okay, let's grab that chair.
What the fuck?
Strong.
Oh, my God.
It's there, isn't he?
He's there, isn't he?
Wait.
go there or where is the chair is the chair here or okay it's at the bottom oh the chair is in there oh it is yay i sit who's here oh oh it's blind man huh well met yes i thought i could sense the aura of a fierce warrior approaching oh he's not blind i'm pressed you found my sanctuary here at the top of the world no doubt you've endured many trials and overcome many foes in your quest to find me yippee yippee yes yes yippee no don't speak a word i nail master motto was taught the art of the nail by the great nail sage himself hereby accept you as my pupil let us begin the lesson immediately.
Yippee!
Yeah, I did that.
Who's he?
Oh, that's my babysitter.
My babysitter.
Odex, while looking up or down to perform the cyclone slash or...
Your form, exquisite.
Exquisite.
Now I know my own master felt when he passed down his teachings to us.
I hope you don't think me too far when I say that I consider you to be much.
Sir, we only met for like 10 minutes.
Yes, when I saw you perform my nail art, I felt a bond between us suddenly flashed into existence.
You honor me beyond my words, my pupil.
Thank you.
We only met for like 10 minutes and now he's like...
Oh, let me hit.
Dream, my brother.
How fair are you in that green kingdom of thorns you call home?
Do you ever close your eyes?
Remember the time we spent together with Oro and our master.
I like to think you do.
Wait, how do I do this?
My babysitter takes over when I do that.
Now go up and left.
Okay.
Alright.
Now go up and left.
This way?
Where's my map, Shay?
Okay.
This way.
Whoa, what's this?
Oh, shit!
Money!
Yeah?
Yeah.
Oh, right?
Up.
And right.
Okay, who the fuck said left?
Time him up.
Oh, hey, who's this guy?
I am Gorb.
Bow, bow, bow!
to gore.
The great mind.
I am gore.
Ascend.
With gore.
Shit.
Okay.
Gorbis.
Gorbis doing Gorbis doing gorb things right now.
Oh,
Gorb dead.
All right.
He's Gorbing out.
I am Gorb.
The great mind.
The pain.
Ascend.
I am getting in my stomach.
I'm.
Mim, Mim, Mim, Mim, Mim, Mim, Mim, Mim.
Happy, happy, tummy.
Here lies, Gorb.
The great mind.
Tummy, happy now.
Gorb, no!
Happy, tummy.
Happy, grub.
Okay, where do we go now?
I get in my belly.
Still hungry.
Grub, still hungry.
now to green path okay i forgot it now how do i get there does i assume okay i can't all right i'll go to we gotta go to he's gonna get me he's gonna get me he's gonna get me
all right did my oh not green path okay where do we go then his blood in the is relentless.
That's me.
Yippee!
That's me!
I'll do everything!
Yippee!
Speed!
Okay, here we go.
And now people said wait, someone said I already did green path.
Do I do green path or no?
I don't know which what is i have to do
okay let's sit down then
i don't need an upgrade do i wait do i have 25 yet one two three four five six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen fourteen fifteen sixteen seventeen eighteen nineteen twenty twenty one twenty two twenty three twenty four 25 i can buy a charm
okay all right let's pull up the map all right guys where is it Where is it in Greenpath?
Where do we go?
The Stone Sanctuary.
What the fuck is that?
There's no Stone Sanctuary.
Oh, here.
Okay, here.
Alright.
Alright, here?
I was like, where the fuck are you talking about?
I was like, oh, it's over here.
Oh.
All right, okay, we go down.
Oh, shit.
All right, after we get there, I need to use the bathroom.
Oh, my God, it's been almost five hours.
Hollow Knight makes the game feel so, like, like, what's the word?
I don't feel like I've been playing for five hours.
In this way.
In this way?
What if I can...
do this no i actually have to walk over there this sucks
ow okay now i can all right it's all the way there
uh and then down okay
we're gonna grab a bench here all right we're gonna sit in the bench I need to use the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
You look at, you know, look at the grub while I use the bathroom.
I'm back.
I am back.
Alright.
The next, below me is... Okay, I need to check my sound real quick.
Uh, below me is the...
Uh...
Oh, sorry.
I just got a message.
I was like, yeah.
I like brain lag I had, I was looking at my Discord messages.
Alright, so.
I am fighting another ghost, right?
Okay.
So I gotta.
Let me put on strength.
And this.
Alright, here we go.
We're all ready.
I'm ready.
Okay, it's down here.
I think.
Rebels.
Oh, shit!
Oh, I forgot about these guys.
It's over here, right?
Wait, what the...
Okay.
That's on him.
Oh, the infected aren't here.
That's nice.
No infected.
It's here, right?
Oh, there he is.
My child.
can you still see please don't hurt me holy he's huge that's like a fucking dino bug can't sleep with your eyes open little one can't dream if you're still breathing little one precious children you speak such loathsome things as you sleep your claws crash and escape child a monster has come for us in the dark will you sing for us okay yippee yippee i'll sing whoa that's my my bed oh that's cool I mean,
I could just...
Where did she go?
Oh, there she is.
Okay, that's annoying.
Okay, she's annoying.
Because she travels everywhere.
Oh, that doesn't even...
Oh my god, that doesn't even...
Okay, she's annoying.
We don't like her.
There you go.
Where did she fly to?
Oh my god.
There you go.
She's annoying because of the platforming.
One by one.
close at last i felt it a warm stillness falling over us i'm sorry i was frightened of you who was protecting us even when we couldn't see you take us there please a place where light cannot haunt us a place without dreams bees you know where that is um
The belly!
You shall be at peace in my belly!
The grub still hungers!
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
A word to the right.
Oh, I was not.
I didn't know there was a reward.
A little reward for little old me?
Beep.
Oh, how does one get the reward?
Yeah?
Oh, oh, it's a mask!
Yay!
Can I come out of here?
Oh, I can't.
Okay.
Yay!
Okay, maybe we need to grab the mask shard now.
Wait, what's over here, though?
Is it just another way to get the reward?
Oh, yeah, it is.
Because that's where I killed her.
Alright, now we go.
Go to Queen Station?
Okay, now we can go to Queen Station.
Now we'll actually...
Oh, shit.
We'll actually grab it.
I like how someone's like, Lost King.
Guys, I killed Lost King two parts ago.
he's already dead.
He's been dead for like 10 plus hours ago.
We've killed him.
We can't kill him harder.
Just do it again.
We can't kill him even harder, guys.
I would if I could.
Okay, we gotta go.
Okay, we gotta go this way.
This is...
Oh my god.
He fucking blocked.
They're all blocking me.
Kill them squared.
Okay, I want to make sure.
Okay, I just want to make sure I didn't accidentally equip the strength one.
No, I haven't done the B-Hive.
That after I get the dream thing.
Yeah.
Oh, I went the wrong way.
It's this way.
Oh, whoops.
Is this how to get back?
Okay, nice.
Oh, it's too late.
We're not going right.
Oh, you mean this guy for the nail art.
Yeah, but will I use it?
Alright, fine.
I'll do it.
Just because we're there.
Just because he's there anyway, I'll do it.
Oh, it's parkour.
Okay.
Why the fuck is it?
Oh my god, I keep thinking that I can...
I don't know why I thought that I could use that as a spike thing.
Oh, fuck!
I was trying to figure out where to go after.
God, I hate that.
Wait, why?
Oh!
Okay, I get it.
Alright.
That's over there.
Okay.
That's over here, though.
Oh, that's for skipping it.
Okay.
We're just to know that our guy where is he where is he I did his stupid test there he is
hello a visitor why have you crept in here little grub perhaps like me y'all taste for discovering new things I am sure and in previous life I was a nail master yes The only thing that drove me was becoming stronger and honoring my skills over now.
I imagine it was my one calling in life, but the feeling faded over time.
What did I do?
It was like, what the fuck?
I don't know what I did.
Now I seek a new calling, something that speaks to my soul and compels me forward.
That's why I spend my time here, secluded, trying to master the art of my life.
creation painting is sculpting these things bring a different kind of pleasure you pixel perfect of a thorn what like a tarn he don't seem very moved by what i said but shield and nail master you're looking for they come to learn a nail art i'll teach you if you insist okay
Learn the...
Yay!
I'm learning how to pay!
Got a great stash.
Oh, okay, so now, okay, this one is like easier.
So, my work doesn't move you.
The wielding of a nail.
The wielding of a brush.
These things are not so different.
We cut into the world so that we can peer deeper inside.
For now, though, I have nothing more to teach you.
Your path forward, only you can see it.
Good luck.
Yeah.
I don't even know exactly what I did.
Made a Rugo ungo...
What, this?
Am I not supposed to jump over it?
Do it again!
No, that's okay.
No.
I don't need to.
I'm not the one that couldn't do it.
Just rewind.
You want to see it.
I think I won't.
Okay, so that's what I got.
Lucky frog.
That jump is almost impossible there, dude.
That's supposed to be hard?
It's almost TAS only?
Wait, what's TAS?
That's my Oshi.
Here you go.
Oh, tool-assisted speedrun?
Wait, what does that mean?
What does tool-assisted speedrun mean?
Oh, they have to use a computer program to do it?
Fucking not gamer.
Fucking weak.
Imagine needing to use a tool to do a pixel-perfect spike jump.
That couldn't be me.
Go to the lake up.
How do I get to the lake?
Just, how's that seed run?
Just get good, exactly.
Oh, that's right.
You know what's up.
Do it five times.
King Station has the last...
Okay, but...
it stop sending her to lake up on I don't even know where that is stop
sending her there go up I don't remember where I fucking fought the hornet like oh it's back to the green path
oh wait we had
Stop taking her there!
Didn't I already do Lake of Un?
I already did this area.
That's the...
Do I not do that?
Oh!
Okay, I see.
But I don't do it.
I didn't swim in it.
I see.
It's here, right?
Oh, yeah!
I remember now.
I remember here.
Where's the path?
Okay, now I go this way.
I swim.
Swim, swim.
Okay, down I'll go.
Down, I- Oh, wait.
Still down.
Oh my god, how much down?
Still down?
What?
Where is he?
Splish flash.
Oh, stay down there?
Hello.
Oh, there it is.
Shape of own.
Oh, I missed him.
Guess we'll never, I'll never know what he looked like.
I, how was I supposed to know?
I just, I stopped halfway.
I just can't.
Oh, it's been too bad.
Too late.
I, he was a giant slug.
How is he so fast?
Oops.
I was like, where is he?
Where is he?
This guy I'm supposed to see.
I'm so confused.
How did you expect me not to move?
I saw a pathway, so I went for the path.
I was like, oh, did I go here?
Run, dead star.
Over.
Yeah, clearly it can't be that important if you only have two seconds of cut scenes if you think about it
okay all right now what is it king queen station okay how do we get the mask
quality quality not quantity all right bottom right yeah Oh, here.
Whoops.
It's here.
Is it this?
Oops.
Okay, this is dumb.
I saw a clip of the...
No, I saw a clip of this person doing this for like 20 years.
No, it's gonna be me.
It's gonna be me.
I'm gonna be her.
This person on 20 years.
winner they did it for like more than five minutes I'm gonna recreate it I'm gonna I'm gonna recreate it it said she like I nearly watched the entire clip too
I'm gonna be hurt JK I'm gaming the fear the fear of being on a twitter post just like her break the record there you go thank god thank god it wasn't me thank god the fear all right where do we go
okay where do we go now we we have currently a thousand we literally are missing a hundred.
Kings?
Okay.
King station.
I didn't want to be a Twitter clip again of that of me trying to do a parkour.
I was scared.
Oh, kingdom's edge.
There's two kings!
You can't expect me to realize which king it was.
Wait, I don't have kingdom's edge.
Where do I go for kingdom's edge?
Yeah, no stack for edge.
Okay.
How do I get there?
Oh, it's up.
Okay.
Up.
Well.
Okay, how...
Is there a bench in...
Is there a bench, though?
Is there a bench at Kingdom's Edge?
Yes?
Okay.
That's good.
He's gotta know.
Holy shit, she just slammed into me.
Wait, down?
Wait, Kingdom's Edge is over here.
Oh, there's another area to Kingdom's Edge.
Okay.
I didn't see the down part.
I didn't read.
Alright, there's another one here.
Oh my god, it's this area.
I remember now.
Are you serious?
That hit me?
Jesus Christ, the range for that explosion.
Yeah?
Where do we go?
Alright, let's open the map.
Alright, here we go.
Where is it?
Right?
Okay, do we go down?
Where is it?
Which bench?
This bench or this bench?
Left of cast off shell?
Go to the bench.
Oh, this bench?
This one?
Okay, one or two?
I ran out of pins.
One or two?
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, is it here?
Wait, is it this?
Is it this?
Yes, okay.
I keep forgetting about the falling bodies.
How are there still bodies?
Oh, is it...
They're all from the Colosseum, right?
I was gonna say, how are there still falling bodies?
Okay, let's see.
It's raining bugs.
Okay, let's grab the bench first before we get there.
Okay, it's this way.
I forgot.
This is the area where I hate the most with the stupid jumping bugs.
Alright.
We get rid of this, this.
Oh yeah, what is this?
The bear would take on and can move freely.
Well, the bear would take and can move freely to...
Wait, what the fuck?
What does this do?
Ah!
Okay, we'll get that later.
Okay, that's pretty fucking stupid, but...
I don't know if I need that for the ghost, though.
I don't know.
I don't think I need that for the ghost chat.
Look at the string.
Parablet pulled their shell.
Okay, yeah, we don't need that yet.
Oh, yeah, God.
a grub song that i wanted to use i remember there's so many i'm slugging it
okay and then we go down
okay and then down
what did i what is my charm okay strength yeah i tried quick slash i didn't oh shit oh my god it's oh my god it's these guys Oh Oh my god, I'm still getting fucked up right now I'm getting so fucked up right now.
I hope I'm going the right way because I don't have a compass I hope I'm going the right way
Okay, it's this way
Oh god Oh god Oh god Is this?
Okay, we keep going right.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, there you go.
This was that way I had to go.
There you go.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, my God.
There's a lot of parkour platforms.
You've come a long way just to die here at the edge of the world?
No, do not speak.
thousands and thousands of empty words from those like you your pride your desires your desperation you will take these things with you once i strike you down raise your weapon then and die like those who came before you all right yeah i'm trying to figure out how oh my god where is he oh he has
Oh, and the shield hurts me.
Okay, now I know.
Oh, my God.
I might actually accident.
Oh, this is bad.
This is actually bad.
This is actually so bad.
Oh, this is bad.
Wait, I might break it.
Okay.
okay oh my god are you serious this is so bad
oh no it broke the charm that sucks that sucks all right we'll grab the hp charm then holy shit yeah i'll grab Rest in peace.
You, they fucked with me because there are so many things around me.
Okay, now I know.
Now I know.
Maybe you're right.
Maybe I need...
Okay.
Maybe you're right.
Maybe it's time for...
I should have been a slug.
Okay.
Maybe it works like that.
No, I fucked up because, like, I also wasn't, like, familiar.
Like, I didn't know when to heal for that one.
Oh, shit.
Whoops.
Eh.
It's fine.
I still hate these guys so much.
Wee!
It's so dumb.
so I don't have to deal with.
Wait, actually?
Okay.
I want to...
Oh, whoops.
Oopsie.
Still have to use it anyway.
Okay, let me charge.
Oh, wait, nice.
Oh.
Where's my thing?
Alright.
Challenge.
Okay.
It's not parkour part.
I hate it.
Like, oh my god.
Are you serious?
That's so dumb.
I'm okay with that.
No!
Let me eat!
Me hungry!
Hungry, hungry, hungry grub!
Hungry grub!
Oh shit.
Okay.
Are you serious?
Oh, he came all the way there.
I didn't see him.
Okay, I need to be able to hit him.
He's so fast.
Whoa!
Shit!
Whoops.
Oh, no!
Ah!
Oh, shit.
There we go.
Come.
Never have I been defeated in combat.
I can see myself there, still sleeping.
How long have I been hitting here?
Here at the edge of the world, no one could find me, except you.
Warriors, knights, kings, every time myself, even time myself, they have no power with me.
Only you.
You are the darkness.
Come!
To consume me.
That's right.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Grub's still hungry.
If he's so good, why is he dead?
That's what I'm saying.
Get in the belly.
Grub's still hungry.
Yeah.
Alright.
Nice, 1800.
Thank fucking God.
We can go back now.
I need to grab my map because I don't know how to get out of here.
What about it?
I actually don't.
So, like, we really...
If I don't have my map, I will not know how to get up.
I can't believe all that.
Just so we still have the parkour.
Guys, give me a sec.
I'm trying to figure out how do I...
Wait, where... Where's the bench?
Oh, shit.
I hate these guys.
Up and right.
Okay.
I legitimately don't remember how to get to there.
There you go.
Okay.
Child, thank you.
Child, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Try Defender's Crest.
A glowing womb.
Next, we're funny.
We're cute to sit on the bench after spawning some flies and wait.
Uh, thank you.
Thank you.
Wait, what?
This plus what?
Loading womb and defenders crest.
What's gonna happen?
Oh!
Oh, it's music notes.
Hello.
I'm singing.
Let's dance.
Let's dance, everybody.
Yay!
Wait, what does it look like with Rick Sanchez?
Me and my evil moorities!
Wait, what about...
What about...
Oh, I did like little knives!
Wait, what about...
What about...
Wait, did they do anything?
for okay that's the music do anything for among us oh no they're just little bugs okay what about her oh oh that's cute that's cute okay let's go back i'm singing la-de-da-de-da la-de-da
Okay, let's grab that.
Okay.
Grubs.
I don't know.
Okay.
This.
Plus.
There we go.
All right.
Let's.
It is time to go back to sag.
Oh, shit.
I didn't even see that.
All right.
Resting grounds.
How do we...
go to get the hive.
We might as well grab the hive charm too to make it easier.
I am not like trying to do parkour in one run.
I'd rather make it easier.
Uh, oops.
Let's try and look at my map.
Isn't it deepness?
Okay.
All right, let's go here.
The hive is in this area.
Oh, how do I get there?
I have the tram pass.
God, I hate these guys.
I hate these guys so much.
Bottom left.
Alright, I'm pulling up the map.
Where do we go?
Yeah?
Is it this?
Oh, shit.
Let me get rid of all my markers.
Is it here?
Oh, stacked a hidden station.
Oh.
Apparently I can't.
Okay, I have to take the tram first.
Okay, we got algo.
Okay, let's go back to...
Okay, we can't do it yet.
Okay.
Okay, ancient bastion time.
All right, before we do that, let's grab.
Um, I don't remember how- which way I went to for the city.
Here?
Yeah, it is.
Fucking stupid homing shit.
Okay, I gotta- oh, I can't even heal here.
see me oh now you don't see me what the okay oh that works I take those I take
it yeah I was gonna turn I'm gonna go to the resting grounds first
okay resting grounds we'll go there first
And then...
Yay!
Go this way.
We finally have 1800.
It took us a while.
Oh, Wielder, you returned!
Let me have a look at the dream now!
So you have to have 700 essence?
I wonder whether the dreamers are watching you as you work or even the old king.
The lock of theirs.
Desperate.
But very clever.
aren't they thought he could hold i have no no disdain for them though as history grows on i grow numb up to its repetitions take your gift and continue collecting essence okay what did i get
all right next up the dream now now holds 900 essence within this car are you surprised that this old kingdom has so many hidden dreams yes you're starting to see them the connections between us and the dreams we leave behind like prince in the dust the time has come for you to learn how to revisit the places connected to you hold the dream nail tight wheeler imagine a great gate opening before you what's this
master the dream gate hold why to hold down while using and oh okay oh i have a tp guys why did you tell me i'm a tp at 900 i could have had a tp all along the dream now grows bright it holds over 1200 essence look into it i can see so many mirror memories peering back at me so many asking to be remembered none of us can live forever so we ask those who survive to remember us hold something in your mind and it lives on with you but forget it and we seal it away forever that is the only death that matters ah so they say enough of that though take this ruler and come back to me with 1500 essence another egg yes i thought so more than 1500 essence the dream that was close so close to fully awakening continue on your path wheeler i know not what guides you nor what it is that drives you for once you have collected 1800 essence though i will be here waiting take this gift may it grant you strength to help you collect the essence of the world oh another mask that i can't use and you as well,
Wielder.
It's time for you both to be awakened.
The essence you have collected.
The hope that still remains in this old kingdom.
Pure potential.
Let it course through you and into the dream now.
Hold it aloft, Wielder.
Awaken.
Alright, now I have whatever it is to get to the White Palace for Park War of Death.
Wait.
George and slash Okay Great Yes Yes No dream can hide itself from you now You appear to the darkest places Just need to find the right crack What will you do with such a power wielder Whose memories will you hunt down?
Do as you wish My promise is fulfilled May the crimes of my tribe be washed away in time Like the rest of those kingdoms Alright nice We did it We fucking did it.
Let us put a TP and then...
Okay, we put TP first.
But then I need to buy one more charm.
Oh, I don't have money.
Never mind.
I don't have money.
It's like a thousand something.
Um, was it down, right?
There we go.
This is my TP.
Oh, I can talk to her?
Okay.
where do i sell my eggs i'm a brook boy wait grub fighter buys my eggs let me have a look at the you still process is still an obsession you keep out of it then once you've collected return to me okay both beautiful and gross sex see them out rhythm reveal them and gather essence great where is my Where's my cough drops?
Oh, there it is.
So, at the antique shop in City of Tears, I didn't save more of my brothers.
I know that was my mission earlier, but I didn't do it.
Oh, Dream Nail?
Why are you doing Pokemon that's the old man like mine?
Nothing of worth his hidden side, but keep probing.
Okay.
Okay, I'll sell stuff in the city.
So I can buy my last charm now.
Alright, um...
Or is this the closest?
Is it King Station?
Is King Station the closest?
Yeah.
Yes.
Oh, this way.
Ah, shit!
It's not fair.
Are we- can you even- Fight the collector?
I wonder...
Is it possible to fight him?
Yeah?
Oh.
Where is he?
Oh, you just... Wait, who's that?
Oh, what are you doing on this miserable downpour?
Impressive formula, isn't it?
you'll appreciate more we're both getting drenched the night up there was an important one the plaque here mentions its sacrifice which carries something of an ominous tone probably met some of the horrible end though it sounds like the night school may have been achieved in the process and all the relics i collected have yet to find a clue as to what that was oh wait are you the shop oh okay oh i just got lore.
Oh, the collector?
No, it's fine.
I don't need to fight him.
Wait, actually, how hard is the collector?
Oh, it is here.
I'll just sell all of it.
How many can I sell?
Okay.
Very?
Another hallmas.
Pass.
I tried collecting their light, but there's little information we glend of each.
Behind you, they do keep a nice shine above them, and there's nothing wrong with piercings appreciating something purely on aesthetic merits.
Okay, we need... How much do we need?
Oh, Nassil?
Give it here.
Do you have something else for me?
If not, get your dapp little self out of my home.
1.4k?
Okay, I have enough.
Alright, how do I do this?
It's like here.
all right okay it's where was it okay to the blue lake okay all right we should be able to buy the next charm notch now
all right we gotta fight our trauma not now though i gotta fight the honey guy
all right he's gonna get me he's gonna get he's gonna get me he's gonna get me oh he missed he didn't get me yet yeah honey guy is far more important than trauma right now all right let's grab the last one yay we got everything wait what
my blessing what the fuck does that mean all right we go
I almost put a TP here.
Oh my god.
Thank god the teleporter is real.
Okay, now...
Now I have one more charm notch.
So...
What can I use that for?
I'll just use Grubstown for now.
Alright, where do we go?
Yeah, we're not getting every try.
Yeah, that's fine.
Is it the hidden station?
Oh yeah, I could replace the pride one.
Wait, where are the chairs?
Oh, it's on this side.
Okay, you're right.
I could change that to the longer one.
Okay.
No, we're going to I'll figure this out.
Alright, where do we go?
Where do we go, guys?
Yeah?
is it here where's the tram oh is this the tram where's the tram is this the tram yeah
okay all right let's go it's time to take the tram station how do i get up oh this way wait who's that oh that's the white palace that's him that's where i have to go for that white palace.
We're looking for the hive.
I'm not fucking doing parkour without it.
I'm not that crazy.
No, we don't need a set TP.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, I forgot about him.
Drop all the shit.
Wait.
What's this for?
Oh, 3k geo required.
Oh, it's for a charm.
I'm not giving Hannah.
I know you don't get no handouts from me.
I'm also fucking poor right now.
Is this a tram?
No.
Oh, here it is.
Am I going to meet the subway, bros?
Beep-beep.
Tickets, please.
Hello.
I have my ticket.
I press button.
Yay!
I pressed the ticket.
I sleep.
Okay.
I'll go leave.
Where am I?
Oh.
That shuns.
Oh, look.
There's the bees.
There they are.
Oh, wrong way.
But the bees are here.
Yeah.
I was like, what do you mean?
The bees are literally right here.
Break what wall?
Oh, shit.
Bee angie.
Oh, here.
Oh, I see.
Whoops.
I'm a little silly right now.
There you go.
I'm yum yum yum yum yum yum.
Now I'm a little silly.
Oh, there's the bees.
Okay, these bees are tough as fuck.
Wait, what are these guys?
Wait, you're not a bee.
What are you?
You ain't no...
Oh my god, it's a pregnant bee!
Wait, what?
What?
What was that?
What was he?
I don't even know what he was.
That was no bee.
He's a man.
Oh, he was a little beehive?
Oh, that's fucking creepy.
That's like alien shit right there.
That's like actual alien.
Oh, shit.
Yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yeah they made him a beehive here's shit I've ever seen where is the benches here okay left for a bench oh that's a big g oh he ate oh oh it's okay if he stings me he's dead
he doesn't know You can only sing once or you die.
Okay, nice.
Irish.
Alright, we gotta find where the...
Where the... where the head B is.
Where the fuck is the head B?
Okay, I wanna get rid of this guy.
That guy's scary.
We gotta free him.
Oh hey, there's a tree.
All right.
Oh.
Let me pogo.
Oh, shit.
No pogo for me, I guess.
Money, money, money.
Must be shit funny.
On our rich man's realm.
I gotta figure out where to...
Where to go for, like...
Nice.
Oh, shit.
It's fine.
I'm just gonna tank this, because it's easy.
I'm trying to figure out, like, where I need to go.
Yeah?
I know when the boss fight is.
So, like, I can rearrange my charms.
Up to rooms, then, right?
Where am I?
Oh, I'm here.
Okay.
But I'll go more.
Oh, it's linear?
Nice.
That's good.
That's what I like.
Oh, if it's linear, I'll just swap my... Yeah.
I'll swap my bench.
I'll swap my charms now.
I wasn't sure if it was linear.
Ah, fuck.
I'll grab my charms then.
That's fine.
I'll tank it all.
I sit on bench.
What are my usual...
Oh my god.
Wait, is he coming over?
Okay, I need to know if you're coming over.
Guess I'll grab Mark.
I don't even remember.
Oh my god, I already forgot my loadout.
I don't remember my loadout.
What do we usually do?
I guess this?
Mark of Pride, Grub Song?
And then what?
I'm here.
Oh.
What can we do?
Our thorns?
Okay, we get shape.
We have to do this.
Use long nail quick slash.
Is that better?
I haven't done quick slash in a while.
I haven't done quick slash at all.
Alright.
Long nail quick slash.
That's our loadout.
Okay, it's this way.
I want to kill them.
I know.
I know, like, but you guys were like, stop killing the...
I don't care.
What?
I'm going to kill this guy, too.
There you go.
I don't care.
I will kill him.
Okay.
Let's go that way.
I'm just going to rush it.
Is he going to poop maybe, though?
He doesn't.
Oh!
Okay, I won't kill him.
he doesn't do anything he just exists in pain but he exists he might be in like extreme pain but that's okay jesus christ oh my god where am i oh there i am
oh oh that's a lot i don't know which way to go i'm going right wait right or left Did I go the wrong way?
Guys, right or left?
Right?
Oh, I was...
What was left side?
Was left side nothing?
Woo!
Actually, I really want to grab the money.
I want to rob these bees real quick.
Okay, nice.
Is it here?
Can't be up here.
Can't be out of here.
Okay, nice.
Do you think they like jazz?
There is a mark try?
Well, it's too late on here.
Hello.
Oh.
Wait, I just need to dodge this.
I don't even have to fight!
Okay.
Oh, what?
That's my bad.
Okay.
That's good to know.
Oh, that's not good to know.
Wait, can I?
Yes.
Okay.
I don't think I can first try this.
Oh, nice.
I can eat.
Fucking stupid environment shit.
I hate that most.
Oh my god Oh my god of course
Oh okay I fumbled I fumbled in the beginning because I didn't really know Like a pattern I get it now It was close I almost first tried that I think I could have first tried it If I like understood the pattern earlier
Where's the shortcut?
Oh my god, I keep falling.
Yeah, I almost first tried it.
Oh my god, these guys are annoying as hell.
Holy shit, there's three of them!
Okay, I'm fucking...
I need to kill these guys for healers, though.
I need to use the big B.
I'm just gonna use my TP.
Fuck this.
Get it.
Bro, fuck it.
I'm going to use my TP.
Oh my god.
Why make that harder?
Yeah, these bees don't fucking play around.
Yeah, their TP is an easier idea.
Yeah.
I hate these guys.
Oh my god, these guys.
These guys are so annoying.
I don't really remember
Where am I?
Holy shit It's fine We'll use TP I think it's here This is my TP Just in case I don't first try it I'll do here Just in case
Wait I didn't Oh!
Oh, it has to be here.
Okay, there you go.
Oh, I can't set it in boss room.
Mmm, clever.
I can't abuse it.
Yeah, I can't abuse it.
Okay, I'm gonna hit the bees just because I...
Never mind.
That was a bad idea.
Oh, they can't die!
Yeah, that was a... I didn't realize they can't die.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, my God.
Hate these guys.
Okay, now that I know...
Oh, my God.
He jumps over.
Oh, shit!
I'm dead.
I didn't think...
he was gonna jump over.
Oh.
I died too without bees.
Okay, it's fine.
Watch this.
Nice.
He's fast.
I got I got beasted, yeah.
Not the bees.
Not the bees!
Yeah, the little bees can't die, I'm pretty sure.
Hit.
Oh, what?
I thought he was gonna dash.
Oh, my God.
These spikes messed with me.
Hit.
There we go.
Oh, my God.
That was messed up.
my bad.
What?
My pogo!
There we go.
I'm here.
Oh,
he went far this time.
Oh, shit!
That's my bad.
I thought...
I really thought he was gonna...
Oh.
Oh,
he jumps now?
I mean, I mean,
I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I'm going to eat, I'm going to eat my, my thing next to your dead body.
Can't dream when you're dead.
Nice.
All right, three tries.
It took me a while to understand how to paddle.
fight him i'm still hungry so hungry all right now i could do the park boy dream dream dream no more oh hey my night at last you're freed small thing i know your kind attempt to resolve your past and know that i am not the queen you seek it's the pale beings that bear blame for your nature though this hive exists within hollowness we lay play no part in this attempt at perpetuation.
Do I?
The rail against nature is folly.
All things must accept an end.
Do I?
You're queen in.
I'm hungry.
I'm so hungry.
Look at her.
No, no, no, no!
But poor key lady can be in my belly.
Oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh!
Please spare it!
Dude, but I'm so hungry.
Oh, shit.
Guys, where the fuck?
Oh, my God.
It's bongoing right now.
Oh, it's this, right?
Jesus.
I'm just gonna absorb real quick.
You get rid of these guys.
to eat to eat or not to eat that is not question
mess time okay we can finally we finally did it guys
we finally did it oh my god why holy what the fuck was that a dry bite what the fuck happened
holy shit that was crazy damn it was like a car crash okay now i'm at the edge
hit him run yeah i almost got hit but it wasn't me wait what's oh that's my portal where am i you know what's edge how do i get out here.
I don't know.
How did I get here?
Oh, this is bad.
I wish I had a compass, guys.
Guys, I'm really lost.
Go down?
Oh, here.
Oh, there's the tram.
There we go.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
It's White Palace time.
Oh, there you go.
Okay.
honey and then I don't think we're gonna need that map for this bees in a trap bees in a trap I don't know what do I need maybe I don't know baby grub song I don't know
alright Uh, what's button?
Wait, oh, button plus.
I don't need shaman for that place.
Okay, is there a chair over there?
I'll configure my chair later.
Okay, so I'm tram now.
And then we just got, go down.
And then...
Yes?
Okay, I'll just do that.
Should be here.
Oh, nope.
have money yet for that nope down here okay it's parkour time
oh there he is hello weem that is time for parkour of hell
am i going the wrong way no it's here oh wait wait wait wait it's a boss
it's okay i I have.
Wait, not really?
Wait, what is he doing here?
Oh, he's just a normal guy.
Hello.
Oh, he's just a normal dude.
Oh, okay.
That's cool.
That's good.
It's like, wait a minute, I wasn't...
I thought I was supposed to do it without fucking parkour of hell.
Oh, is it here?
Let me shit on the chair.
Alright, now we gotta figure this out.
Okay, we don't need steady body.
We don't need shaman stone.
Guys, help me remember my loadout too, because I don't remember.
Alright, we get Markup Pride quick slash.
Oh, I don't want to get double.
Ah!
Double damage is fine.
I have, I have self-recent.
Oh, wait.
Why do I need Grub Song?
Wait, why?
Okay.
Oh, Markup Pride doesn't help.
What do I need then?
Okay, so what do I get?
Rage out of heart?
To survive.
Dash Master?
Alright.
Okay, here you go.
That's all I need to survive.
What?
Where is it?
Where do I go?
No?
Dashmaster will mess me up?
Okay.
And what do I- I have two slots!
Long now?
Okay.
All right, let's do it.
Oh!
That's awkward.
Guys, it's gonna be a long day.
Whatever, is this where I'm supposed to go?
Hey, why is this block?
Good start, right?
Good start to parkour.
Wee.
Oh, more of this guy.
That's not cool!
It's not cool!
Oh, don't reach in now.
Oh no.
Oh, he does two damage?
Aww.
I did not know that.
That's so rude.
What's this?
What did I do?
Door open.
Where's door?
Oh, that door?
How do I get back?
Oh, that door.
Oh, hey.
Um, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Was it back here?
I legitimately don't remember where the door was.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, there is door.
Door!
Yippee!
Oh.
Up.
Okay, up, I'll go.
Oh, I'm...
Oh, I'm hearing voices.
Hello?
King, your troubles, let us.
Can I kill him?
Can they be killed?
King, your troubles, let us.
Hello?
Oh, oh.
Oh my god, look at all these juicy souls.
Just laying there.
Oh, they respawn?
Nice.
See, that's what I mean.
Look at these guys.
Literally, look at that.
Unlike the fucking mantises.
Wait, is Longdale not good?
People are saying someone said to get the mark.
I don't have...
I don't have enough space, though.
Yeah, I don't have enough space.
I don't have enough space.
I'll get Overtime.
Is Fragile Heart not good?
But I get more he is.
I mean, I could put that.
I'll put that.
Then what do I do to do?
Huh?
Not enough space.
Yeah, I don't have enough space.
I mean, I'm going to do Fragile.
I'll do Fragile Heart and I'll do Fragile Heart.
Oh, actually, long nail.
I'm gonna do that.
I'll do that.
I'm gonna do it.
Chat is our chat is fighting again, but I trust my, I trust my, I trust my, my soul.
Guys, maybe I shouldn't trust my soul.
Baby-
Baby, I shouldn't trust my soul.
I don't know, I got confused.
I was like, where am I?
Oh, hey.
Hey, that's another area.
Where did I get that?
Oh, it's over here.
Oh, hello there.
I was like, oh, look at these fucking buzz saws.
I hope nothing bad happens to me.
All right.
And so it begins.
Okay.
How do I get to this?
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Now we're palatating.
Oh my god, whoa!
Wait, how do I do this?
Wait, what?
So confused.
Wow!
I'm so confused.
Woo!
Okay, just stuff.
I wish I could look up.
Okay.
up.
Oh, I can!
JK!
I can look up.
Okay, I just gotta look up longer.
That'll fuck.
Oh, okay.
Wait, what's over there?
Wait, which way do I go?
Oh, nothing.
Okay.
Gamers don't look up!
Oh, God.
Fuck.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Oh, whoops.
Yeah, I know I can pogo the sauce, but there's no need for it right now.
I don't think I need to pogo it.
What?
Okay, let me regen this.
Oopsie.
The magic is...
I cry out in pain.
Before I die, I had to cry.
Wait, why the fuck?
Huh?
Where do I go from here?
What the fuck?
I yelled into that boy.
Oh, it's down there.
Whoops.
That was so confused.
That was also a spike.
Okay, I didn't realize that was also a spike over there.
I was like, what the fuck is that?
Oh, okay.
I'm gonna wait.
Yeah, I gotta wait.
There we go.
Oh, I could have got that.
Wait, what?
Wait, oh, I did.
Ha ha, speedrun!
I was like, wait, where am I?
I did get there.
Wait, can I do this?
Oh, I can.
Nice.
Now what?
Wait, what do I do here?
What do I do here?
I don't know what to do.
to do here left and drop wait oh drop there oh i see it there we go i was like where is the next stop there
for now oh
okay What's this?
Alright.
What?
Is that an area?
Oh.
Okay, yeah, I was gonna say, is that part of it?
Where does this go?
What?
I said...
I dashed the wrong way.
I was trying to dash left.
I got scared.
There you go.
I was like, what the fuck is that?
Yeah, I'll now go.
Yay.
Which way?
Oh?
Hey, guys.
Oh, it's just this.
Eh, I'll grab the full.
Grab the full.
Oh, I can farm these guys.
Farming my followers.
Oh, fuck.
I did not see that guy.
Okay.
Up, down.
They go...
Oh, okay.
Ah!
I forgot about that.
Okay.
When it goes up, I go down.
Oh, he's so fast!
What?
He's so fast!
Okay.
Get it.
Oh!
Oh, there's an area here.
Okay.
Oh, hello.
Yay!
Made it.
Now where am I?
Oh, yay.
Okay, I got it.
Now where do I go?
next one.
The left side?
Okay.
Bench time.
Sleepy.
Where?
Oh.
This side?
When he's like, oh, oh, wait, no, I've been here.
Have I been here before?
Have I done this before?
No?
Okay.
I couldn't tell.
Oh, I have to be faster than that.
Oh, I see.
I see now.
I was, like, wondering, like, how fast I was supposed to be.
Ah!
I'm okay.
I look up.
Oh, oh, oh!
Okay, I sort of realized.
Wee, wee, wee, wee, wee.
Oh my god, I thought I didn't have to go all the way down.
That's my bad.
I was being silly.
Oh, come on.
I'm just a silly bug.
Beep, beep, I'm a silly bug.
I love.
Oh, whoops, I double jumped when I should have.
Oh.
No, I needed hot blood.
Hello guys.
Oh, oh, oh, that's me.
Oh, it's me.
Whoa.
Okay.
Oh, that was an accident.
Oh.
I messed that up.
Because I wasn't really sure what to do.
I can't say that.
I don't know.
I want to cheese that.
But I realized I could just do this.
Just be...
Oh!
Just being a little silly.
Just being a little silly, folks.
Touch me!
that is so fast yeah it is I'm not expecting how fast it was oh my god okay yeah holy shit that's literally one jump that's crazy oh I almost made it
now it's being too silly just being a silly little rub I got greedy there Show us the tech I don't think I can do the tech I'm just a little grub And a big grub this world I don't remember how I did this one Oh Not like that
Okay Yay Actually don't remember how I did this Oh, okay.
Okay.
Yippee!
Wait, what's over here?
Oh, I need this.
What do I do here?
Oh, here.
Yay!
What the fuck?
I got confused.
I looked, I was like, what the fuck am I looking at?
Oh my god.
What is that pattern?
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
I need to, like, try pattern recognition for this.
Okay.
Whoa!
Oh, I just walked for it.
Take it.
Wait, what if?
What if?
Oh, my.
That would have been so sick if I got that.
If I actually got that.
Omni-yum.
Don't keep these.
Whoops.
Oh,
I just walk over.
I can't stop walking over.
I'll stop walking.
That almost worked.
What if I just walked over, guys?
Guys.
Oh my god, what am I looking at?
Oh!
I fumbled it.
Pain.
This one's high.
Oh, whoops.
I should walk forward.
Whoopsie.
Oh!
Alright, I'll jump here.
Oh, no need to dash.
Oh yeah, you're right.
E-he.
Oh!
Because I forget where they are.
Where am I?
Eternal question.
Okay, this one.
Ah!
No!
I was.
Okay, now I'm trolling.
Now I'm trolling.
Okay.
Oops.
I was being silly there.
Stop trolling.
It's still that's the last one.
Okay.
I figured it out.
Yippee!
What the fuck?
What?
Wait a minute.
Oh, it's here.
Never mind.
What the fuck?
What?
Oops.
Oopsie.
That's so funny.
I got lost in the side.
I got lost.
I was like, where did I go?
Oh my god, I almost got it.
Accidental secret discovery.
I don't even know what I discovered.
Oh shit.
whoops I'm gonna wait
there was a secret I didn't even notice I was like where am I oh shit I'm gonna slam into that I fucked it up
oops I'm gonna hit that I don't wanna see me hit that oops
okay that's I think this is...
I couldn't...
It's so hard to cancel in time.
I fall down.
Oh, I'm gonna hit that too.
Yep.
Okay, we got...
Nice.
We did it.
Oh, oh my god, that's just a dream.
Okay.
Oh, I'm gonna hit that.
Oh, no?
Oh, that was close.
Oh!
Okay.
Yay!
Hey, hey, oh, oh.
Oh!
Hello, buddy.
Thank you, thank you.
I am King Grub.
King Grub is here.
Oh!
Oh, ah!
Yes, that's me!
Yes!
Bow before me!
Oh!
I don't know where to go now.
Where do we go?
Elevator in the middle?
This?
Beam me up!
Yay!
Yippee!
What?
This room right here?
Okay.
That works.
That doesn't work for me.
What?
Guys, you're not tricking me to do Paphapade.
I know what's over there.
You're not fooling me.
I'm not doing Paphapade.
I know it exists.
I'm like trying to figure this out how much for papapay we're not finishing this today and we do papapay oh my god I'm mad now look what you did I was thinking with a super chat thingy thank you no amount of money will make me do Paphapain.
Hey, Joki, there's a wand.
It is a really cool reward.
Mr. Mufloffians, thank you for the super chat.
Oh my god, I'm actually mad.
I'm Paphapain.
I'm actually mad now.
I know what this is I know what this is I I just thank you for the super chat thank you thank you Gabriel guys I gotta fucking try and do the regular path oh my god he's not gonna leave is he for you to go through path of pain Thank you.
This super chat.
Thank you.
Fly up!
Oh my god, please.
Fly up.
Please.
It didn't matter.
There was nothing there.
Oh my god, that was actually just bait.
Okay.
Oh, that's good.
I take those.
I actually take those.
Take those.
Let's make you go.
Like, I know a shortcut.
It's on the left.
Champion.
Thank you for the super chat.
We haven't even done the normal path.
Did you want me to do Papa Fade?
Yay, bench.
It was 10.
I don't.
I don't know.
I assume.
Oh, my God.
it's a shortcut toky i don't think a shortcut named path of pain is a shortcut does that oh that still hits me okay path of pain after final boss i'm thinking for the super chat thank you thank you we'll see how much time i have left oh i thought i got that it's emotional pain probably
We'll see how much time I have left.
Oh, I don't know why I thought I could do that.
It's painful how much it saves.
How much time it saves.
Are you serious?
Oh my god, I thought there was an area there.
I want to go back to the bench.
I'm gonna sit down.
Fuck this.
I don't want to wait.
I think he has a point.
I keep fucking missing that guy.
Oh my god.
I need a pogo to that.
Okay, that's fucking fine.
Okay, let's sit on the bench.
Alright.
Yeah, I need to...
I'm gonna try and...
I'm gonna pogo...
Ah, I need a pogo more.
Okay.
Okay, that was silly of me.
Ah, that was also silly of me.
I'm being silly!
Okay.
Oh my god, it's this area.
What do I do?
I'll skip?
I don't even know that.
I skipped it?
Do I go up or down?
Up?
I didn't even know I skipped it.
I just saw the thing.
I was like, I go this way now.
Okay.
Oh, that was close.
Which way do I go?
This way?
Okay.
Oh, whoops.
Oh.
i gotta regen i gotta you go left at the bottom of the path
yeah is that oh is that where i go
that yeah that yeah that sounds accurate
Oh my god.
I'm trying to figure out how to do this.
I'm going to stream my fluff again.
Thank you.
Super chat thingy.
I'm going to wait for regen before I do this.
No, fuck.
If I die, I'll just die.
I don't want to land on a platform.
I was like, I better fucking die so I don't land on a platform.
What?
Pogo this?
Why Pogo this?
I got scared.
Cat.
Woo!
Okay.
Don't jump?
Wait.
What?
What do you mean?
Wait, what?
Oh my god.
I was like.
Did you see that?
I like, I like, did you see that?
I blended into the, the thing.
I like merged into the port.
That's crazy.
Yeah, I was like, what the fuck happened?
Do it again, I didn't see it.
oh no i double jumped it i shouldn't have double jumped i just accidentally pulled i just didn't jump it there was no need to that's too slow that's too slow
okay these one this one's frustrating
oh oh okay i get it but that like that has to be timed though oh i almost timed it i almost timed it oh i really yeah but it's hard it's really hard to time it
this area is difficult the other ones I was I the other ones were fine for me is this area
okay can I do that skip wait I'm gonna land here first is that skip possible
hmm right yes okay Alright.
Papa pain is easier.
Let's try.
Let's skip over there.
And I will do as many skips as possible.
Mmm.
Okay.
I want to skip it.
Ah!
I missed it.
I just missed a jump for it.
There you go.
Nice.
Now what do I do?
Wait, what do I do after that?
I don't know if I can't make that.
Oh, I can.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
That was easy.
Okay.
Oh.
I imagine if I could do that skip.
Aw.
Okay.
You can?
How?
Whoops.
Okay, I'm fucking up now.
Just dash normally?
Oh, okay.
Oh, yeah!
Nice.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Aww.
I have to do this again.
No!
Alright, let's wait.
I can wait.
Oh, I'm not doing it.
Like, I'm doing way too slow.
Yeah.
I wish I can skip that.
With this.
I wish I can just skip it.
Mmm!
I need a dash, not jump.
How?
I'm just bumping my head.
Whoa.
My head.
Oh.
It's time that one.
I didn't know there was an ending to that.
Okay.
Yum, yum, yum.
Wait.
Oh!
Whoops.
Yeah.
Is that skip worth it?
Oh, yeah, it is.
Whoops.
Okay, now that I know.
I wasn't sure.
Now I know.
Okay.
Let's see.
hmm okay okay whoops sorry i got a little greedy there i was thinking break the wall there no
i'm trying to figure out how to do this i just dash i guess i just dash right yeah oh nope i want to die there so i don't have to worry Yeah, I'm just gonna dash.
Wait, first.
Okay.
Oh, what?
Oh, I didn't realize!
I was like, yeah!
And then the fucking giant ass song came over there.
Oops.
That's my bad.
Okay, now...
Oh, this one.
Wait, I heard about this one.
Oh.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, now I'm taking it seriously.
I just like ran into it.
I really have this.
I know this one.
This is infamous.
This one's infamous.
There's no skips here.
Oh my god.
And this one's hard.
This is definitely the high blood arena area.
I was like, this confuses me a lot.
This one confuses me a lot.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Damn.
Time to dash when top spikes come up.
Okay.
Where do I time this?
Ooh, kudos.
Oh, oh.
Oh.
What about this?
Is it a top?
Is it still a dash?
Wow.
Yay!
Oh!
Okay.
I was like, whoa, I had a feeling that it was coming out, and I was like, I did it!
Oh, that's unlucky.
He got me.
I had a feeling, too!
I knew it was going to come up!
Oh, oops.
I waited too long.
Ah!
Oh, I don't know why I double jumped.
I'm getting nervous.
Oh, I'm nervous.
My belly is scared.
Oh,
nice.
Ow.
There you go.
I did it!
Is that it?
Hello, everybody.
Where do I have to go now?
Is that it?
Wait, did I do it?
There's more.
Go right?
Okay.
Dream nailed them.
They just say my king!
My king!
Let's see.
We will wait, king!
One section left?
Okay.
We're not go.
Do I...
Crystal dash them?
Is it this way?
Who dropped this king?
I know, right?
Okay.
I thought I could have a free crystal there.
Here?
Remember to stop.
Thank you, guys.
Now I know.
Where do I go from here?
Oh my god, okay.
Is there fucking anything coming down from there?
Hello?
Excuse me?
Like, okay.
Like, where do I go from here?
Can I pogo that?
No, I can't.
There's nothing to my right.
Oh, max height jump.
Okay, there you go.
I'm a little special.
Okay.
Wait, I wonder.
Uh.
Ah.
Oh, that's a thorn.
I was, like, wondering what that is.
Okay.
Hmm.
Yeah?
Oh!
What?
Where do I go from there?
Alright, what?
Oh, whoops.
Oh, through the hole!
I was so confused.
Okay.
There you go.
What the fuck?
What the fuck am I looking at?
Oh my god.
I got so nervous looking at that.
Because I was like, what the fuck am I looking at?
I didn't thread the needle.
More paths.
Excuse me?
What is that?
Yeah, I remember this.
This one's hard.
This one is the hardest so far.
Okay.
I don't even miss...
Yeah.
I had a feeling that...
That's fine.
No!
That's not fine!
I got comboed.
I got comboed by the bugs.
They comboed me.
That's illegal.
This area.
Bug on bug violence!
Only I'm allowed to Kill it!
I don't think I... Oh, I do.
That's good.
Oh!
I got too close.
Ah!
This is... This one's difficult.
This one's the most difficult out of all of them.
For sure.
Oh!
I was too...
Too low.
Oh my gosh.
That one was silly.
That one is silly.
Okay.
I think I'm doing pretty...
Oh!
I think for like my speed for it.
I don't think I'm doing too bad, though.
Are you serious?
I always get messed up on the last one.
I think for how fast I...
I think I'm doing pretty decent speed.
It's literally this.
This is like my current filter.
Oh my god.
Always that.
I always end up getting too close.
I get too close to it.
Okay.
Oh.
was close i
got comboed into it yeah
that was close
oh i'm trying to do it like i'm trying yeah i i try to cancel i try to cancel as fast as i could but it hit me against the spikes that's just unlucky
Okay.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
What do you do here?
Do I just crystal dash it?
Chat?
Holy shit, I could have touched the horns.
I got scared.
I was like, What's that?
What's that?
What's that over there?
I swear, if I fell all the way down after that, I would have been so sad.
I...
If it actually made me fall all the way down, I would have been so sad.
Did I do it?
Oh, okay.
Wow.
Okay, not gonna lie.
Wasn't as hard as I thought.
The normal one.
Hello?
No cost, too great.
What?
Father?
Papa?
Oh.
Do I just...
Oh, okay.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
I got it.
I got the thing.
The king saw.
Sola worm, Sola root.
Hide a void.
Okay, we did it.
We fucking did it.
Let's go.
Now back to the abyss.
Why the abyss?
Oh, okay.
Um, I got rid of that.
How much is it?
Holy shit!
okay um let's figure out how to do this
um i don't remember guys what the fuck were my load up guys i don't even remember what my load up was what's this holy charm symbolizing union between higher beings the barrel was slowly absorbed the limitless soul contained what opens the way to a bird now we're in try to shortcut Okay,
after we defeat, get the true ending.
We'll see how I feel.
Just have steady body.
Here.
Is that good enough?
Alright.
You don't need shaman stone.
Oh, you don't...
Oh, okay, I clicked the compass.
Okay.
I'll grab the compass.
But I have, like, extra stuff anyway.
And I'll grab Nognail.
Just for it.
I felt like I completed the parkour thing a lot faster than I expected.
Was that pretty fast for parkour?
I can't tell.
I did a lot of skips, too.
I didn't even realize I did skips.
I just assumed that was the right thing to do.
I legitimately just thought, oh, it should be this way.
I see a fucking platform up there.
Wait, what's this?
stone oh nothing i guess down i'll go
hello what's going on oh what the what where am i holy shit all these bodies are these my brothers why did you guys fail why were you failures Ow.
You guys weren't so failures, me, Mia.
Maybe you won't become empty husk.
Uh, ow.
Not good enough.
This is like a fucking maze.
I don't know where I'm going.
I'm gonna absorb real quick.
Okay, this way.
What?
That's me.
Oh, dream it.
Okay.
How's that?
Hello?
Knock, knock.
Oh, is that my egg?
No cost too great.
this egg is made for me I'm gonna blow my nose I'm not gonna mute myself that's me
my oh hello oh he's my babysitter y'all on holiday oh never mind I ate him I have consumed him What am I supposed to do?
Am I supposed to parkour?
Guys, what am I supposed to do?
Now we climb.
No mind the thing.
Oh, climb up.
Okay.
Where the fuck are the platforms?
I have to do the parkour again?
Just fucking parkour!
I can't believe it.
Back to parkour, I'll go.
No voice to cry suffering.
I literally just parkour.
Horn of God and void.
Oh, are these all the people that failed?
Climbing?
Just not as good as me.
Brothers.
Oh, hey!
Big brother!
i did it big brother come on
oh oh oh second place no prizes no winners for second place you shall see the blinding night that plagues their dreams you are the vessel You are the hollow knight.
I was the failure.
I can't believe it all along.
Time to go home.
Okay.
Who would have known?
Who would have thought it was me all alone?
Yeah, I'd like to see John Hollow Knight.
I'd like to see fucking Hollow Knight do the path of pain.
Oh, wait, they're not fighting anymore?
Oh, shit, you're right.
I do it not for self-defense.
But for fun.
Chill on this chase.
It's no...
I don't care that they're not fighting back.
You think I care?
I do it for the love of the game.
It's funny you think I care that they're not fighting back.
It's even better that they don't fight back.
Alright.
Oh Do you like to say that again?
No Okay,
this way No, I would like to not repeat myself a crazy statement
Oh, that's fine
Oh my god, I swear I've done the abyss so many times.
Oh my god, I could have used my TP.
I forgot.
Wait, where is my TP?
I could have used my TP this entire time.
Where is it?
I don't even know where my TP is anymore.
Oh my.
Oh, never mind.
Thank God I did not use my...
No, it's in the hive.
I would...
Imagine if I accidentally used my TP there.
I just like transported into the goddamn hive.
Thank God.
Alright.
It's time to do the...
Okay, before...
It's time to do the final boss.
Finally.
Wait, I have a new charm?
It's fine.
It's time.
What is it?
Oh.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Okay, I don't need compass.
We do Mark.
Uh, what else?
What is it?
Shaman stone?
What else?
What should we do?
We have two more.
Slug for fun?
No, we already have We have Mark of Pride Quick focus Let's quick focus
Dreamcatcher would be good Would it though?
Do I need that?
Do you want me to stack that?
What about Grub Song?
I can't do I can't I'm gonna do quick quick slash because I don't have enough.
I don't have enough for that.
Yeah, I don't have enough.
We'll just do this.
Alright.
Alright, now it's time for...
Let's put a portal here.
Just in case.
My left shop.
This shop?
Why?
Yippee, yippee!
Oh!
What's going on?
Oh, well?
So, another would join our group.
I have a gift for you, warrior.
As a shopkeeper, I admit, parting with me for free is very difficult.
As a great nail sage, I must recognize your skill.
The master they are in my remaining pupils.
Now, traditional decrees you too may hold.
Wait, what?
He's a nail sage?
You shall be the last to receive it's like...
What?
Bama.
Off you go.
I have nothing.
I'll be up briefly and eager to take your G and...
Oh my god!
That's a big-ass knife!
Holy shit.
He's Yoda?
How did you hold that knife?
Have a dream nailed him yet?
Valkyrie are much dead earlier.
I mean, he made a good choice swiping careers.
Nah, I don't use any of the nail arts.
I just go slushy slushy.
Oh.
Alright, we save here.
And now we go.
We finally fight the boss.
Holy shit.
It's finally time.
Oh my god.
It only took us seven hours.
I swear, it's the rock man.
The rock man is my hubris.
Okay, I'm gonna grab slippers because my feet's cold.
Okay.
Ready.
Ready to fight him.
Hey.
It's time.
You guys said I couldn't...
Oh, hey.
Hello again.
This path is open.
I won't be joining you in this.
Oh, wait.
I already talked.
Shiri said that before.
Okay, we do this again.
Let me grab...
Oh, wait.
I'm sorry.
It was here.
Let me grab a cough drop before I do this.
Wait, is my teleport still at the hive?
There you go.
Oh.
Oh, this guy.
All right.
No, she was.
I talked to her before.
I remember talking to her.
I remember.
She was like, I won't join you.
And I was like, why not?
Why won't you fucking help me?
Oh, she wasn't.
Whoops.
I'm level two now.
I never leveled up to level three.
Alright, I don't remember how to fight him You shall know the state Okay I legitimately don't remember his stuff
Hello This is bad Because I legitimately don't remember how to fight him Oh this is bad I legitimately don't remember oh
I mean that's good well that's not good oh okay now I remember this I remember this
oh nice oh shit what the fuck oh shit not cool
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Not cool, buddy.
Not cool.
Oh, nice.
I can heal from that.
I remember that I can heal.
Oh, now it's the Toho part.
Yeah, this is the part I didn't like.
Oh, whoops.
Oh, no, not the Toho again.
No.
Toho, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, get good okay okay I sleep now quiet snap time it's snap time oops okay oh okay I I get it.
I get it.
When can I heal?
Oh!
Not there.
Oh.
I'm dead.
Because I don't understand.
Oh!
That's unlucky.
I didn't understand.
Yeah, she does two hits.
I was confused.
Wee-ing.
Oh, I don't spin anymore.
Okay, let's do this again.
Oh.
Oh, that Pogo stuff.
I don't think I can do the...
I'm good.
Oh, what the fuck?
Okay, that...
Okay.
That was my bad.
That...
Oh.
That was my bad.
That was actually so bad.
I'm y'all, y'all, y'all, y'all, y'all.
I messed up.
Oh, I'm messing up.
Wow.
Whoops.
Hello.
Oh, no!
I'm messing up my timing.
Okay.
I was messing up my timing.
All right, I'll focus.
I'll hard focus.
Wow!
Why are you so far?
Okay.
There you go.
I'm just gonna eat first.
Okay.
Focus time.
Oh, no!
I forgot.
No!
I didn't mean to do that.
No, you threw off my group!
It threw up my group!
Wing spin!
Okay.
My spaghetti is falling everywhere.
Yeah, hard focus for real.
I swear, guys, I focus now.
What?
Oh,
no.
I faced the wrong way.
Okay.
I put down the...
No!
Fuck!
You threw up my groove!
I need to stop reading.
Reading is bad.
Reading was fat.
I'm yam yam yam yam yam yam yam yam yam yam.
I'm reading.
Sorry, I was reading chat on my phone.
That's why.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
How did he get so close to me?
Oh, unlucky.
I'm yam yam yam yam yam yam yam yam.
and drive.
Oh, what?
Not Toho.
Anything but Toho.
Okay.
Not Toho.
Please stop.
Stop Toho.
What the fuck?
Well.
Like this.
Oh!
He's scary!
Oh my god!
She's scary.
I have to look up.
Guys!
I'm not used to looking up!
Oh my god.
What?
But I have to be closer to the race.
Oh my god.
Okay, I get it.
I'm always, I'm too far.
I'm too far from my race.
Yeah.
I know now.
I was too early.
Okay.
This guy.
I feel like I can end this faster.
If I use more magic.
Not gonna lie.
Yeah, I'm gonna try and use more magic for him.
I'm just gonna try and end it faster.
There you go.
Oh, fuck.
What the fuck?
Okay.
That was a mistake there.
Kill it.
Sighten.
Okay.
Oh!
What?
Oh, I was not expecting a double.
Okay, that's good.
Okay.
There you go.
Toho time.
Oh!
Oh, never mind.
I get hit.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Oh, my God.
Oh!
My bad.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Oh fuck.
Okay.
Oh, this is bad.
Oh my god!
Yeah!
Holy shit!
Oh my god, that was hell!
That was actual hell!
I was...
Oh my god!
I was not ready for that hell.
I was...
Oh my god, you can tell...
Oh my... I'm a mess right now, sorry.
I went through a lot fighting that guy.
Actually, I'm a mess right now.
That fucky was...
crazy
i'm surprised how much i survived there Oh, oh, that's my bad What the fuck fuck up?
Again, holy shit.
You really like using that move Oh
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
I accidentally ran into him while I was trying to knife him.
That was awkward.
That was...
Oh, my God.
And then it's Toho.
I was not ready for Toho.
Squash.
Okay.
Oh, fuck.
I didn't expect him to do that.
Okay,
nice.
Oh, my God, again?
What the fuck?
Oh, the furthest...
The furthest bullet ever.
Bro, right?
Oh, shit!
That was an accident.
Okay, now it's...
Yeah.
Good!
Okay.
I will say that felt bullshit.
I can't...
Oh!
Radiance is hard.
Alright.
I'm, like, figuring her out.
Oh!
Unlucky.
Oh my god.
I'm just gonna do this real quick.
There you go.
Okay.
I hate the...
I hate the explosions.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh.
Alright.
I did not mean to do that.
Oh, but it's my favorite move.
Oh, it's my favorite move.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, that's my bad.
I got confused.
I got so confused.
Oh, nice.
Get good.
Get the!
Oh, my God.
Radiance.
Radiance time.
Where is she?
Yeah.
Now I know that's like a free shot.
Are you serious?
Oh.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Oh god.
I hate this!
Oh!
Are you serious?
That's so fucking bullshit!
That's so bullshit!
Oh, the laser spot.
I was doing so well.
I was doing so well, too.
The laser spawn fucked me up.
Oh.
He actually jumped this time.
I was not expecting...
I was not expecting the laser spawn.
Because the laser spawn was so bullshit.
Oh.
What the fuck?
Thank you.
Let me outer this corner.
I want me in the center.
There you go.
I can heal a little bit.
Oh, never mind.
Oh my god.
He's not...
What the fuck?
He's actually...
He's actually not letting me do anything.
Fuck, at least skip this first.
Oh my god.
He's actually not letting me, like, do anything right now.
He's input reading.
Fucking cheater.
Are you serious?
He's input reading me.
Okay.
Oh!
He's lazy!
He is cheating!
He actually spawned in front of me.
What a bitch.
Bullshit spawn.
Oh.
What the fuck?
I hit that perfect here.
There we go.
I'm just gonna heal just in case.
Oh.
That's unlucky.
He did the double.
fucking block.
I was expecting that.
Oh my god, he's parrying so much now.
He has not parried this much before.
Okay, but he has not parried that much before.
That's weird.
He has actually input reading me.
Fucking cheater.
He's actually input reading me.
I'm like, because you've never done that before?
What is this bullshit?
See, look at him!
He's actually endpoint reading me!
I'm like, where did that come from?
Alright.
That was a good dodge for me.
I was not even expecting that.
This should be soon.
There you go.
Let's get good time.
Get good!
There you go.
You show bullshit, though.
She's so fucking bullshit.
Holy shit.
That was my bad.
I rushed that.
Are you serious?
Like, someone...
That shit shows...
up i can't see it
i know that i'm not going to win this one but i still i just want to do it for practice at this point the spike showed up what she did lasers when there's spikes below me oh my god I got boxed!
I actually got boxed!
That was cheating.
That was actually- Oh my god, and then he jumps.
You never jumped before?
What the fuck is this?
He's gonna eat just in case.
Why?
I just stood next to him and was like, Hey, hello there.
Input reading, yes.
Oh
Okay There we go His fucking knee got me What the fuck?
That's bullshit How did his knee fucking get me?
Oh, okay, that's unlucky
Yeah, his fucking ass was apparently too strong for me.
Oh, that's unlucky.
Yeah.
Alright.
Come on.
It's...
Get good!
Back here again.
I'm back here.
Hello.
Hello, my queen.
I'm here to kill you.
God damn it.
I shouldn't have done that.
What?
Okay.
I...
Oh my god.
I hate...
I just got hit by everything.
I panicked.
I got hit by everything.
I don't know.
She was scary, okay?
Oh my god, it doesn't stop.
Now I'm getting hit by him.
It doesn't stop.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god.
That's supposed to be a Pogo.
Another one?
How many do you want to do?
Yes.
I'll just do this just in case.
I think I just parried that.
Did I not?
I'm just gonna heal a little bit.
And then...
There you go.
Hit.
Oh my god.
Fuck you.
Here's some magic.
Yeah, I did like three parries in a row.
That was crazy.
easy oh i his head apparently landed on me his head is just too big and strong my thing is super chat thing thank you good i got bonked by johnna's head oh i don't have any magic though maybe
What?
Three times?
Okay, I wasn't expecting three times.
Not gonna lie.
I'm gonna try and focus up here.
God.
Okay.
I'm actually so hard focused right now.
Oh.
Okay.
Because I know there's more than one phase.
That's the worst part.
I know he ain't...
Oh, thank god.
No!
No, are you fucking kidding me?
I have one life left.
Oh,
what?
What?
No, I didn't even see that!
I didn't even see the...
I didn't even see the orb.
The fact that they fight him again is annoying too.
Dude, I don't want to fight you.
Just let me fight her.
She's just tedious at this point.
You're stupid.
fucking head.
This stupid fucking head.
Uh.
Alright.
Munch munch.
Oh.
I used to waste in my...
I wasted my dash because I didn't think he was going to do that.
That was just my bad.
Okay.
That's good.
I actually needed a heal anyway.
Because I wasted my stuff.
Ah, I thought he was gonna do the slam.
It's just tedious.
Are you serious?
Are you?
Oh my god, dude, fuck you.
Actually, fuck you.
I'm just so impatient now.
I just realized he didn't even use that.
This is his first time.
Please, just scream.
There we go.
I was like, just scream.
I know it's over.
There we go.
Get good.
Oh my god.
I did it too early.
I hate this move the most.
That spawn army?
What?
That's the fucking soul.
thing spawned on me and it didn't even explode oh my god it went on me that was that was actually bullshit that was so bullshit holy fuck i didn't like that
Me no like he.
I hate the RNG part.
Oh.
Yeah, I can eat a little bit.
Okay.
Me no like the RNG.
What?
Oh my!
Well, I get hit by the last shot too.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
I miss when...
I miss when a Toho was that.
Oh!
Okay.
Clam!
Come on!
Yeah!
There we go.
I like time it now for the dream though.
Because I'm not patient no more.
Yeah.
Figure this out.
I hate you.
I hate you so much.
Oh my.
you.
Oh, I hate you.
Oh,
my God.
Okay.
Fucking course.
Oh, fucking course you did that.
Oh.
Okay.
Are you serious?
Are you... Oh, my God.
I'm like threading the needle right now Holy shit
I'm threading the needle for that
I'm stuck I'm stuck
Are you still?
That's so bullshit That's Oh my god That was so bullshit Like the ray and the sword too the ray and the sword welcome to hell yeah no that felt like fucking hell
that actually felt like hell well i had to whoops
like this
really that's so bullshit
There we go.
I'm just trying to do this as fast as I can.
Okay.
Okay, that's where he does his stabby stab.
I can do this.
Yeah, I can do this again.
That was a lot of damage that I just did.
Holy fuck.
Okay, I'm like stuck in the fucking corner of hell.
I was stuck down there.
I'm just gonna heal that.
Fuck this.
Oh my god, really?
Mr. Your scream.
There we go.
Oh, I tied the curtain clearly.
Get good!
Oh my god.
Welcome back.
I'm not gonna...
If I'm like in like these corners, I'm not gonna risk shooting up.
Because that...
I can accidentally...
Oh, are you serious?
Okay.
I'm focusing right now.
I don't have to.
I have to hard focus this.
Okay.
sucks when I'm like stuck in a area.
Oh my god.
Oh my what?
Why is this so bullshit right now?
No!
Uh I just saw like spikes below me.
Yeah.
This boss is extra bullshit.
because of the RNG.
The RNG of getting...
Yeah.
It's just the RNG is so bullshit sometimes.
And it's like, I can't avoid it.
Okay.
I'm just trying to make this part the fat, like, do it as fast as I can.
I just want to do this.
Oh my god, seriously.
That's unlucky.
Nice.
Oh!
A gas fucking head!
Okay, I'm rushing this part.
I should...
Okay.
Oh no.
It's bad.
I'm actually...
I'm fucking on this part when I shouldn't be.
Yeah, I might actually die on this phase.
At least chop yourself.
I actually do this then.
So I don't want to worry too much.
Mmm.
Any jumps?
He doesn't jump before.
Stupid input read.
Oh my god!
I hate how he's input reading me.
Nice.
Alright, there we go.
Let's get good, Tab.
Get good!
Oh, of course he starts with this.
Oh!
Oh, again?
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
He put me in the corner.
So I didn't know what to do.
I hate it.
I hate the double damage.
Are you serious?
Oh.
This is not looking good.
Nice.
She did it twice.
So nice.
Oh my god.
No.
It's not worth healing until...
Hit.
Try and lock in the best I can.
Okay.
I'm gonna lock in right now.
So I'm not gonna talk much.
That was an axe.
Oh, I got stuck in, like, the worst corner.
That sucks.
Oh, my God.
I was just in the worst place possible for this.
He hasn't used it in a while.
There we go.
We did it.
This is easy.
This one is easy.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh.
It was like frame perfect.
Die.
Are you serious?
No, not the solar balls.
Oh my god!
Oh no!
I was too slow.
I was so slow for that.
It's literally just RNG of which moveset she decides to use.
But even then...
Holy shit.
Even then, the hardest part is literally phase 2.
And maybe like...
If I get used to phase 1, I might be able to...
Oh my god, that's unlucky.
I'm also like scared of like...
Okay.
What the fuck?
How did I miss that?
Jesus Christ.
He was on my head.
There we go.
Oh, wait.
That was so unlucky.
Oh, my God.
I might actually die in this phase.
Are you serious?
Oh, my God, I'm going to die in this phase.
He jumped!
Oh my god, he jumped!
Holy shit.
He actually jumped!
I rushed it.
I'm getting impatient right now.
Okay, I'm gonna lock back in.
Starting now.
I'm just getting impatient.
There you go.
I'm gonna heal just in case.
Because I wanted to hit this time.
There you go.
This is the worst place for this.
This is the worst place for it.
Fine.
There you go.
Here you go.
Get the!
I'm just trying to be patient here because I want to know what move he's gonna use
it's actually bullshit when he does that again holy shit oh
my god
the RNG bro she's actually
like what what is this
oh there's no way i could have dodged that that's no way i actually got cheese there's no way you can dodge that she actually has like the most oh god yeah
that was actually such bad rng for me oh and then he Of course he jumps.
I swear to God.
That was like random bullshit time.
Nope.
I don't know how the fuck that happened.
Okay.
Just grab one and then...
Oh my god.
He bent forward so it didn't hit me.
What?
Oh
my god.
There we go.
This should be it.
Cool!
I just hate this one.
I just hate this move.
Hmm.
Of course.
A fucking course.
Oh my god.
Oh!
I couldn't live through that.
These lasers are so brutal.
Oh, these lasers are so brutal.
I'm dead here.
Oh my god.
I'm not.
I shouldn't use magic.
I fucked up by using magic there.
Oh, I got greedy.
I got greedy.
Uh.
I got really greedy there.
Whoops.
I don't know if I should use magic when she does the constant sword thing.
Because I get punished for it too much.
How do I miss that?
Sometimes I don't know where that is.
Oh my god.
And sometimes he jumps, Ren.
I'll just eat.
Just for the sake of it.
Oh.
All right.
I mean, sure.
I'll take that.
What?
Okay.
I see.
He should be.
It should be soon.
There we go.
Yeah.
Yeah, I know.
Exactly.
I was like, what the fuck was that?
This is a long...
This is a long stream.
I think I'm just getting really bad RNG too.
I think that's what's happening.
My RNG has been so bad for these...
Okay, hard focus.
Oh my god, like this.
Like this.
Just like that.
Like, oh my god.
I...
That was so bullshit.
Because that ball focused on me.
It focused on me.
It threw me off.
Hmm.
It hard threw me off there.
I got the grouper this guy, though.
It's okay, Edgar.
I got this.
Oh, what the fuck?
Nice.
Alright.
Oh,
I had no hit until he fucking slammed his head against me.
That's...
Okay, that's cool.
I like how I went no hit until then.
oh my god now i'm getting hit all the time oh my god now i'm getting all the hit he actually threw me up
stupid head i know it's doing so well too
oh that was like one second too fast hollow knight learn head oh i don't even have the spell that's so i'm gonna do this right now.
That's it.
That's my fault.
I messed up.
Okay.
Oh.
I can't believe it.
I can't get out of there.
I got the face too really fast with that, though.
I got a face...
actually got to the not phase two um is that phase two when he does the middle i don't know i don't know if that's considered phase two
sometimes it doesn't hit the hitbox for him is so slow oh phase two is when the okay i got to like the phase where oh Whatever phase it is When she starts hitting the middle I got that Oh, that's unlucky
Oh It's fine, I'll heal a little bit
Stupid headbutt And then he randomly jumps That's cool And then he randomly toe-hose me That's cool too Oh
I hate it when he does that headbutt!
Am I dying in this phase?
And, uh, just grab one.
There, fuck it.
Oh, I thought he was gonna scream.
There we go.
Fuck.
Alright.
Yeah, I am.
I am getting too impatient, though.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh!
I just hate it when they spawn in.
Of course.
My last HP.
Holy shit.
I hate her.
I hate her so much.
No, I did.
I drank water.
I can hydrate in.
Oh my god.
Am I winning?
When will this nightmare end?
That's a good question.
Yeah.
Oh, I was unlucky.
I was not expecting that.
She's stupid fucking ass!
This booty!
This booty actually...
Oh, unlucky.
I'm just gonna heal a little bit.
Mmm.
Oh my god.
This pattern has been like, changing.
Damn.
I actually need heal though.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh my god.
I'm worried that he's gonna headbutt me.
I'm trying to make sure he doesn't headbutt me.
Okay, there you go.
Oh.
fear of the head but okay here again oh my god even my master phase one I still have phase two I
was not expecting that
oh I didn't expect that either
okay again
oh my on again what
the fuck
oh I
don't know if that was bullshit or not but it felt bullshit I will say that felt so bullshit oh I only have 4 HP I I... This is not it.
This is not it.
Wait, where is she?
Oh my god.
I don't know what to do for that.
I...
I got the phase two though.
I got a phase two!
Oh, what the fuck?
Why did you jump?
What the fuck?
And what a phase two it was.
I'll just heal a little bit.
If you nailed down, if you hit nailed down, you would jump on it dealing more damage.
Is that true?
Do I have to hit?
Wait.
Am I pogo on him?
more damage is that true or is he one guy yes okay i'll do that then
he stabs right yeah
one guy okay who was it because one of the one i saw like three people that was like yeah no it's totally true i saw like one person that was trying to back him up too It was like, no, that's so true.
He's like, yes, I saw you.
I saw you said yes, too.
Don't think I did it.
Give him the same punishment.
Oh, what the fuck?
Alright.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I went too early.
No!
The laser.
Are you serious?
I got...
Oh, he boxed me in.
She actually boxed me in.
Holy shit.
I feel like I'm getting the most unlucky.
unlucky.
Shit ever.
The RNG is so unlucky.
It's very hard to heal in this, but sometimes this doesn't work.
I'm just not gonna do it when he gets done like that.
Like, what the fuck?
Leave me alone.
Oh, yeah.
It's just It's just too tight The The room to heal
Now I know why this is the hardest boss
Don't hit by me Oh
Oh of course that hits me Oh my god he's not even It's not done yet
Are you serious?
Get me out of here
It should be the yellow now.
It's just the fact that it's so RNG when she does.
Oh.
It's so RNG.
Like whatever moveset she decides to use.
Oh.
I thought that was...
That was close enough.
I hate these ones.
Of course that hits me!
I feel like I dodged everything, but I...
Ah, yes!
Please.
That's crazy.
Oh!
Oh, shit!
Okay, that's not legal.
That shouldn't be legal.
That actually shouldn't be legal.
What she just did there.
Holy shit!
This would be if I'm getting the worst RNG possible.
Did I hit me?
I can't tell.
I guess she hates me.
Bro, I hate her too.
I also hate her.
Don't worry.
Oh, and then she starts off.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I also hate her.
How many orbs was that?
chat how many orbs does she throw yes how many how many
that was cruel that was actually so cruel
okay i missed
I'm just gonna try and get to get out of this phase as fast as I can.
I need to stop using that when she's doing this.
Oh, well, looks fine.
There you go.
I don't know why I keep doing that.
It doesn't work for that.
I need to remember it.
Okay, and then I back up.
Because I don't want to get hit, but oh, I guess.
Okay, and then back up.
Should be close to...
Oh, that's fine.
I think it's close.
He almost has no HP.
Come on, yell.
There you go.
Oh, I could tell when they're...
There is no way I am dodging in time with the fucking slug, and you guys know it.
She hates me.
She knows that that's okay.
I hate her too.
Oh my god.
I just didn't have time to react there.
And again.
That's fine.
And again, that's fine.
And again.
Oh, and then, oh, spikes.
There we go.
That's fine.
Oh, and again.
Okay, oh, and...
Give me a sec.
I'm gonna...
Oh, I need angry peed.
I'm done angry peed.
Many of that.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm done angry peeing.
Oh my god.
She's actually only using Orbs on.
Like, I swear to God.
She's input reading me.
Because she knows.
She knows how much I fucking hate that move.
I swear.
She is input reading me.
I refuse to believe anything else.
Oh.
That's unlucky.
Doesn't.
Okay.
Cheating it.
Alright.
Okay, and then I don't want him to headbutton me.
Oh!
Uh, nice read.
Now they're all input reading me.
Oh, stupid headbutt.
Oh my god.
Wait, I might die to this moon.
I'm rushing it a lot.
Yeah, I'm going to die to this one.
Ah.
I rushed that.
I was impatient.
I was impatient there.
I got toe-hoed.
I knew I was going to get toe-hoed.
I can't help it.
I just want to get reach-beated all the time.
Okay.
I think that one was a bit boring.
shit because like his y'all stalked me while i'm trying to like what the fuck was i supposed to do there
oh that's unlucky i'm rushing okay okay i got the skip what's the skip i'm rushing now
okay yeah i lock in yeah i'm rushing it to be fair i could be doing the pap papapay that is true i could be doing that right now but when i win it'll be so sweet oh
my god he almost actually got me there
hit unlucky
all right this is where he's stabs himself.
So I can do this.
I can do this again.
And then I can heal one bite before he head-spots me.
I just don't want to get head-butted.
Is that true?
Using magic in the beginning makes it more aggressive?
Nope.
I guess we'll never know.
so it's like oh my god i'm getting distracted oh i looked at chat sorry um it's like that you know when you put the when you uh when you do the left and right trigger on in pokemon so that the pokemon pokemon would catch the pokemon faster thank you thank you for the super chat stop what do you mean i was asking you guys if it's true because he super chatted it
That's why I asked if it was true!
Damn, Edgar.
I'm sorry.
Chad's calling you a liar.
Sorry, Edgar.
I guess I can't do it.
Because Chad called you a liar.
Try it.
Edgar, I can't.
You got downvoted by the chat.
Or like A-B, say, I'm, look, I'm, I'm going through a lot right now, so I'm not really paying attention anymore.
Oh my, I, who will pass him, because I'm reading chat.
I'm reading chat now.
While mid-fight.
I don't even remember what my build was.
It's been so long.
I've been fighting him for so long.
build was oh
a fucking court this is oh god
this goddamn stupid head
me out get me out of here um yum yum yum yum oh
what the fuck holy shit okay okay are you done
What the fuck?
That was crazy.
Like, what the fuck did I see there?
Yeah, it was blocking forever.
This is the worst spot to be.
Honestly.
A fucking horse.
I'll just steal one more.
Just in case.
Whoops.
There we go.
Now we're back here.
Oh fuck.
Even though I mastered this phase, like I said.
It's literally...
Okay.
Oh, I don't even want...
I can't talk anymore.
Okay.
Oh my god, I was like, oh my god.
That's close.
Okay.
Oh my god, I hate these.
I couldn't have another, I don't have another dash.
Oh.
There's this phase though.
I have to dodge that shit, what the fuck?
Oh my god.
Oh my.
That's impossible.
Oh my god.
I got scared.
He spawned in front of me.
What can I say?
He spawned in front of me and sent out this goddamn, like, spikes.
I don't know if I could have dodged that.
Oh.
That's unlucky.
I got trapped in the corner.
I don't like being in the corner.
Hmm.
I need to remember I can only do one in there.
How could I...
How could I have dodged it?
When he spawned there.
That's fucking fine.
Hmm.
I need to...
Not...
I need to not rush that.
I'll heal.
Just coming out.
Okay.
Hit.
Alright.
Come on.
Oh, fuck.
Um, that's bad.
I have no power-ups.
Maybe I could get one hit, I think.
Okay, there you go.
Now I have it.
Okay.
What?
That's my bad.
I risked, I fucked that up.
Alright, okay.
Oh, okay.
Two, four, six, seven.
Okay, I have seven HP.
For this.
Just not gonna...
Okay.
I'm trying to free up.
Wait,
oh my, oh my god.
Don't poke up, but what about Eddie?
He told me to poke.
No, not Eddie.
Not Eddie.
What about that guy?
That's not Eddie.
Who was the guy that was like, you should poke up them.
Uh.
Oh, it gets rid of the spider.
Oh my god, sorry, I'm reading chat.
Sorry, I'm gonna read...
Ah, fuck it, let's just do it.
Let's just commit to it.
Fuck it, I don't really care.
Let's commit to it.
There we go.
Boogin is really high risk.
Okay.
Sorry, I'm like reading chat too.
Alright.
MJ, thank you for the magenta soup, buddy.
Thank you.
Alright.
It's fine.
The build is fine.
It's not the build.
issue.
It's not, I don't think it's a build issue.
I don't think we could do anything that's different.
Honestly.
Okay, no chat reading, no chat reading while we're fighting.
I realize whenever I reach chat, I like fumble it.
Like right now.
No chat reading when I'm fighting him.
I'm sorry.
I usually do when I'm fighting the bosses, but I want to get this over with.
I've been reading chat every time I fight bosses, but this is the one time where I'm like Okay, maybe I should stop reading the chat.
I'm doing I'm still reading chat by the way, but It's just happened Okay This is the one boss where I think I can't read chat I say as I I'm still reading chat every time you see me look right that's me
Oh, again.
Okay.
Again.
Alright.
Oh, my god.
And again.
Yeah.
And then you get headspot.
Alright.
Good.
Oh, I saw I had my dash.
That's unlucky.
Holy shit.
He's doing that.
I know, Doki, if you're reading...
God damn it!
I can't open!
I'm so used to reading chat!
Okay.
Yeah!
I can't help it.
No one would know that I'm...
We know now.
I saw what you typed in my chat.
What?
Oh,
what?
Oh, I thought I didn't hit me.
Okay.
Oh, I tried to do the...
Oh, I'm dead.
Uh, I tried to dodge.
Oh.
Okay, okay, guys, we gotta...
Oh, my God.
We gotta beat it in.
It's three hours.
Because I'm not doing a part two.
We got...
Oh.
I'm hard-focusing.
Hmm.
I don't know why I couldn't pull that.
Okay, that was a mistake.
That was me being greedy.
Okay.
Oh.
Don't go too early.
What?
Okay.
Weedy.
Don't help but me please.
What?
Please cut-
Oh, I was gonna say please stab yourself.
Ugh.
Okay, I always get greedy Because I just want to get to the last boss as fast as possible Weedy no good.
I'm sorry Can't help it
Okay Fucking head hit me Oh my god,
this fucking helmet touched me
No headbutt
Nice.
I need him to stab himself.
Oh, I didn't need...
Random jump!
Please scream.
Please start screaming.
There we go.
Nice.
You screamed.
Get good.
Oh.
Oh, gosh.
There you go.
Stop!
I request you to stop!
Oh, my God.
Of course.
There you go.
Please stop.
Not cool.
please stop you don't like it
where is she oh oh my god I didn't see that
can you like fucking TP me can you TP me closer to you
Oh, now you TP closer!
Fucking bitch.
She's too far.
She too far.
Why are you so far?
Holy shit!
And then she TP's in front of me.
All right.
That's cool.
I still have to got to understand phase three, too.
I still have phase three to understand after this.
This is a wild...
I went off of this wild ride.
Not gonna lie.
I hate it.
Damn.
I think she would do double dash.
Oh, okay, that was just, that was a mistake.
He's too far.
I'll just heal.
I don't want to just mess up.
Oh.
Okay.
Okay, because I know he's got a headbutt after that.
Alright.
That was short.
At least the music is fun.
to listen to.
Thank God.
Oh, stupid headbutt.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Now off to the other phase.
Yay!
Get good!
Oh.
Are you...
Okay.
That was my bad.
Oh, man.
I wish she was closer to me.
Oh my god.
I didn't know what to do there.
I don't know how to dodge that.
Oh, nice.
Okay, that's good.
Alright, that gives me not a lot of HP, but that's okay.
That's okay.
Yippee.
Oh my gosh.
Just a lonely grub.
Trying to understand.
okay okay
we're fine no we're not fine oh are you serious holy shit
no lazy
lazy Laser ball combo.
Wow.
Laser ball combo.
I will say that was indeed bullshit.
Hmm.
Oh.
There you go.
Whoa.
It's a lot of jumping.
Wow, okay.
I'll just beat a little bit.
The headbutt here.
Toho in this tiny spot.
Why the fuck not?
I need to remember to...
Okay, there you go.
Okay.
Yeah, good.
Good, good.
Hippie-pie.
I'm just trying to get good.
That's good.
Oh my god, that's so unlucky.
Oh.
You did not spot in front of me.
Why did that spot in front of me?
Scotty thank you I'm committed we I've hit my I've hit my wall I thought I thought the fucking mantis was a wall no this is definitely this is definitely the biggest wall 100% it's
the two down damage is the plus two I think it's because it's plus two it fucks with me so much
I honestly think because like I'm okay with all the bosses that have only done like plus one I've like not struggled at all
oops uh-huh
maybe it's time to play play Dark Souls like yeah to get to bring Dark Souls.
I'll heal here just in case.
All right.
We die here.
I'm swapping skins.
It's time.
I'm swapping to the lock-in skin.
Do we die here?
I'm swapping to lock-in skin.
Oh, timing correctly.
Yippee yippee
Oh I mistimed that That's my bad I hate that I hate that mini one The mini jumps fucks with me so much Oh my god
I don't think we're doing this one
I barely have any HP Oh
Alright it's time to bring him out This is the Dark Souls of Metrovania.
Praise the sun.
Get over here.
It's time.
It's time to praise the sun.
Wait, who the fuck is he?
Oh, shit.
Wait a minute.
Why does he look different, too?
Oh, shit.
I'm not used to that.
Oh, my God.
This changes everything.
this actually changes everything I don't know how to fight him when he looks different holy shit wait I ain't ready what who is he oh my god oh my god I don't
this oh my god i'm not okay right now i was not expecting him to be different too
guys maybe we're not gonna praise the sun maybe
maybe we're not oh my god yeah most likely we're not Now that...
Oh my god, I swear to god, if she also looks different, too.
Alright.
I was like, where did he...
Who the fuck let his guy in my fucking house?
I don't even know who this guy is!
That's the worst part!
Oh, whoops.
There we go.
Is she also going to look different, too?
Get done!
All right.
Okay, no, she looks the same.
Okay, that's good.
That's actually good.
Oh, my God.
I couldn't praise the sun.
That, that, like, literally, that's, they set up, like, the perfect thing for me, too.
Oh, my God.
I didn't even realize that still existed.
Oh my
god.
Okay.
Alright.
That's cool.
Sure.
Sure, let's do this again.
I don't mind.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh!
Wait, I did no hit!
Let's go!
Praise the sun!
I actually did know it.
I don't know how.
I don't know, man.
I don't know.
Oh my god.
I don't know if that hit him.
I can't tell.
Oh, fucking curse.
Where's that?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Who's that coming from?
I-
Okay, cool.
That's actually the closest I've ever got.
And I did no hit.
I did no hit run too.
That was the closest.
I just gotta deal with this guy.
He looks different.
Let's do the fact that he doesn't look the same no more.
Even though that, like, fucks with me.
Alright.
Okay, you should do the stat.
Yeah, this.
Oh, what?
Okay, I don't know how that messed up.
That was a weird thing to mess up.
Okay, I know that that else I can also do that
It Oh, there we go
We're good
Okay All right
Get good
Oh my god, they didn't see that That was scary That was actually scary.
That was so cheeky.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
That's okay.
Oh.
That's fine.
That means I can heal.
Getting my Estes flask ready.
Phase two.
Yay!
I had a feeling.
I knew he was gonna do that.
Anyone that does, like, no hit run for this?
Okay, wild.
Stronger than me.
Okay.
There was... I couldn't.
He comboed me perfectly.
He comboed me.
so perfectly.
Oh, no, TikTok.
I didn't think I'd be playing Hollow Knight for nine hours.
But only because of this particular box.
I think the moment I figure her out, like, it'll be so fast.
Oh, sorry, I'm just...
Oh, what the fuck?
He's doing, like, all the weird shit.
There you go.
Why are you being weird?
Oh, shit.
Okay, now I'll do the...
This, and I'll just do this.
Alright.
Again.
Oh, my god!
Stupid headbutt!
Like, I said, why?
you being weird oh
my god i have to get him before he screams no i have a feeling that was yeah i had a feeling we finished it good get good good i ain't no quitter oh i did not realize that there was an extra i did not realize
My bad.
Eh.
Oh, my God.
That was my bad.
Are you serious?
Ah, my dash.
Yeah, I don't think I'm living through this.
I don't think I'm living through this one.
I messed up too many times.
There you go.
I don't know.
I don't know, Matt.
I didn't drink my Estes.
Oh my god, your stupid fucking orb shit!
Oh my god, and then she TP's to the other side.
I fucking, because of course she did.
I fucking, of course she did.
I fucking course she did.
TP near me, please, woman.
Call your loved ones.
We're not leaving here.
We thought we were gonna stay forever on the rock boy.
No, this is where we'll die.
Call your loved ones.
It's time.
Tell them you're not seeing home anymore.
That little jump though, when he does, it's so sad.
Oh my gosh, I'm actually, I should do, I'm gonna do a rerun of this.
Ah, fuck it.
Let's just see how, how far it takes us.
Might not be worth, yeah, it's not worth it.
That's not worth that.
I don't know why I'm hitting I'm hitting a ceiling on this one I'm hitting a wall on this every other boss like yes some of the bosses were hard but holy fuck this boss This boss is ridiculous.
This boss I'm actually struggling so hard.
There's something about him.
Or about her.
Did I do it?
No, it's this thing.
Okay.
Oh, that's unlucky.
Oh.
Didn't mean to hit that.
Hit.
Ground slam.
I think he's gonna...
Yeah, there he is.
I wasn't gonna use my magic.
Oh!
Keep mistiming that one.
Okay, I can do two magic attacks here.
This is worse than grinding for top 5.
I don't know.
100%.
Oh my god that's so cheeky that's actually so cheeky holy shit I'm a little myth that he did that
that is actually bullshit
Oh my god oh my god he's actually like
He's toying with me.
I don't know if I have enough.
I don't have enough.
I only have enough for three.
That's so bad.
Oh, I thought that wasn't gonna hit.
That's so unlucky.
I don't know if I'm getting better or not.
phase two i can't tell i can't tell
but i'm no quitter i will be where radiance whatever her fucking name is i don't even she's not even you know i don't even care you know what she don't matter to me that's how did i care for her i'm not even gonna remember her fucking name Fuck you.
That's right.
That's when you know I don't care.
You don't matter to me.
Not even a bot to remember your name.
Whoops.
I didn't think that was going to happen to me.
Actually, I'm just going to drink one, actually.
I feel like that's going to be appropriate.
Oh.
That's unlucky.
He didn't drink another one.
Okay.
Jesus.
Nice.
Okay, I got, I got, uh, a few energy for that.
You're good.
Why can't you help me fight him too, so solid?
Honestly, he's not, okay, never mind.
I was gonna say, at least it's not the energy, what?
I spoke too soon.
Oh my god!
Yay!
Okay, nice.
Oh, I get, like, one foot here.
Thank god.
Oh, oh.
Oh
It's not fair
Oh my god, wow, thank you for
letting me hit you one time.
What an honor.
Wow, thank you.
Oh my
god.
Not the balls.
That's it, I'm looking at my build.
I'm looking at my build.
Okay.
I can't.
Whoever fucking suggested me lie now.
I don't like it.
That's it.
I've actually finally looked at my build.
I can't.
I can't do it.
I can't anymore.
That's it.
We're doing this.
I'm done bashing my head against that wall.
Two hours.
I have two hours left.
Oh, whoops.
Does he even get hurt by this?
I can't
tell if he does, honestly.
I don't think he does.
Holy shit, he's having a fun time.
That's for sure.
I don't think he is.
Wait, is he actually getting hurt?
I can't tell.
Does he actually get hurt by it?
Stinky?
He doesn't?
Okay, but...
he is okay that's good enough for me I don't care if it does one damage that's good enough I don't care that's good enough for me
honestly one damage is good enough one is better than nothing
I don't even remember what I removed oh I nailed it
Oh, whoops.
Oh, what the fuck he jumped?
That was my bad.
I was trying to do that.
It's just out of reflex.
Drink this.
It's just...
Okay.
No head buff for you.
Alright.
If I land in my aura, that's right.
Land in my aura.
Nice.
All right, see?
Land in it.
I don't know if she gets affected by it, but I'll try.
Please, can you come down so you can go into my aura?
Okay, that's good that she flew next to it.
Thank fucking god.
Oh, fuck, that's bad for me.
What is she?
You don't fuck it.
I knew...
I had enough.
I was like, fuck it.
Praise the sun.
Keep praising!
I just gotta keep praising the sun!
I got such good RNG.
Oh, and then I jinxed myself.
Peep.
What?
Oh my god.
Okay.
That's not fair.
Oh my god.
I wasn't even trying for that one.
Oh shit.
Attack.
I didn't realize I had a quick time event.
I hit with my aura.
I did it with.
I wasn't even trying.
I did it with aura.
around because I was just so tired.
The power of aura.
Oh my god, I survived.
I can't.
I was gonna unequip it after this.
Praise the sun.
Praise the fucking sun.
Now I'm John Holland.
Now I'm John Dark Souls Knight.
Oh, stinky rage.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guess how many hours did he took that Radiance took me?
That was the best RNG I could ever get on Radiance.
Three hours.
Oh my god, we did it.
Oh, that one.
I don't know what the average time is in killing Radiance.
Was that bad?
I had the smoothest cell.
I swear, I felt like everything was so smooth until Radiance.
And then Radiance was where I...
I hit the wall.
Three out.
Oh, thank God.
It's normal.
Oh, my God.
That's all that mattered.
You're right.
I killed him.
That's all.
I swear.
I had, like, even the parkour.
It was not that difficult.
Oh, my God.
The parkour.
I felt like the parkour.
I, like, cruise through.
easily um i've only like struggled like in one or two spots but after like i figured like i figured it out it was so easy and then but this the radiance state phase two was actually so hard because he did not let me breathe once yeah i almost climbed died during the climb yeah jade thank you the super chat thank you no I'm ready for silk song.
I was not expecting it to.
Because tomorrow's sleeping dog stream is going to be a short stream.
Maybe like two hours.
Dream.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I didn't heal.
There was no time to heal.
Oh.
I felt like I was getting very unlucky with her RNG.
Her RNG was like...
like so bad it was so hard yeah oh it was so fucking hard no there was no time there i don't know what time there's no time no time to explain no time i was just very unlucky i'll think about it i think about path of pain after Silk Sign.
I'll think about it after.
I'm just happy I got the true ending.
It felt like a filler episode trying to get everything to even...
Like, I felt like the parkour was such a small segment out of everything.
I was, like, most worried about the parkour.
But in the end, it was everything else.
That was so...
high yeah it was actually everything else that was so difficult
oh i'm so happy i'm so happy i wasn't expecting that run to be to be the um to be the actual run 81 there we go there you go 22 hours for true ending oh my god i'm so happy it's over i'm gonna rest now thank you everyone thank you thank you everyone i'm so happy we beat we beat halloween night with the true ending you guys didn't think i could do it you're like you guys you but i i was determined i was so determined i never give up never give up I knew we could do it If I bash my head against the wall Hard enough and frequently enough Eventually the wall will start breaking If you brute force enough A hole will eventually appear And then I win I won't win And we did it with aura Chat We did it with aura That's my subinoshi.
That's right.
Anyway, I'm gonna head off now.
Congratulations to anyone that has watched me for 10 hours straight.
I'm sorry.
But thank you all for watching.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you suffer me, head to bed.
You deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.